foreign
[Music]
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
because I've arrived when it's the only
option second is
[Music]
foreign
on this back
brush it down
next
I'll be strong
[Music]
Corners down
foreign
[Music]
surprising as I've seen myself
thank you
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends all
born in the myths are forever when they
pan our Lord I hear every Echo inside of
the world clear I feel all the hopes
inside of the same fear shadows in the
same years when they tell us that it's
gone but y'all I'm still here
[Music]
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
because I've arrived when it's the only
option second is
[Music]
foreign
keep aching My Voice keeps on my soul
keeps Rising as I sing
[Music]
rush it down
next I'll be strong
[Music]
Corners down
here we go
[Music]
Michael
Myers
[Music]
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths are forever when
they've been our Lord I hear every Echo
inside of the world clear I feel all the
hopes inside of the same fear shadows in
the same years when they tell us that
it's gone but y'all I'm still here
[Music]
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
you can't believe
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song I can hold myself
and reinforce whether that is
beat down this is the rebound our
systems go
Discover right when it's the only option
second is
[Music]
defensive practical this is the
beginning imagine your boy you're level
two my brothers
[Music]
sure
When The War now
[Music]
the worm evolution and this ain't my
final form
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
[Music]
I'll be strong prove myself
I'm still here
Corners down
[Music]
here we go
foreign
[Music]
around the world
foreign
[Music]
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my songs
[Music]
defensive practical this is the
beginning imagine your boy you're level
two my brothers
[Music]
sure
War not Jaws on the floor
has been feared like art on the wall
[Music]
s
but my heart keeps strong though
[Music]
run this back
brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
I'm still here
[Music]
foreign
here we go
[Music]
Christmas
foreign
[Music]
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
you can't believe
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
because I've arrived when it's the only
option second is
[Music]
better keep them if I'm Evolution's
constant and this ain't my final form
[Music]
my voice
I'm fine
[Music]
here we go
my voice
[Music]
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths are forever when
they've been our Lord I hear every Echo
inside of the world clear I feel all the
hopes inside of the same fear Shadows
defeated all of the life in the same
years when they tell us that it's gone
but yo I'm still here
[Music]
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing
[Music]
music
deep nipple this is the beginning
imagine your boy you're level two
bread and the trenches so coming against
us is utterly senseless
[Music]
revered like art on the wall
and this ain't my final form
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
alone
everything
[Music]
here we go
through Ninja Turtles
foreign
[Music]
soccer
[Applause]
in Las Vegas
a better Grand final test
[Music]
[Applause]
show
hello everybody and welcome to the
evolution Champion series 2023 what's up
out there everybody
all right
this thing ever loses presented by
Chipotle thank you very much for the
sponsorship Jim yeah we're here live in
Las Vegas at the Mandalay Bay where
thousands and thousands of fighting game
fans are here to not only celebrate but
to also compete in their favorite
fighting games with that said let's
actually get on to our first panel can I
please welcome to the stage kimone see
rosawa say Ichi yoshihora from French
bread to the stage everybody Give It Up
[Applause]
thank you
guys
uh
hello this is from French bread
my name is
designer thank you
foreign
[Music]
ER for the day
um it is a pleasure to be here
okay so
um
oh this place is getting hotter hotter
by the second
so okay
um
all right so come on let's talk about
let's talk about why you're here today
just talking about why I'm here today hi
do you see them
because it's the 10th anniversary of
undernight in birth right overflow
so everyone thank you all for playing
and supporting under 9th in birth
any comments for you know 10th
anniversaries
so here's the illustration by himself
so I uh so we've uh actually draw this
illustration just for this occasion uh
and I've I've done my best to actually
uh done my best to make the illustration
to commemorate the 10th anniversary
okay
so the basic point of the point of this
illustration is that Hyde's height skill
is actually drawing the number 10 on the
illustration so that's the that's the
point that um I have actually uh put my
point on when I'm driving when I draw I
try to draw this illustration
yeah
this is an amazing illustration so round
of applause again
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
this is his first time in Evo
foreign
so he's out he's being surprised by all
the people around here giving Round of
Applause
so by looking at the crowd how do you
think uh how do you feel
oh the sheer scales the sheer scale is
amazing
I mean this sure scale kind of kind of
gives me this uh you know pressure that
you know which you know makes me be
purely amazed
so
um to commemorate this 10th anniversary
there is something right
so there is something for you
there is something
I have a big news
oh
this is the first okay
is that right you guys ready
roll the tape
roll the clip
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
there you have it folks the world
premiere of undernight in birth 2.
[Applause]
so this is the first the world reveal
first revealed for underneath in birth
to Sister sellers
foreign
[Applause]
we are so happy that we're we were able
to show this to to you guys in such a
big big scale so I'm very happy and I'm
really appreciating that moment right
now
so as you've seen in the trailer we are
going to reveal the trailer on uh we're
going to reveal uh release the game on
early to uh 2024.
please look forward to it
[Applause]
all right so
um
come on I have a question hi
so what's new in this game can you talk
briefly about it
foreign
characters in action and all the you
know
well some unseen characters as well but
you know well if you think do you
haven't you think that the illustrations
are a bit new
so we've changed the number of a number
of the game to you know for him from you
know basically nothing to two
um so we're making a sequel so we're
we're making big changes as well
foreign
so we have a new story as well
it's been 10 years in the making and it
is moving forward
[Applause]
foreign
as well
so we're keeping what what's good for
100 nights uh on the night in birth and
we're also going to add and introduce
new system to actually you know excite
things up for the game
foreign
game will include rollback Neko
[Applause]
oh it was really difficult you have to
know that
yeah
I'm so happy that we were able to reveal
that today
all right then oh now we've revealed the
new game we would like to hear some
comments from your Shahara song as well
uh
height
s
thank you for all your support and
playing because of that we were able to
you know uh we really uh we were able to
reveal the sequel today
so thank you so much for your support
so we have a couple of you know uh old
illustrations ready to show if that is
actually available
okay
so this is actually the concept I wrote
underneath in birth so let's talk about
that a bit
um
foreign
so this is a rough sketch of what is the
new you know the character image you've
seen in the trailer it's also going to
be used in game so before we actually
you know finalize the illustration this
is the rough that we've uh designed uh
designed to you know choose what kind of
um
stance that the character will be
actually taking on the new illustration
hi
foreign
and
um we've thought of many you know
iterations of illustration and poses uh
but you know
um I thought that if it is a heroin
character it should be you know shown up
front so um we decided to go with it
upfront uh pose with the character
all right that's amazing so
um if that's the case
no so this is the illustration that's
been you know taken care of
[Music]
um
so the left side of the illustration is
the is is the
um is a rough image that's just before
the complete uh before completion and
after a couple of you know
um a couple of more you know process we
have uh the right side the illustration
on the right side is the completed image
all right so uh of course there are you
know many characters that you can look
forward to for you know new new
characters I guess
so you can definitely look forward to
other characters new illustration as
well
all right so let's look at the new
illustrations that's coming on on screen
right now
foreign
[Music]
but uh we again we've tried to uh try to
uh think of a different pose for oriya
as well but
this is God
however
but uh as you can see the pose in
question is actually way too wide to
actually implement it in game so
unfortunately we had to change it to a
different pose
so the illustration on the right side is
actually the one that you uh one that
we've decided to you know work on
it
so same as Renee so the one on the left
is just before completion and after for
uh further process the right side is the
completed version of the illustration hi
hi
[Music]
so as we've just seen in the
illustration there was something or
someone behind the illustration right
foreign
[Music]
so the illustration behind the character
is actually an image of what the user uh
what the what the character will
actually hold on to and fight and you
know what kind of skill the character is
using so the this is the image that all
characters will have on their character
select screen behind the actual
character
foreign
for all characters that
um for new uh we we would like we wanted
to illustrate uh the way you know the
characters uh how characters fight and
what kind of weapon uh and Arsenal uh he
or she has for the character uh for the
uh for the gameplay uh we wanted the
newcomers and
um other fighting game players to
actually join in under 9 in birth and
you know recognize what uh recognize or
you know guess on what kind of gameplay
that the character would have
that's all for orier
all right let's go for enkidu
a
um
you've seen two rough sketch of two
poses for enkido as well but again
um we've decided to go with the right
side of the illustration
foreign
I thought the pose was amazing
and it really really looked great but
the problem is
his tattoo on the right side of his
right side of his shoulder
it can't be seen on the screen so
um well we thought the pose was great we
decided to go on with a different pose
so again this is the uh this is the
illustration foreign
left just before completion and a couple
of more process the right side is the
completed illustration that you can see
in game
foreign
so uh as as I've told uh as we've told
you uh before uh just now
um we've also visualized in kedu's um
fighting style and
um and his skill abilities uh by
visualizing this some kind of aura or
energy uh right uh right around his hand
and arm
s
all right that was interesting so um
that's about it for illustrations so
um let's actually you know
so
um do we still have time for this
session if you guys are actually you
know if you can actually let me know
all right so I think we're out of out of
time so let's talk uh let's uh sum this
up with uh the final comments from the
you know French bread folks
[Music]
foreign
again I'm very happy to be here today to
reveal you the new game new game uh
that's been the work for a very long
time I'm very happy to reveal it today
here
[Applause]
so we've been uh we've tried to
implement many new uh new new aspects in
the game too for you guys to enjoy so
look forward to the coming updates uh
please stay tuned
thank you let's talk all right let's
hear the comment from um
so if you have if you actually go to the
arc system works booth now
there's something very special Hands-On
you can head on to right now
[Music]
I am very happy to announce that under
night and birth 2 hands on demo is
available right now on our system works
Booth come on
foreign
stories and you know what's been behind
behind the scene regarding on tonight
and birth two so we would like uh so we
would like to invite you all to the
panel as well
foreign
all right let's heat up the Evo Festival
from here on out ah thank you so much
for joining the panel today
[Applause]
all right
That's all folks for undernight in birth
too
all right let's give it up for that
panel
come on everyone
all right well stick around because
after this quick break we're gonna have
side games coming up to talk about their
new title
Chipotle's new Chicken al pastor is fire
on every level fresh chicken hot off the
grill a rich marinade of seared Marita
peppers and ground acchiote balanced
with a splash of pineapple all combined
for the right amount of heat Chipotle's
all new Chicken al pastor is where fire
meets flavor
thank you
[Music]
Trump
don't kill me
oh no
super Lola
feels good
I'm ready to walk
[Applause]
come on
till I fly away
[Music]
tell us
foreign
[Music]
wrong
without that sound and heard the crowd
Shake ground screaming around
for the main stage I'm still Brave
battling the Giants are still made the
real face that's that choice ignite the
fire
[Music]
s
keep shaking but my heart keeps
my voice
[Music]
foreign
my soul keeps Rising as I sing my song
[Music]
nothing
anything
[Music]
else
because
I fly
[Music]
myself
hey everyone welcome to Evo connections
presented by atnt I'm Persia and I am
joined by the one and only Justin Wong
Justin we are here Evo 2023 from
Champion to content creator and
everything else in between tell me about
the importance of connecting with your
community uh
you know I think his passion talking to
everybody in general really helps a lot
because everyone wants to be like oh I
want to meet your favorite player we
don't want to be like celebrities or
anything like that we want to make sure
we still get to talk to them and I think
that's the best part is given an
opportunity to have a conversation with
you exactly
you can see having conversations being
personable we're all fighting game fans
here and speaking of fighting games this
wall behind us got a lot of Champions on
this wall I see your name quite a few
times how do you feel about the future
of fighting games and you think you're
going to get another Championship under
your belt it's so hard to to win Evo now
because everybody's here more people are
playing
and I'm old you know I'm old I got no
time but in general I still want to play
see what I can do and I think like that
passion that fire will never go away so
I hope uh I can keep playing I hope more
people get into fighting games because
it's such a beautiful genre beautiful
sport
so
we're gonna try I want to retire at 10.
I don't like odd numbers so we'll see
and marvel three this year has a great
showing so many competitors how do you
feel about 2023 marble and everyone who
is showing up to compete this weekend
man I would say it's unbelievable it's a
it's over a 10 year old game uh so
really big shout outs to everybody who
really kept the scene alive especially
during the pandemic with parsec and
everything anyway
um
you know Tong West Coast you like
everyone really loves this game and I
feel like it's a game that can never be
replaced even after Evo let's say if it
never came back to Evo we would still
all be playing Marvel 3. yep so even 10
years from now we'll still play Marvel
three even 10 years from now if people
wanted to have a Marvel 3 tournament
everyone will still show up so it's one
of those games unreplaceable I
thank you so much for joining us we're
gonna send it right
right versus rising and we're excited to
Welcome to the stage creative director
tetsuya fukuhara along with Kane Bryan
and Maximo to translate
this new update
all right welcome everyone
versus Rising panel here at Evo 2023 we
have an exciting presentation for you
guys today with a lots of new
so stay tuned my name is Kane Bryant
I've been a translator with the cygames
localization team for about oh well it's
approaching seven years now
um and as for what I've translated
specifically if you liked it I did it if
you didn't like it I don't know where it
came from
um so joining me to my left is creative
director tetsuya fukahata and he will
give a brief self-introduction
all right
everybody
um
[Music]
all right so hey everyone I'm frikohana
from cygames I am the general director
of the grand blue fantasy franchise and
the creative director on Grand blue
Fantasy Versus Rising uh thanks for
coming out today and by the way I'm
actually Max from SCI games and I'll be
your interpreter
all right so in case you did you guys
didn't know uh fuku harasson is actually
an established fighting game vet
and uh it makes me wonder how long he's
been watching Evo actually uh
[Music]
so this is
foreign
[Music]
hype this weekend with some gbbs Rising
news and speaking with hype let's get
this show on the road so first up we're
going to give you guys a brief
introduction of grand blue Fantasy
Versus Rising uh
foreign
[Music]
all right so uh gbvs originally came out
in 2020 and was developed based on the
concept of creating a fighting game that
um anyone and everyone can pick up
um and now with Rising we're basically
elevating that experience on every level
and the plan is to release it uh later
this year
awesome so we are looking to create that
kind of game for everybody
um and enhance the experience that you
all got familiar with in verses so next
up we're going to talk specifically
about what we've improved uh
foreign
right and so uh these are the main
changes coming to uh Grand blue Fantasy
Versus Rising as you can see on screen
we've got new mechanics enhanced visuals
new characters new story rollback net
code cross play and more
awesome um so with all those features it
makes you wonder how we can fit that
into one small game and yet we can
because we have a powerful design
concept
um supporting the game so next
fukuhatasan will detail a little bit
about what guided our development this
time around us on game no concept
um
all right so uh the core gameplay design
will remain essentially the same and
Rising but we've added a number of fresh
new Mechanics for players to enjoy
Ed
systems
um so yeah we just held our Online Beta
recently and introduced a number of
these new mechanics uh through a series
of online videos so uh we won't go into
too much detail about them here but I
would like to give a huge thank you to
everyone who played the Online Beta
thanks to the massive turnout of players
uh we're able to gather a lot of
feedback
speaking of the Online beta test out in
the crowd right now how many of you guys
got into the Online Beta just curious I
see one two twenty five thousand that's
interesting wow I didn't realize we
could fit that many people in the stage
here
um very fun
um and speaking of the mechanics intro
video if you want to check it out for
yourself you can scan the QR code that
is listed in the PowerPoint above me
that probably looked weird for you
stream monsters me pointing at nothing
um
but uh if you can't scan it right now we
will be tweeting this code later you
could also search for it on YouTube and
by the way you might recognize a certain
sultry tone uh from doing that video
that tone is mine uh they pick me
because I'm cheap for those videos
fine you know we do what we can
um so next up we'll talk about specifics
about the upgraded points of the game
and first up we have enhanced visuals
you
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
we also took the opportunity to enhance
the visuals and Rising uh with improved
shaders and post-processing effects to
kind of give it a high quality
theatrical anime visual style uh We've
also updated some of the character
models as you can see on screen
foreign
and we've also upgraded the visual
effects on screen and honestly they are
quite stunning to see even the most
simple of attacks feel satisfying and
impactful to pull off
um
[Music]
right so um in addition to the hit marks
we've also updated other various effects
so try and see if you can spot the
differences between Rising into the
first gbvs our team really went out uh
with each and every detail
and I gotta say uh being in the office
and watching the game evolve from versus
to versus Rising especially in this
front was really cool to see at first
the localization team didn't know that
we were going to be doing enhanced
visuals and so uh playing the builds for
ourselves and watching all that happen
in real time was really cool so we're
excited for you guys to see uh the final
polished product as well
um next up uh everyone's long-awaited
feature uh rollback and cross play needs
no introduction
as you can see uh so uh
uh so yeah when gbvs first came out in
2020 we received a huge amount of
feedback for uh rollback netcode and the
domain was actually further increased
due to covid
um
foreign
since then but since gbvs was originally
built around delay based netcode
sorry about that uh the cost of
implementing rollback uh would have been
nearly the same as building an entirely
new game so it wasn't something that we
could do just on a whim unfortunately
is
like this
and so yeah there was a lot of internal
discussion about the possibility and
timing of uh doing something like this
and when we presented the ideas we
wanted to implement our system works
like adding cross play and whatnot uh we
ultimately decided yeah let's do it
so you know what they say folks when
life gives you delay based netcode make
a sequel out of curiosity how many of
you guys were waiting for rollback for
Grand blue
okay yeah that's the entire room I think
I see us all the way to Delaware with
our hands raised uh I personally feel
like that it's been 70 years meme
um but here we are we made it you guys
we're here roll back yeah
[Applause]
and you know uh when you do decide to do
a sequel that means you get to put in
some new characters uh this is
personally my favorite uh Advanced thing
coming to grambly Fantasy Rising um
foreign
uh so yeah these three new playable
characters have been announced for
Grandma Fantasy Versus Rising um they
all play quite differently uh with each
with their own individual play Styles so
I think they'll add to the overall depth
of rising
Story games
uh so yeah we last announced near as a
playable character but have yet to show
off any uh gameplay footage so uh I
think hope you guys are ready to check
that out all right guys so we are going
to show the footage off now uh get
yourselves ready if you need to here we
go
oh my
God
the blue Fantasy Versus Rising
Tokyo Meat Stop
all together three two one
Grim here
I feel the love I myself am so excited
for this character this is my favorite
Grand blue character and I promised
there was no nepotism involved this
happened totally naturally
um so let's hear a little bit about the
character from The Man himself
characters
foreign
ER is a character who can use the wind
to manipulate his projectiles and
movement uh giving him a huge variety of
movement options to let you uh Rush down
your opponents from every angle
um
foreign
[Music]
ER will play a particularly important
role so uh grimler fans look forward to
that and with these four new characters
coming to Rising 28 characters will be
playable at launch
foreign
I think
um and on the next slide uh we'll be
going over exactly what we meant earlier
by Anne Moore coming to Rising
all right here we are the and more uh so
this picture actually made waves at
Anime Expo so we thought we would debut
it again
um
uh yeah so this is uh something that we
introduced that Anime Expo but we wanted
to reintroduce it here and give everyone
just a little bit more context
is
[Music]
foreign
all right so uh fighting games are
essentially comprised of one-on-one
matches which means there will always be
someone suffering defeats and you know
we've all been there uh salty after
losing a rigged match you start to blame
others maybe like your family being
noisy someone may be distracting you uh
but blaming others is never good and so
I feel even worse and more frustrated
myself for this
[Music]
right and that's where we came up with
this new mechanic to help you manage
I'm also personally excited for this
because I am salty as a bag of chips
after most of my matches and uh so we
will go into a little bit more detail
about the partner system
hi um
all right so uh partner characters will
explain things to you and provide you
with advice
um of course they'll praise you when you
win your matches and they'll Provide
support for when you lose all right and
the comments will actually be based on
what happens during your matches on top
of that and also they're all fully
voiced
yep if there's anyone that can make me
get over a bitter loss it is Tiny
narmaya so I am looking forward to that
we have just a little bit more about
this coming up now
foreign
a huge variety of lines for every
situation so you can really see each
character's personality shine through
um of course you get to choose your
partner characters so go ahead and pick
your favorite and jump in
hi
all right and we've got some real info
coming up next
uh oh it's costumes get it hype
this is where I'm like this is where the
real game begins
drip time
so forgot a song costume skin is
um
[Music]
foreign
so one of the downsides to creating a 2d
anime style game is that it's actually
quite difficult to create costumes for
them there are a lot of moving Parts
like the characters hair and their capes
and whatnot that are essentially drawn
by hand frame by frame much like
traditional animation
foreign
[Music]
excellent all right so um yeah after a
lot of research we finally found a way
to tackle this issue
it's down and of course we'll be
releasing more costumes in the future on
top of grand so look forward to that
so you're telling me there's a chance at
summer Grim near or even Valentine's
group near
actually first we have to make summer
grimnier and then look guys I have a lot
of fantasies okay they get mixed up
alrighty next up we have another new uh
system update to share with you this is
uh updates to our ranking system
and our ranking systems
right and so in Rising versus ranks will
be character based it'll also uh this
was also featured that was highly
requested
um and it should make it easier to jump
into ranked matches and try new
characters out
um
all right and so there's going to be an
experience point system where players
can earn rewards uh as their level goes
up you can still earn experience even
after losing so I hope that'll encourage
players to uh use characters other than
their mains
um see you guys are going to get to S
rank because you're good at the game uh
but I'm going to get to S rank because I
want the s for Anila to stand for sheep
um we are not the same so next up we are
going to talk about some of our updates
to the training mode options
foreign
all right um so this feature here is
more for the lab monsters but in
training mode
you only standard training mode combo
trials
um in the previous game it was a bit
tedious to jump in between training mode
and trials on top of all the loading
times in between
um and so by integrating it into
training mode you'll be able to easily
practice on your own or uh production
trials all right so uh smoother
experience coming at you we also have
one more training mode update here for
you now
I think that one got more than the
costume skins you Traders it's about the
drip not kidding let's hear about this
Frame data Frame data need two things
all right and this one out here is
definitely for the lab monsters we've
added a Frame data display to training
mode uh this was something that was
highly requested as well
awesome
um that's it for our training mode
updates uh we'll see what's uh next in
store
oh okay here we have some engaging new
features
uh that are coming soon to you I think
I'll give Max a break from interpreting
here because uh he's been going a while
now and I'll take over interpreting
duties uh butasan could you please
explain what we're looking at I don't
know
foreign
all right guys we have a huge update
coming to the online Lobby system we are
expanding it from just the deck of the
grand Cipher into an entire Island
featuring lots of uh low and high places
so you can experience a lot of fun
locations to play around maybe relax a
little bit and we're really aiming to
give you a sense of comfort that you
would get from exploring an MMO RPG town
foreign
area where you can release some of your
stress from your matches you'll be able
to do things like Jump Around fly on a
hang glider and we even have a special
punching bag for you to attack to get
some of that stress out
I know
um
so at first when we announced Grand
Bruce Legends I was a little bit nervous
because I didn't know how people would
take it however I was very relieved to
see that people
um really gelled with the system with
the feature
um and that even we receive comments
like this is what fighting games needed
um so in Grand bruise you're going to
play a variety of party games including
obstacle races
um and survival courses Etc so it should
be a fun time
foreign
relieve some of that stress or also
um you can use it to spice up your
streams a little bit so lots of ways you
can have fun with granbury's Legends
and now we will go over some of the
games that you can play in granbury's
Legends
um
so this is rising Royale I believe it's
probably the simplest of the games
available in granbury's Legends um it
features a obstacle race where you have
to obviously Dodge obstacles
um to uh proceed to your goal
foreign
so the game will feature items where you
can use them to hinder the progress of
your opponents uh making for an
unpredictable uh time with lots of table
turning action
um so if you like to fight dirty this
might be the game for you uh next up
we'll go into the next game here
foreign
teams will be split into four and then
you will be uh working with your team to
try to collect as many gold bricks as
possible the team with the most gold
bricks wins and this is especially
hilarious for fans of the mobile game
because you understand the value of a
gold brick and personally if I lose in
this game I'm going to tell people to
post grids we'll see how you actually
make use of those gold bricks
um and next up we have another game to
Showcase here
foreign
[Music]
muscle training and is part of his
muscle training he's throwing bombs at
you as you do
um and in this process uh the ground
beneath your feet will literally crumble
away
um so the rules for this game are very
simple uh the last one who survives is
the winner
foreign
but among them is a game that features
uh downtown Shibuya as the location of
the events our staff have been working
very hard to make this an intriguing uh
game so we're looking forward to sharing
more with you in the future
um so our next slide features the last
bit of new information we have for
today's events
um so here I'm gonna let Max take the
interpretation Reigns again uh that's
very difficult whatever we're paying him
we should double it
um so thank you Max for taking that back
over for me absolutely um so uh
I know
it is
all right uh so first off uh sorry that
there is only a text on this slide but
uh yeah so we received a lot of comments
asking whether or not this would be an
upgrade to the first dbvs or not and uh
with the implementation of rollback
cross play all of the new uh features
and modes adding being added to the
overall experience uh the amount of
content we've added just wouldn't be
plausible through a simple update
um
[Music]
so I know some of you are hoping for an
update to the original gbvs but uh
Gremlin Fantasy Versus Rising will be
released as a separate entry to the gbbs
franchise
um
is
[Music]
all right so uh We've also received a
ton of feedback during the Online Beta
thank you for that and we will be
looking into making some changes to the
game moving forward and so I hope that
rollback and cross play will make it
easy to recommend this game to your
friends uh I'm confident that this game
uh will be a title that players around
the world will enjoy so that I hope that
players who um enjoyed the previous
title will uh pick it up again too
much
foreign
with that being said we thought we
should do something for those who
enjoyed the previous title and so we're
planning on making some elements of the
previous game transferable to Rising so
in addition to your story progress we'll
be uh you can transfer your tournament
trophies any ex colors and battle pass
weapon skins and colors as well to gbvs
Rising so I'll hold on to that save data
awesome so we had a few important
clarifications there an announcement
about the stuff that you can keep from
your versus group versus save data I
personally am excited to keep my ex
colors I spent so long collecting those
um so uh I think that wraps us all today
before we go however just going to make
sure that we don't have any final things
we want to talk about uh
I've just got one more quick thing to
share with you guys today so next slide
all right
all right so uh it looks like I'll be
doing a signing here at the side games
booth at Evo we have original postcards
and goods available too so if you're
here and have some time come through
foreign
[Music]
day one of the very first uh offline
gbbs Rising tournament at uh 2 p.m after
this uh so today will be pools with top
32 starting tomorrow
foreign
so during all tournament hours
it's rising for
uh once again if you're free uh come
through and give it a shot and if you're
not here at Evo today we do have a link
to the stream um on our official Twitter
or X account not really sure what it's
called now but uh definitely come by and
check it out awesome I personally am
wishing all of you Catalina Mains out
there a very good tournament at day one
um so uh thank you so much for all of
your comments today I think uh we've got
day one to Evo off to a great start um
so we're going to conclude with just
some final comments here uh so for
karate song take us away
um
all right and that is all for today's
Finals uh sorry today's panel uh but we
will have some more announcements
planned during Evo finals so stay tuned
for that ooh more announcements planned
could that be something like a release
date
[Music]
no comments
hi
uh so no comment unfortunately that's
all I can say for today
um so to everyone watching we'll see you
again Sunday
okay that's fair enough uh so I guess uh
yeah we'll just find out in two more
days uh what's in store for us it sounds
like something is
um so before we go just I'll get through
goddess on one last chance to make any
last comments so forgottus
hi um
all right so we've got plenty more in
store planned for this game and we're
all really hard at work and trying to
make this a game that you will all love
so we hope you check it out and that is
all for today so thank you so much for
coming out all right guys this is a
final reminder that if you go to the psy
games booth and sign up for the open
Beta tournament you will get this spiffy
bag look at that that is special and
inside that bag is a clear folder
featuring some key art from Grand blue
Fantasy Versus uh so be sure you sign up
and you claim this sweet swag for
yourself and that will conclude us today
I'll show it to the camera real quick I
think I got my angle wrong there uh but
you know what I'm a translator not a
host
um and we will conclude there folks
thanks for coming out we'll see you next
time
[Applause]
[Music]
be sure to check out Grand blue versus
Rising tournament finals tomorrow at 4pm
PST all right we're going to take a
quick break and when we come back we're
going to have arxus on stage to talk
about Guilty Gear strive
50 fighter coins with yours visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details you got
this
only a handful of people in the world
can do it you could be the best
but it's dangerous these are incredible
steaks you're going to be forced to make
Split Second decisions that could cost
you your life get out whether you like
it or not you are in this race
you're so
Gran Turismo based on a true story radio
PG-13
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
PlayStation
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths are forever when they
pen our Lord
clear I feel all the hopes inside of the
same fear
[Music]
is everything
I have a brand new age when I hear my
voice
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing
[Music]
and reinforce whether that is
right when is the only option
[Music]
privacy running the trenches so coming
against us is utterly senseless
on the floor
on the wall
uces constant and this ain't my final
form
[Music]
through the sky
brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
[Music]
thank you
believe through a sky and
I am
[Music]
strong
thank you
[Music]
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths are forever when they
pin our Lord
clear I feel all the hopes inside of the
same fear
[Music]
s running back quarter on one cab 199
seconds is everything y'all
I push forward and tell them to hold
that roll back I don't see any limited
lacking the vision
the hell I would risk it I'm basically
different I'm everything they say that I
hate this
to move on as soon as all the pressure
gets too strong feel like I was born
here for something to prove wrong what
was that moment when you felt that sound
I heard the crap [__] Crown screaming
one more round let the lights flash over
the main stage I'm still Brave battling
the Giants are still made the real face
that's that choice ignite the fire of a
brand new age when I hear my voice
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
second
is
[Music]
simple this is
The Trenches so coming against us
with beard like art on the wall if they
didn't know if I'm inform Evolution's
constant and this ain't my final form
[Music]
a flying ways you can't believe
brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
[Music]
thank you
life
[Music]
thank you
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths are forever when they
pin our Lord
inside of the room
all the hopes inside of the same fear
s
[Music]
is
lacking the vision and asking why the
hell I was risk it I'm basically
different I'm everything that says
[__]
with a record-breaking 2
481 entrants here at Evo no one is a
stranger to Guilty Gear strive please
welcome on stage director Ken miucci
Akira katano and Kenta asano to talk a
little bit more about the game
all right hold on one more time
everybody let's make some noise for
Guilty Gear shrive and the developers
and a CEO come on
[Applause]
thank you ever for being here and thank
you guys for joining us on this panel
today uh so we got a couple of slides
we're gonna go over uh I do actually
have
sorry
do actually have a little bit of a
question regarding strive in general how
long did it take to develop strive in
general and the developmental period
that went on behind it
is
arima
[Music]
so basically we uh basically we started
developing uh guilty gears uh strive
right after uh Revelator so in terms of
concept level we started developing
right after you know Revelator uh
released uh released to the public and
after after that we actually released uh
update for Revelator rev 2 but we're
still uh we were still developing uh
strive behind so with that all combined
it will be around seven to eight years
so there was actually a time where you
were still working on some rev Guilty
Gear while also working on strive at the
same time
foreign
so that you are correct so while uh
Daisuke was working on the basic
concepts and scenario for the new guilty
gears Drive uh he uh I actually think uh
um build it up uh developing developing
you know rev2
that is extremely impressive extremely
impressive I do have a question how long
does it take to say develop one
character like let's use uh Oscar for
example how long does it take from start
to finish for the concept art and the
lore and the animations how long does
something like that take for just a
single character
foreign
[Music]
all right
so yeah uh when you think about the cons
uh the base concept level and you know
going to the completion it will take
around a year
so uh we'll have a concept uh concept
data and you know rough uh concept art
and uh 2drs like henta here will draw a
rough uh rough design of the character
and he'll actually make the specific
designs of the character in 2D and they
will model it they'll actually put the
effects and they also you know put the
Motions in and also you know record
voice lines and after that it'll uh the
character can be tuned and be completed
uh that will take around about a year or
so
uh I another question regarding Oscar in
general I feel like that has been a
character that a lot of Guilty Gear fans
have known and cared about for a long
time was there a reason why Oscar is now
in strive as opposed to some of the
other Guilty Gear games
like why was Oscar for strive and maybe
not
rev one or rev2
um
[Music]
Tennessee
um
so obviously uh go to your strive is
basically one point one end
post all bad guys story so at some point
we uh we want we definitely wanted to
put Oscar out in some point of strife
however there was this complication of
you know uh I'm not I'm not sure if if
I'm okay to say this out loud here
because a bit of a spoiler but you know
uh on story mode Oscar you know is in
certain State and you know in certain
State and we were not sure how to you
know Implement that into the game
playable character so for a long time
within the dev team we had long
discussion long discussion about how to
implement a playable character of a
character that's in certain state in the
scenario
um so
um after a long discussion we decided to
um we decided to implement Oscar in the
current state of form
very good so how long would you guys
implement the new character what does
that do to the development of like
balancing the game is that difficult
when you have a new character then you
have to balance that character around
the game that does that take a while do
you guys have a lot of conversation
about that make sure it's they're tuned
the right way
um
designer
[Music]
characteristics
foreign
well uh well definitely the first by uh
character by character so I won't uh I
can't say too General but uh it takes
around uh it takes around minimum of
three months to actually tune up tune up
a character in Balance we do have uh we
do have battle designers that were
formerly you know uh Top Class players
in-house so we uh we uh they actually
you know
um get to actually play the match uh
between the new character and the other
older characters characters to actually
tune the character in Balance however it
kind of you know differs from character
and character and uh in Oscar in
particular particular we had to invest
more time to actually tune it right
watching that character is probably one
of my favorite things in strive by the
way so excellent job on that character I
think the character is so cool uh I do
have another question is there anything
that we can look forward to in the
future regarding Guilty Gear stride that
you might be able to tell us
um
[Music]
so I'm going to answer to that question
and can we actually producer
okay
check
good all right
um so yeah uh just recently released uh
developers back here that I kind of
mentioned a little bit about the new
updates that's coming shortly uh which
is one is the new special moves to some
characters and a new battle mechanics
that's coming also uh along with like
new additional characters of course so
Scene Three will are we are planning not
only to update to uh doing like the
additional characters but a couple of
other
um I'm rebuild uh input updates that are
being planned throughout the season
three uh which makes uh player more
excited to get into play Guilty Gear
stripe
well I am extremely excited for the
future of guilty gears Drive are we
excited for the future of guilty games
Drive
[Applause]
any more closing comments from the team
over for guilty gears Drive
um we actually brought some slide here
if you want to solve yeah let's show
some slides so uh the reason I bought
this slide is to uh
uh appeal can tell who is our lead to
the awesome lead to the artist here uh
who draw this
yeah come on
and also these
uh some of you have like saying he is a
incredible artist who worked on drawing
these and also I'm trying to change the
next page oh
yeah and uh as you see he did the art
for 50 uh no 500k and uh 1 million user
and we just recently reached 2.5 million
players 2.5 million players in yoga
tribe
[Applause]
we've accomplished this because of all
over support thank you so much
and uh some of other art
there you go uh with he's also worked on
these kind of uh uh Tower record
collaboration
some other art working with the the
um
Barbie store I don't know how I call it
in English
and this is a recently announced uh
collaboration art
and uh I also brought some uh you know
uh rough image of Oscar I didn't have a
chance to show it but yeah
and uh
I don't know if you have seen But the
arcade mode for Oscar but he
the original Oscar have different color
so we did also have the portray so this
is first time showing this for a year
and uh Kenta asano he also works on the
character colors
these are all the colors that we have uh
not all but like some up to color to
open the in addition to ex uh do you
want to talk about like what college do
you like
whatever
it is
so uh there's this color number 13 as
you can see in the screen right now uh
that's one of my favorite
peanut butter
um
so having having the main color of you
know black and white is also very cool
but putting accent in uh you know very
different color is also something uh can
uh I I like the most at the moment
uh
foreign
then you know he'll uh do his best to
actually provide more colors to you guys
to enjoy so give it up to Kenta foreign
[Applause]
going around and uh people are having
fun there's a lot of fun moments around
evil uh for sure this year uh we all are
also planning to make more exciting
announcements uh soon sometimes maybe
during Revo
um maybe this weekend
I wouldn't say anything all right I
tried guys I tried I tried
so thank you that's my uh me kamiyachi
producer and
um
[Music]
so thank you all for uh so thank you all
for the loud support this has been Ken
tasana
I will say that as being a huge Guilty
Gear fan since day one I'm extremely
excited to see what this game does and
what everybody does in the future for
this title
foreign
I'm sure that a lot of you people who
are in the venue and watching the stream
and are looking forward to some kind of
you know information
uh coming up so please keep an eye out
on Evo uh till the final till the final
so uh please look forward to it
everybody please one more time the
developers of guilty gears Drive
thank you guys so much
big developers on the stage but we gotta
give some love to the in the great Indie
Fighters as well let's check out some
trailers
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
there has been
[Music]
it only took a few centuries but ladies
and Gentlemen please welcome to this
game
features real life drag performers and
all their Camp queer kick Ashley
duking it out to discover who the one
true top is and a world full of bottoms
your Champion drag her is being death
dropped Onto You by Fighting Chance
games A Fistful of good Judy's who
realize no one else is gonna do it so
they had to strap on
I mean scrapping
we know you're thirsty
too bad
[Music]
foreign
will die here
Jack tryhima
choose your Legend
of the legends
Joe I gotta say I love all the different
Artistic Styles of these Indie Fighters
well guess what what we got a lot more
to show off so let's check them out
[Music]
in the vast expanse of distant galaxies
the very fabric of reality trembles as
an Unstoppable warlord leads an armada
to seek out the Hyperion cores
imbued with unimaginable power
they hold the key to either salvation
or annihilation
would you plunge the universe into
Eternal Darkness or bring it back from
the brink
wish list now
okay
foreign
and I tried to add just enough
to get to the fighting game that I would
have fun playing but still felt as
simple and Bare Bones as possible
[Music]
foreign
yeah
hey yo
yo
you free
so we had Tough Love Arena on stage last
year and I have to say it's been pretty
great to see how far the development has
come absolutely Aaron and also don't go
anywhere because up next we're going to
be talking about Nickelodeon All-Stars
but first let's hit this quick break
at Chipotle real food always starts with
real ingredients in real kitchens when
you order Chipotle real food starts with
you whether it's in restaurant pickup or
delivery however you Chipotle is the
easiest way to Chipotle
good
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up everyone we at tenno are
Beyond excited to announce the launch of
some brand new merchandise for Evo
beginning with our new officially
licensed Street Fighter designs which
include premium embroidered hoodies and
more also we have new officially
licensed designs for the King of
Fighters 15 Guilty Gear Tekken and other
fgc partners each 10-0 product is
carefully designed by fgc heads with
only the best material for maximum
comfort and style trust me you don't
want to wait to cop these
welcome back everybody to Evo
connections presented by a t my name is
vicious here with the industrious the
illustrious Robert television AKA
Hollywood it's good to see you man how
you feeling bro I feeling amazing bro
we're here at freaking Evo I'm with my
dog vicious you know you're the real
Hollywood one bruh you in the game then
yeah big Hollywood in the game at least
yet what's going on put in the word
everything's been going great man now I
do have to ask you coming in from a
professional perspective you are a
professional Street Fighter player how
does it feel making that connection with
all of the Street Fighter fans around
the world with the brand new Street
Fighter 6 now being the headliner at Evo
so it's been amazing of course playing
Chicago six I always say that I'm no
longer a pro player by my standards I'm
still I'm still nice but I like you know
it's not like I was in the past now that
I'm doing other things but with that
being the case it's amazing being out
here seeing everybody bro I mean and of
course I'm ready to see all these pools
matches too no I have seen you make that
transition of being a man of the people
in the fighting game Community what is
it like to you in your opinion having an
event like Evo bringing the FTC together
yo so that right there I've been walking
around just smiling ear to ear
throughout this entire event like so far
just everybody that you see there's
people from around the world you already
know Jeremy like we do this for real
before any of this cameras and beautiful
at T microphones and all that just us
riding around in raggedy cars City to
City playing for next to no money
whatsoever so all this happened is extra
and it's beautiful but the most
important thing is the community aspect
so seeing all of my friends and
everything like you know like yourself
has been dope and I gotta say you know
speaking of community shout out to my
man's uh piano then setsu you know RFP
you know absolute Legend you know what I
mean I feel like he's somebody who
completely represented exactly what the
fgc is all about so I gotta show love to
him and it's the perfect time to bring
that up and we couldn't do it without
those types of folks especially folks
like you as well we're going to go back
to the main stage we'll hit it off with
everything going down here at Evo
the excitement continues on day one of
Evo because coming up next we have a
great reveal from Nickelodeon check it
out
we're taking a look at some of the
exciting new mechanics in Nickelodeon
All-Star brawl 2. to start let's take a
look at some of the completely new ways
Nick Brawl 2 handles movement movement
in Nick Brawl 2 is now fully analog
meaning you can walk and run and you can
also aim some moves in any direction
available to a control stick it's also
worth mentioning that yes tap jump is
now an option and you're able to set
custom profiles with your name tag when
it comes to defense rolling spot dodging
and air dodging are now all available
there's also two types of air dodging
there's a neutral air Dodge which keeps
your current momentum and the
directional air Dodge which pushes you
towards whatever Direction you're
holding each of these techniques has a
little bit of invincibility to help you
run away and Dodge your opponent's
attacks or even slip in a counter attack
just keep in mind you can't act
instantly out of these options and yes
with air dodging that also means wave
dashing is back baby
if you remember it from Nick brawl 1 the
rock paper scissors mechanic is gone but
light and strong attacks are here to
stay including new horizontal directions
strong attacks are what you'd expect
stronger than your regular light attacks
and usually quite a bit slower they can
now also be charged both on the ground
and in the air and they still reflect
projectiles
as for light aerial attacks you now have
five total options up down forward
backward and neutral blocking has also
been changed while blocking you can get
still pushed around and even go into a
teeter if you get pushed to the ledge
but now you can only block a limited
amount of damage and for a limited
amount of time before your bubble bursts
leaving you wide open for an attack if
you also manage to start blocking just
as you're about to get hit with an
attack you'll Flash Blue and hear an
audio cue that lets you know that you
just performed a pairing when that
happens you suffer no block stun and no
block push from your opponent's attack
and can act immediately
and now the biggest addition to
Nickelodeon All-Star Brawl 2 the Slime
meter
build up your slime meter during your
match by hitting your opponent to
enhance your attacks movement combo game
and more
one of the first ways to use slime is by
spending one of the three available bars
to enhance your special attacks
SpongeBob for instance normally blows
one meezy tiny innocent bubble but if
you enhance it with slime he blows three
much more powerful individually
threatening bubbles that can assist you
in controlling space and locking down
your opponent feel like Patrick's
neutral special needs a little more
oomph try spinning some meter on it
maybe your official just won't quite
raise the lens bummer that's also a
great time to use your meter all special
moves in the game have a powerful slime
version to explore so make sure you use
every single one
slime burst is another use of slime that
can help you out on the fence if you're
getting comboed mercilessly or about to
go flying out of the ring you can do a
slime burst to stop all your momentum
and knock your opponents away it can
definitely be worth using to break out a
combo or hang on to a stock for a little
bit longer just keep in mind it costs
two whole bars and there's plenty of
other powerful offensive options
available with slime as well
one of the most powerful options is the
Super Attack
if you manage to build up all three bars
you can Unleash Your super has an easy
way to wring out any opponents you might
catch that also happen to be a high
percent everyone's got a totally unique
looking animation to their super so
definitely be sure to check those out
and let us know which one is your
absolute favorite
slime is all together the key to
becoming a master at Nick brawl to but
what we just mentioned only scratches
the surface of how you'll be using it
once you're comfortable with the basics
it's time to get into some of the more
Advanced Techniques
for all you sweaty players out there
slime canceling is another powerful
option that you can spend your meter on
and its applications are only limited by
your creativity instead of spending a
bar to enhance an attack you can use it
to cancel an attack what does that mean
basically instead of having to wait for
the rest of your attack recovery you can
do a slime cancel and then well do
anything you want if your opponent is
nearby and tumbling from recent attack
the momentarily freeze next to you
allowing you to line up your next attack
let me take a quick breath and keep the
combo going something important to keep
in mind though is that your next attack
won't be quite as powerful as it would
be after doing a slime cancel so those
potentially powerful combo finishers in
strong attacks might not always be the
best options to go for after a slime
cancel
slime canceling can also come in handy
if you miss an attack or adjust short of
the ledge when trying to recover tired
of using your legs want to get close to
your opponent faster how about using
slime to turn your air Dodge into a much
faster air Dash that you can immediately
attack out of this is a great way to
break through your opponent's defenses
or just barely squeeze out a combo
finisher where you otherwise might not
be able to get one just keep in mind
you're not Invincible like you would be
with an air Dodge so don't just go
throwing yourself at your opponent
expecting to hit them every single time
that's just foolish
so those are some of the core mechanics
to look out for in Nickelodeon All-Star
brawl 2. hopefully you all have fun
discovering and exploring the ways to
play especially with the all-new slime
meter for a slightly more in-depth look
at the characters themselves keep an eye
out for the upcoming character
spotlights where we dive into everyone's
all new movesets game plans and quirks
thanks for watching
[Music]
let's do this
get back here
don't call me Sheldon
Harris
hello suckers
[Music]
those were some great reveals but I have
to say there's nothing better than free
burritos you heard it correctly from me
because over the course of this weekend
Chipotle will be giving away over 40
000 Yes you heard me correctly 40 000
free burritos and bowls through text to
win giveaways you do not want to miss
out on this opportunity but we will be
heading to a quick break we have more
exciting panels and reveals for you soon
enough
test that choice ignite the fire of a
brand new age when I hear my voice
[Music]
keeps on
myself
[Music]
oh man
this back
brush it down
next
I'll be strong prove myself
[Music]
thing
here we go
[Music]
oh
I dream
s
[Music]
welcome back to Evo 2023 now you do not
want to miss out on this upcoming
conversation because we have one of the
most prolific voices in the fgc Seth
Killian who's going to be interviewing
one of the most accomplished players in
Evo history Mena Rd
hello perfect I think this is happening
uh hello I'm Seth Killian
um I'm here with Mena Rd uh only
two-time cup two-time Capcom Cup
champion uh recent CEO Champion you've
been putting bodies on the floor uh we
were just unfortunately having a deep
conversation right right before this all
started so we're sort of uh backing up
here but
we're here to talk and so I get to ask
uh the kind of weird questions that I
like to ask so when I think about strong
players I sometimes think about uh their
superpowers right like a list of
superpowers that you might have a list
of specials I think of three superpowers
for you
um but I'm only gonna talk about the
first one right now and the first one is
sort of the cheering section right like
you have
hype men you got a crowd you got a crew
you got them back home and like that's a
huge plus
um
tell me about that tell me about what
that superpower is for you
well that superpower uh
it comes back from from culture honestly
and the Dominican Republic we're all
very passionate about about sports about
everything we which here loudly
um about who we want to win our team in
baseball or whatever so in fighting
games is the same thing but
it became more about a safe space uh
because we didn't know anybody here in
the FTC it was it was all like VR versus
the world but now it has like become
more of a something you do for passion
because the FTC is like it's like our
home now like the Dominican players is
like oh we just go into one of our
tournaments it's not going to the USA or
going to fight the international systems
let's let's just go to our tournaments
you know and now we do it um
out of love you know out of I want you
to know that I support you and that I'm
here but it's not about being a safe
space anymore it's not about uh we need
to defend each other yeah you're not
playing defense anymore before it was
like me and my yeah the crew together
um there was I think 2017 was fair to
say your big breakout year right like
you were you were making dents in the
Capcom Pro Tour and then obviously went
big at the cup and had an incredible
string of victory over super strong
players right like famous lifelong
players my favorite moment of that
tournament for you was actually
not in the game it was the moment you
won I don't even know if you'll remember
this but the moment you won
you sort of froze and you looked at the
kind of at the camera for a second where
you're like oh that just happened so
you're realizing it but at no point do
you stop moving if you do uh you realize
it but you're sort of rotating this
whole time
and you do a no look hug to your crew
that was running up on stage so from the
moment you won you were just like boom
right right yeah actually that broke my
heart like really hard because I was
just like you just knew like a no-look
passing basketball like you knew they
were coming and from the moment you won
you were starting to turn around to go
for the hug and I was like man yeah I
actually when I was playing I don't use
um headphones I never use headphones I
like hearing the the crowd and
I I was hearing them going crazy and I I
look around I was like they're there I
know if this happens they're coming up
like I know there nobody's stopping them
so as soon as I won I tilted my foot
because I know they were gonna tackle me
I was getting ready like as soon as I
won I was like Wow but I was processing
but I was getting ready like I don't
want to get knocked down you know that
was the funny part you got it there was
an impact like you see when they hit him
like the chains fly off the neck because
it's like a good it looks like a good
hit effect the array tackled me then
kava came around I was like I need to
read like
so it wasn't out of love that you're
rotating for the hug so make sure you
didn't get Survival yet
uh that is extremely perfect
um you talk about like wanting to hear
the crowd and like listen to the
audience like that means a lot and I
think it's the that's a hard thing it
doesn't always come through when you're
watching you know I watch a lot at home
these days and I don't think that part
comes through and it's both it creates
pressure on you but it also is that
feedback right it's that rush like the
same that's what sort of this is all
about right like that experience of
being close to people like feeling like
that electric charge you kind of get how
do you handle that right like it's very
different than grinding at home like you
literally feel the pressure
do you have pre-game rituals or just
like how do you mentally prepare for for
this well
um you know every time someone is really
successful uh at something I I feel like
they're a little bit crazy I feel like
no one becomes really good at something
being completely sane so in my case and
I know it's kind of weird but I see the
crowd as one one thing it's just one
entity you know it's not multiple people
it's just one thing and when I hear the
crowd of the booing or cheering it's
like what do you want from me today you
know like I'm I'm talking to you the
crowd one one thing and if they're
bullying it's like today I'm gonna I'm
gonna make you sad today I'm gonna shut
you up if they cheers like today I'm
Gonna Make You Proud so it's like I'm
just talking to one friend that that's
the crowd I don't imagine it as
thousands of peoples it's just one one
single thing
uh that is super Zen I really love that
answer very Zen and also the only other
I once heard a DJ talk about the crowd
that way the same way where you sort of
treat it all as the same but I love the
idea that you're I'm gonna shut you up
yeah crowd uh very powerful that gets me
to another thing is like I think one of
your other superpowers is like I would
say
you're a sore loser but you adapt right
like you learn quickly so I want to hear
about
how you how you handle it when you lose
but like how do you stay
out of the anger Zone I guess I think
about like I saw I grew up with Michael
Jordan Michael Jordan's Hall of Fame
acceptance speech the guy was angry
right like he's still angry about stuff
from like high school and he's like
calling people out how do you stay in
the good place away from the dark hello
I've been thinking more about like let's
about myself and more about my my circle
the people that work around me and the
people that make it happen you know uh
people that help me develop in-game uh
the sponsors everything and when I lose
it's not about oh I lost you know but
men are are they the this product that
everybody is working for
this product that everybody's working
for my group of friends my family
everybody can't
um I can't afford
to do that to lose and embarrass myself
I love that yeah I love that I can't
afford it yeah I can't afford to lose I
can't do that because I'm embarrassing
my whole team you know so now I think
about okay this is just the process uh I
lost I need to learn today so I'm able
to give them wins in the future and that
that helped me a lot when I stopped
thinking about myself if it's only
myself it's gonna be the same as always
I'm I don't know how to lose honestly I
don't know how to lose but when I think
about all of the people that help me be
where I am right now then it becomes
easier to to accept that it's just a
process
I really love that uh you flip it and
make it not about you but you make it
about service to them and that's a form
of strength
um I really love that that brings me to
sort of one of your second superpowers
which is the confidence right like
you're always willing to bet on yourself
when you make a hard read and I think
this confidence pairs with sort of the
third power which is pattern recognition
I see you and you do funny stuff to top
play like you do stuff to top players
that
you don't really see a lot of other
people get away with right like sort of
walk up and throw like you have a
freedom to your movement and I often
think about top player privilege like it
gets measured in frames right if you
respect somebody too much it slows you
down you start thinking about it like
you're not willing to go for the kind of
the surprising thing you you show them
Respect by not doing the obvious cheap
not putting in a throw Loop or whatever
so
talk to me about pattern recognition and
how you get that sense of confidence
where it comes from
actually tying it together is very
important because I feel people become
predictable they they have a pattern
when they're not confident when they
need to go like okay I can't I can't see
everything I can react to everything I
need to have a pattern that helps me
survive I need to do things that just
work uh hadouken here I stand here maybe
I'm safe you know and that's when I feel
like people are getting scared when I
feel they're getting uncomfortable I
start looking for patterns oh as soon as
he gets scared he does this when he's
confident
um he does this but when they're
confident it's harder because they'll do
anything but when they're scared no so
that that's that's what I look for and
it I I actually you know like Taskmaster
from Marvel like I I feel I identify a
lot with that character it's because of
that because I can I can like see what
people are doing but not only in gaming
real life and see myself in that and
that confidence game from Cava Cava was
absurdly confident for no reason I was
like why are you so confident you're not
gonna beat them but he kept going and
going kept doing great things and
I took that I was like okay let me try
that and when it worked it actually
inspired him he says oh man that gives
me the confidence I was like what I
stole it from you it's a loop like that
right you reinforce each other and
because yeah yeah you play together it
worked like that but that that's the
thing like I try to learn from everyone
that I see try to see the good things in
everybody and I just steal the good
things from them you know and and bring
it into myself and they didn't they
won't even realize that I did that
you know it's it's amazing I do it in
game and I do it in real life and it
works
so who are some other players
that you you who do you learn from
that's a hard question I know but you're
task mastering it up
it's it's tough uh but I I learned from
I learned from a lot of players that
it's hard to say because every player
that I play I try to see what they're
doing the ideas that they have and if I
can speak with them I try to see like
why will you do that you know the
reasoning uh but that's great advice by
the way for everybody at home just ask
ask the top player why why that happened
or how and be specific right like don't
just ask a general question like yes a
situation why did this happen in this
way why did this happen specifically yes
yes and from regions I learned a lot
from regions like
so in Japan they have a certain style of
play in America they have a certain
style of play in Europe it's also
different so I try to see like why are
they playing like that you know is it
because they're used to playing fighting
a certain style and they shape their
their gameplay that way so if I fight
that style should I play like in
European you know if if I fight this
character should I play like a Japanese
and what does it mean to play like a
European playing like in European is it
depends on the matchups but for example
when they play against uh bison in
Street Fighter 5 a lot of them didn't
give him the respect they disrespected
his spacing like I will stand right here
because you're very slow and a lot of
players try to like approach him smother
him they just stood right outside his
range every time and if he committed
then they jumped it was like so simple
it was so effective I was like I just
need to do this and I'm gonna have
against your time so yeah that's what I
see I see it uh in regions I learned a
lot from that that's a super great
analysis I love I love approaching it
that way I heard John Troy gave you some
Fireball lessons and then you learned
how to throw fire you beat everybody up
by throwing fireballs
true
he did he did I I asked him now I like
asking and just ask everyone
the best fireables in the world I was
like wait I need to I need to talk with
him see what's going on and I learned a
lot I was terrible at using Fireballs
because I used to use them like as a
poke like birdie but now it's it's all
about where you're standing and when you
can abuse it when they can jump and it's
it's really it helped me a lot honestly
asking is is I think it's my biggest
strength as a player I just I just ask a
lot I think that's good advice for
everything in life just ask you'd be
surprised what comes back and the cost
of like somebody saying no is much lower
than you think yeah my life changed a
lot just by asking
this this part of this whole thing is uh
uh here because we were running a
tournament and I would just go to the
Capcom Booth as a random guy from the
internet and ask for Stuff
and they said no
three years in a row and then the third
year they were like okay maybe and then
away we went all it was was just ask and
kept asking and they told me to get lost
I was like yeah that makes sense I'm
just some guy from the internet why why
would you give us anything but they did
eventually we talked to the right person
so just ask great advice
um
we're at the beginning of the Street
Fighter 6 Journey you know projectile is
debuting we're hearing more about Tekken
8 Mortal Kombat like when you look at a
new game
what do you what jumps out to you like
what are you looking for how do you
break it down we're still fresh with the
six so
what jumped out to you immediately as
like
a lever that you could use or a thing
you needed to work on or
well gameplay wise um I try to set games
from from what they are like if you play
marble you can expect to want to play
Street Fighter there or if you're gonna
play Street Fighter like I just take the
Bass from the past and see what they
what they try to change and why like why
why would you uh get rid of the B system
to go to the drive system I want to see
like okay so for a phone factor or for
what but so you're trying to out-think
the designers I try to understand yeah
yeah yeah yeah no no that's great I try
to understand them but I also focus a
lot on things that are not uh
based on gameplay like the music the
design the characters the story because
I'm gonna invest a lot of time doing
this so I want to see what I'm getting
into it's not it's not just you know me
pressing some buttons doing some
functions it's just me enjoying what I'm
doing and and I wanna I wanna relate
deeper to the characters to the story
that they want to sell me and I focus on
that a lot too you know that's so super
wise right like I'm just a degenerate I
go straight to the training mode
right in but
but you want to really invest and like
appreciate the whole package uh it
really does help smooth out those
rough edges yes um and then same thing
for characters like when you're looking
for a character that's you know you
always have sort of a fresh take on
what's going to be good or how to make
something work you see something that
other people don't see what is that that
jumps out to you
well
um
gameplay wise I look for I like
conditioning players so I look for tools
that can that can condition that require
a lot of your attention for example you
have birdie right at the start it was
the dolphin Dove then they can and then
it became the sweep so I was like okay I
can condition them with this Blanca
Blanca ball uh Luke sandblast so I like
a very strong tool that makes you focus
on it so I can condition you play around
yes and and you forget about the other
things and design wise I just go with
with a lot it's just whatever I like you
know I never thought I would like Blanca
but it is what it is you know I'm open
to anything
and you got the Luke in the back in case
uh yes bad matchup or something like
that yeah yeah okay so let's do a speed
round I call this game underrated
overrated
okay
Blanca
in Street Fighter six on the radio
underrated
drive impact
overrated overrated why you got to say
why
I feel Drive Impact is very strong but
in top level play it has like maybe one
or two uses but most people that I ask
that are like from mid level to below
they're like oh Drive Impact breaks the
game it's like no no it's a strong
resource but the game doesn't revolve
around Drive Impact so that's why I feel
is overrated I think that's good advice
it is just kind of a plateau that you
reach but you can get you can get past
it yes uh why is Blanca underrated
Blanca is underrated at first because
he's ugly I don't know why most people
they see ugly characters they think
they're bad right away with birdie it
happened for the first two years oh he's
fat he's ugly he sucks like no this
can't be broken you know and I feel like
Blanca most people see him like oh I
know what he does no he has he has set
play now he has to die I used to call
him circus characters yes he's not he's
real now so I feel like most uh top
players know
more or less where he's at but I feel
like most people in general the
community they think Blanca is worse
than he actually is
underrated overrated Dominican Republic
super underrated super underrated in
what way is food department gameplay
what's the in a lot of things it's not
on everything I'm not gonna I'm I'm a
little bit biased but you know keeping
it down I appreciate it I feel like
first thing first players I think
they're very underrated I think you need
to rank players on their ability to
perform when they are given the chance
if they're never given the chance and
they don't do anything okay they don't
do anything but they never played so a
lot of them
never get to travel and they're amazing
players so they're on their way to end
on department and I feel like on the
tournament side I think like we have uh
top quality tournaments but most people
don't get to go because it's like this
is the Dominican Republic it's not
connected to the USA it's a little bit
harder to go but I feel like the
tournaments there are amazing so that's
good advice or good good shout outs to
the tournaments there and it's also like
when you keep the consistency that's
when you start seeing people come up so
right if you can keep it consistent
that's how you build the audience and
that was definitely yes one of the keys
Evo
um and growing underrated overrated
modern controls
on the radio too yes
um I feel like it hasn't developed as
much because most people are not even
willing to try it for real it's like oh
I see this it's too different I'm not
gonna do it but I feel like a lot of
characters like specifically Luke I feel
Luke
is better and modern than in classic
so because of like the level one
reaction because you get uh you don't
have to deal with the mental stack in
this game you have the one button DP you
have the one button level one you have
you can be anything easily and you don't
lose a lot of tools it's about what you
lose he doesn't lose anything
significant it's just a back heavy kick
so I feel like
in the future we're going to see more
modern specific counter picks like oh
you you pick this character I'm gonna go
modern you know that's exactly how I
think about it I think about almost like
a character right like a different
character same way like super turbo had
like old character like old Saga versus
New Saga like it's basically like a
different matchup the control scheme is
a funny way of thinking about it but
that is how I've been thinking about it
for myself it's like there's a time
where you'd like to pick modern as a
counter pick I think it's going to go
that way because it really shuts down so
much like sitting around with the level
three with the instant reactions is like
it's hard to play against that like
you're just like I don't know I don't
know if this button is safe or not and
then you're thinking about it and then
you lose right yeah it's uh it's
oppressive
um hard read on how many people in the
top 64
Street Fighter bracket will be using
modern controls
I'm good at this kind of thing
stop 64. top 64.
I'm gonna say
five players five five players my number
was three
it's closed but I think it's gonna be
five I think I think we're gonna have
one wild card and I think we're gonna
have you know the Japanese they're using
a lot of modern uh tachikawa kawano yeah
and to your point there's going to be
some people that play Modern
as part of their repertoire right they
don't maybe play a modern all the time
but they can I might I don't know
[Laughter]
putting your money where your mouth is I
love it watch out the threat I know
that's what makes this year so exciting
right there's gonna be some surprises uh
people are gonna be showing some stuff
and modern I think is one of those big
oh no right we got Rasheed in the mix
but it's also like there's just a big
unknown with modern like nobody's ever
quite seen the full power so uh it's
gonna be really it'll be exciting
what's something that you know now that
you wish you knew five years ago 2017 or
something
I'm gonna get a little bit deep
I hate that
I wish I had known people show love in
different ways like not everyone loves
the same way that you love and I didn't
really understand that I saw a lot of
people from different cultures even from
here from America you know and I I saw
them as dry because in my country
everybody's like really warm they go
they're really confident that you that
you like them they don't have a
self-awareness so the USA everybody's
like you know a good looks or you know
keep keep doing your thing I was like
wow they're they're not really my
friends you know they're what are they
doing and the more I kept uh interacting
with everybody the more I kept being
here I was like Wow people really follow
what I do and a lot of them care about
what's happening with me but they just
have different ways of showing it you
know sometimes it's just it's just words
of encouragement and sometimes it's just
it's just a gift they think about you oh
man you want to go eat or whatever and a
lot of them just wash your things wash
your streams they support every match
and I wish I had known that before you
know I thought a lot about what people
were saying about me and I just focus on
the bad things but I realized like the
people that do the good things they they
they do the actions you know they
support you and every time I got that
support every time people clap for me
every time they like my posts every and
all of those things I didn't see them
and I wish I had known that before I
will have I would have been happier all
those times you know I think that's
Super Wise right and that's one of my
favorite things about the fighting game
community and always has been it's just
right seeing people from all over the
place that have their own form of
respect their own form of disrespect yes
right like both uh goes both ways
um and and finding those Common Grounds
and finding people pay respect to each
other and that's always one of my
favorite things about these big
tournaments is for as much as we all
have favorites right like the crowd is
cheering for a hype play they want a
good match at the end of the day right
like they have their favorites but
everybody's just cheering for something
great to happen yes
it is when we're talking about like
I don't know
this is this is starting to get a lot
but when I saw your investment back into
the community in the Dr uh when you won
the first big prize from Capcom cup
um that was super meaningful to me
um
just because
there's a there's a little tradition of
trying to give back but you did a lot of
great things and helped players from Dr
go out and play and have a good place to
play back home
but you
you raise the floor for everybody right
you set expectations at a new place and
you created not just a good thing or a
good time but you created opportunity
and that meant a lot to me because it's
I think that's what
um yeah has been one of the most
meaningful Parts about Evo for me is
it's been such an opportunity for a lot
of people so when I see that coming from
a younger generation it's it's pretty
great how do you think about what it is
you want to give back to the community
and how do you want to think about your
what do you want to accomplish with all
that what do you want the
the fgc and you're part of it to look
like in in a few years
honestly I've been thinking about this a
lot
about what I'm gonna do after I stop
being a player I know it's early you
know I I but I've been thinking about
that like what am I going to do I'm
sorry I'm a player how can I how can I
help and I went back to how it all
started you know why did I start playing
and I realized I started playing because
I wanted to I wanted to share with my
friends that I was having fun and that
we could kick it together and
I realized like how big uh the FTC has
become a part of my life such an
important part of my life after the
pandemic I was like man I'm home I miss
everybody I miss the strangers that I'm
gonna meet
and I just want the FTC to
keep growing and that more people can
live the same experience that I had it's
been so magical you know my life all the
people that I've known and I want more
people to know that there's a space that
you can do that you know you don't even
need to play fighting games to be part
of the FTC it's funny I met so many
people I just like to watch they just
like to watch they just like being here
and the world needs that the the world
has a lot of people that they they're
alone and and they want to meet
people they want to have fun they want
to find the meaning of what they're
doing here in this life and I feel like
the FTC helped me they gave me a space
in life and I want more people to find
that so I just wanted to grow more
you're killing me here I'm gonna
try and keep it together I think that's
uh
yeah incredibly powerful like how do you
how do you judge that is it that by the
performance like what does progress look
like to you is it seeing more Dr players
traveling is it seeing is it do you
judge by performance in a tournament you
know it's a hard thing there's a lot of
a lot of things that can happen in big
tournaments and so it's very can be
inconsistent how do you measure progress
and how do you feel like you're tracking
towards what's most important to you
well it's when I have a multiple Circles
of people in my life I have people from
all walks of life in my life people that
you know uh they focus on on their
college people that work in business
people that are like you know not doing
so good when all of them start talking
to me about fighting games
and it's not about me it's like oh I saw
the new game I was like wait what why is
my uncle talking to me about scorpion
every time I see people get more
invested into it and I see like more
friends that don't know anything about
fighting games getting into it it's like
the product is good people like this and
I feel like it's been growing look at
this look at us we're sitting here I
don't even know where my friends are I
can't I don't know where Kaaba is I
don't know where nobody the whole room
is full of friends it's full of friends
it's full of people that that enjoy
fighting games and this is progress this
is progress
yeah that's how I think about it I mean
there's there's numbers but it's the
feeling in the room that's what I always
every time there was a big change in Evo
or something happened or just in any
tournament
if there's that feeling in the room
we're okay uh that's what matters games
games come and go you talked a lot about
uh
uh loneliness uh and lonely people and I
think trying to fight loneliness has
been
a big deal a big part of this
one thing that's a part of that like
to avoid loneliness you need different
parts different people at different
points in your life right at some
distance a closer
what about the family how important has
that been to you
did your parents support what you were
doing no at the first no
um I don't know I don't know if most
people knew this but academically I
wasn't really good like I got into
college when I was 15 and I was
projected to like finish being an
engineer when I was 19. so my parents
were like big on that you know you got
to do this uh this is the this is the
path we have set for you and I think
you're gonna do good and I was like I
don't like this you know maybe if I if I
had the knowledge I have now maybe it
will have been different but
I'm glad it happened you know because
life is not all about being safe life is
not all about doing what you're supposed
to do but it's what you want to do is
how you feel happy and I feel happy here
and when they saw that they love it here
my mom saw my set right now she's in the
hospital uh taking care of something and
she sent me a text message oh you got
three perfects oh my God I was like wow
really uh and my dad was like you got to
pick up JP my dad told me like my dad
told me
um in in 2017. is he right by the way
yes okay I need to figure out okay he
said he told you in 2017. in 2017 he
told me like yo if you don't if you
don't win Captain Club if you don't make
something out of this gaming thing I'm
gonna put you like in the military
you're gonna you're gonna do something
and now he's talking to me about
matchups
you know it's so it started with threats
yes I feel I feel the support now and I
feel like everybody should always think
like they have a balance I need
something safe I need to survive but I
also need to be happy I need to do
things that I like and I know that
yourself or your friends your family
they will be happy if you're happy
you said a lot of things there
um
maybe maybe this is the same answer but
what does I think at the beginning right
like
you came on it had such incredible
undeniable success now I have a second
Capcom cup under your belt many other
wins CEO just recently
what does respect look like this was a
thing that I felt like was not given at
the beginning in spite of the results
right now the results are super
undeniable
what form does respect take for you
what does it look like
I think it comes as acknowledgment
um
being unknown not being recognized
people not even noticing you're there
it's it's it's pretty deep it hurts and
when people start to acknowledge you you
are part of something you're here I
think that's the biggest form of respect
you can give you know like they they
know you're there they know your life
and they know you want to do things too
so I I know before when people used to
like Boo me and go against me uh I will
be so tired like wow you know I don't
even know you and now
I I see it as such a sign of respect
like we know you can win and we don't
want you to you know like we know you're
good at this they're afraid yeah yeah
they recognize the fear yeah we hate you
because you can do what we don't want
you to do so I see it as respect when
they cheer for me too you know but yeah
just acknowledgment for me is like the
biggest sign of respect uh I've seen in
the FTC
and in life in general
I think we're getting to the end of our
time
let's let's end on uh gratitude you've
been talking a lot this time about
things that are important in your life
and
what when you think of the fgc and you
think of your time here what
what's the Gratitude like for you what
what gives you that feeling of of
gratitude or what are you grateful for
I'm grateful I have something to look
forward to every day that I wake up
every day that I wake up I have friends
to think about
I have
self-improvement to think about I have
events I have places to go in the world
opportunities and I have a chance
to change the world and to inspire
people and people see themselves in in
what I'm doing and I can send a positive
message like I have a I have the
platform but at the same time I'm part
of it like I I receive
what I'm giving like if I try to help
more people will help back and even if I
don't help more people are just helping
me it amplifies yes so I'm really really
grateful I have something to look
forward to in my life and honestly like
the way my life has been
I'm not even like I think God has done
enough for me I'm a firm believer so
I think my life has been too good and
I'm just grateful for for the time that
I've that I've been here
I think that about says it all
um please join me in giving a hand to
Mana Rd
a lot of wisdom here today thank you so
much
right don't go anywhere because we're
gonna take a quick break and right after
we're gonna have an exciting skull girls
exhibition right here on stage we'll see
you soon
Chipotle order just got extra the
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code hdkn 236 and received
250 fighter coins with yours visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details
sir perhaps a new hunting ground
Creighton wants a hunt I'll give him one
he'll never forget better take him out
before they find the lizard
ship won't quit I do not want to be
lizard food
PlayStation
Red Bull gives you wings
oh no
super Lola
Victory feels good
[Music]
them
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
my voice my voice
when it's the only option second is
[Music]
the beginning
number one contender
's jars on the floor
has revered like art on the wall if they
ain't in the know better keep them
informed Evolution's constant and this
ain't my final form
[Music]
brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
[Music]
thank you
until last time
believe
[Music]
yeah
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends all
born in the myths are forever when they
pin our Lord
shadow
s
[Music]
is everything
yourself worthy I live in the impact as
soon as I push forward and tell them to
hold that roll back I don't see any
limit they're lacking the vision and
asking why the hell I would risk it I'm
basically different I'm everything they
say that is
to move on as soon as all the pressure
gets too strong feel like I was born
here for something to prove wrong what
was that moment when you felt that sound
I heard the crowd Shake ground screaming
one more round let the lights flash over
the main stage I'm still Brave battling
the Giants are still made the real face
that's that choice ignite the fire of a
brand new age when they hear my voice
[Music]
through a sky
my soul keeps Rising as I sing my songs
[Music]
all right I know everybody at home and
the building's gotta be excited for this
one please let's give it up to the kill
sage and Sonic Fox as they compete in
this 1v1 exhibition Munoz and Kai let's
take it away
everybody Welcome to beautiful Las Vegas
Nevada home of Evo 2023 and of course
today's skull girls exhibition between
two players you know and love my name is
Kai Kennedy I'm joined by the one and
only Mr mix Masters himself Munoz
yeah how you doing Kai uh so we're gonna
have a special exhibition here between
Sonic Fox and the kill stage uh EG's
finest Evil Geniuses and they're gonna
be showing off Marie solo Marie a
character that's in pre-alpha right now
so
we're still working on her for a little
bit and
seeing how she's gonna be playing on the
set yeah exactly so you're going to see
some some uh some unclean frames but
some really awesome action we're
actually gonna go to two first two
freeze today the first first of three is
going to be a solo Marie match we want
to see all that action the second first
to three is going to be with Maria
inside of a team shell so I'm very
excited to see these matches I don't
think there's much else to do but get
right into the action to kill Sage
versus Sonic Fox Marie exhibition are
you guys feeling excited out there
that's what I like to hear oh yeah the
crowd noise oh man so I think we're
gonna see some really cool things we're
going to walk you through what we see on
I've been following the players watched
some of the footage that they've had as
they've had a chance to play with this
build so you're not just gonna see them
flailing around on these buttons they
actually do know a couple tricks they
want to pull off so if you see something
hyped that you don't understand what
just happened I want you to Make Some
Noise anyway because it's probably sick
right so just let's just see what we see
about as y'all yeah we're almost in the
same boat as everybody else when we see
something be like what happened yeah
Marie's been nothing but like surprises
for me because I've been like you know
trying to be spoiler free on the
character like I like to be Hands-On
when I you know
see a new character in the game so it's
gonna be nice to see all right jump
right into with that solos so of course
that laser assist doesn't have an active
hitbox on the blue beam itself it causes
hitboxes on the explosion yeah the shock
waves cause explosions you're gonna need
to pick the right one with the intensity
the button light medium and heavy put it
further or closer to you
also that's how you get the throw pick
up on throw the uh the vacuums suck it
spits them all the way across the stage
so you've got to use heavy laser to pick
up off that throw oh yes I need to see
the throw animation too so yes yes all
right so sage and Sonic are masters of
The Craft when it comes to this game
they pick up characters within seconds
they probably both know how to play the
whole roster so seeing uh both of them
uh try out the characters can be very
exciting nice nice Annie t-shirt you can
grab that in the back of the booth over
there yeah be sure to head to school
girls Booth to pick up that merch so you
too can look like famous players Sonic
Fox that shirt is fire I'm sorry
I think that's half the deal you also
will be just as good as Sonic if you buy
that shirt oh yeah oh definitely the
merch helps
all right so all right so we've got some
we've got some thumbs up some
we've got some really good pallets so
far too you might you might recognize
some references oh word yeah
got some Flags some representations
around the world too
it's good stuff
all right all right dive in it it's
waiting for the mood to be right yeah
kicking it back over here okay so
there's a lot of things that you're
going to see from Marie that are
actually pretty awesome and that is the
intensity of the button on the specials
has always been something that when you
play Skull girls you know Light Special
heavy special they all have different
utilities than what they are but the big
ones are that they're pretty obvious for
when you call Hildegard with a heavy
button it's either going to be further
away or longer charge up right so
hildegard's punch that'll hold for
longer and be more powerful when they're
heavy you can just hold that well it's
when you use it when you use um heavy
kick for Hill guards punch that means
it's going to stay out longer oh it's
different okay timings on the timings if
you use light version it works inside of
a combo if it's heavy you can actually
maybe get a little side switch action
it's kind of like a bit of a dollar
store assist set up there you might
actually see that because light swirl or
twirl which is a sort of assassin style
leaning Iron Mountain you know the
shoulder strike that you see in a lot of
games
she's got baji Quan she's got shoulder
strike and when you do like shoulder
strike it has no hitbox it just switches
sides it kind of zooms the other side
almost like a cancel cerebella Concho
right yeah
so man when you see that oh man are we
in it are we going it's like it oh no
okay
double check double check double triple
check always make sure so I've already
seen some stuff I don't want to spoil it
for you but you might see some pretty
schmancy uh side switch shenanigans that
will get people hyped I'm open for it
let's get to it all right so who's on
the left of the right I think that we
wait I see it there I think it's Sonic
on the right and then Sage on the left
yep
Sonic and Canon colors yeah oh wow what
a starter
you can get
oh really suck
what side up switch aside too far though
nice but don't reset all right so the
medium leaning Mountain medium shoulder
is plus enough to link but it's also
good if you want to do like just
basically a stop reset oh I see also
never heard the song before either so
this is a really good
nice and we see it again enough to link
oh oh we got double Hildegard we got
double little card oh no does she care
about undizzy guy
she has no care from Disney oh that's
also scary
nice reach out half a life bar
come on Sonic let's set this started
okay
going on with that laser my starter here
medium shoulder strike is actually Plus
on block that's its utility light has no
hitbox It Gets behind you medium is plus
heavy is armored so her air throw
literally just sets into the corner in
wall Splats basically yes yes yes it's
extremely Fair
oh nice reset
very close that's a reversal okay we'll
take it
nice combo here nice to stagger with
heavy shoulder this should kill
please kill
I'm not a liar let's go
back on oh a chip oh okay
oh armor
and she's dead
all right Sonic Fox taking the first one
in this solo set going up to nothing
exactly oh man
you're seeing a lot of shoulder like
situations where they're both on the
shoulder I want to go plus but I'm armor
so I go through you so it's about kind
of the mind game when you have this solo
set like this
she also seems to have like decent
disjoints too yep all right Justin goes
out
Oh that's oh that's it's like Rachel
from blazeboot so it sticks out there
yeah so anything that that uh that
Maurice summons will go away when she is
hit so it won't just save you please
that needs to be Universal right right
looking at certain characters you know
what I'm saying certain privilege
characters oh double hell really I put
you in stone that that that uh suction
animation from the vacuum yep oh
nice the SE three nice exactly you get
that stagger you do a little tick throw
there
little miniature launcher standing light
punch has a lot of hits yeah it looks
like she doesn't have an air Dash and
what I'm noticing now she can double
jump out of some stuff though oh that's
yeah yeah that's that too
man some like delayed like jump Combos
and stuff like that
so her jumping heavy punch actually
pulls both the attacker and the defender
backwards so you can either choose to
like follow it up with say like medium
punch to Rocket you forward again or
jump out of it and cancel into another
normal so there's a lot of combo route
utility and opportunity oh wow inside of
those jump combos oh got a little one
that super looks safe seriously the
Spirit Bomb
Soul bomb let's say yeah right yeah
nice pickup nice medium into the link
good link pulling it back
and gotta finish now
that looks active heck oh and again with
the armor
we can spend as much meter as you want
to here okay this is super I did see oh
my Lord yeah
you can spend more and more and more
meter as you want to basically confirm
the kill yeah though this character
could definitely play armor against
armor get out of here oh to the corner
pick it up going in oh Mission too far
too far
over there again throwing the dust
bunnies out throw some lasers
yeah it's gonna mix some people up that
Laser's gonna come out and be like oh no
is that gonna hit me it's like no that's
not the hitbox buddy you're gonna have
to be able to learn and identify
visually is that the one for me do I
jump into it out of it all that
say it's fighting back there Sage
fighting back even it up one two one
he tweeted out earlier how nervous he
was
good you're good you're doing great
sweetie
all right
not wondering which one of her like
standing normals is the overhead is it
the giant swing one or is it the motion
just body slams of the skeleton standing
heavy punch maybe an overhead okay
or it might be crouching medium heavy
which is the the skulls and flex that is
a signal by the way
see that Marie's a huge wrestling fan
yeah
suplex City all these lasers nice that's
when he comes out yeah I'm gonna get him
yeah I'm noticing that the the short
range laser is also good for like uh
grounded coverage for approaches and
stuff it's delayed so she can still move
it if she doesn't and we're gonna finish
here with some meter nice
that's a green Life part no she's just
like the sick of supers in the game
like a spare bomb uh skeleton punch move
the meter burn uh wall slamming is like
it's all six though
truly a best character
oh when you can use that for screen
covers too so you can like blind your
mix up like
oh
insane what could happen if you put this
character on a team oh yeah we're about
to see that after like Yeah The Works
this is a good picture from Sonic here
oh nice punish
oh get off me
okay we're scrambling here oh nice
not enough
oh so she gets three reps off one bar
from one on those if I'm not mistaken it
gets it's sequentially more expensive
the longer you just keep it going so
basically like the ninth hit is you know
a lot very expensive compared to those
first right all right so he's looking
like a Marie Master over here with this
character oh yeah two seconds worth
actually so one of the things you'll see
a lot and it has so many different
situations is the Crouch heavy punch is
that skull suplex where she she likes as
a skeleton that pops them up off the
ground and you can cancel that into a
Hildegard special and then continue the
combo after it's been after the special
which means you can create a situation
where the mix or combo is done very very
differently after that Crouch heavy
Punch Yeah so versatile like many other
characters in the game just do whatever
you want open world game high degree of
Freedom yeah
right there exactly doing that light
punch to sort of create an opportunity
to jump in didn't quite work yeah
some of her buns kind of like drag in
the air too so she can just set up some
mix
it's very important like
uh for for mid-screen Stuff
oh the skeleton we got just a little bit
away oh nice side switch of course that
is yeah light shoulder strike has no
hitbox dude she is like mini locking
mode I love it
man imagine if cerebell can switch sides
it's autocorrect oh no way
oh wow
launcher okay
let's not get on the corner I think that
was an overhead oh that was fun
that funny
oh nice pick up thank you buddy
it looks like you're going to shoot one
at a time right yes ah okay you can only
have one last glue rabbit out at one
time
true Looney Tune mix with that that
Looney Tune mix yes I can't stress how
how great it is to see like all these
characters like jumping into the game
after like two years yes or DLC it's a
long life man a long life and they look
like they just fit right in like
like they've been here for years
oh well okay yeah try it so what
happened there is you want to use
multiple medium kicks to raise the
height of the character so then you do
Spirit Bomb it gets the most it's
impossible because it does not stop
until you hit the ground in power yeah
they're trying to set that up first
very nice Sonic extremely strong taking
this one all the way to game five we're
gonna see a game five on this one oh boy
my favorite
excellent if you're out there and you've
got a favorite let them know Make some
noise
[Applause]
oh wow the quick side switch stuff
cycle for insane plus pressure Here solo
mind you yes get out here with that
armor yes
conversion
excellent yeah so a lot of combo rides
are going to have that extremely
reliable jump light punch into jump
medium punch conversion because the rug
snacks them down towards the ground just
a little bit yeah so you can get back
those re-stand moments oh nice research
here Sage looks like he wants a nice
inner stagger he's the one this
you can spend the meter here oh yeah
nicely done
looking very strong clean very strong oh
nice yeah and again the rug puts them
right on the ground get on the ground so
I can combo you
oh man
50 coats are we out
nice
dagger would say it's gonna do in the
corner with this
is some oh
just a tip yeah oh oh okay I almost
float over for that over like Princess
Peach double Hilby
because that's a lot of meter just gotta
stun him right here yeah go into it oh
what
oh Yoshi safe what
tries to go the plush
are we out
[Music]
says you really wants out this corner
here it's a one hit for sage because oh
look at all that meter oh yeah
nice pickup that late laser hit right
there like the Finish light bar
tail end of that hit
dunzo nice over even or even
now lasers lasers
that's kind of a way to to play around
action
oh oh okay we're out
there's some bunnies on man you need to
you need some friends
oh that's not good for sage oh drops the
combo
it's good he push them away and we're
out the land cancel yeah that cancels
all of the guards done that was in air
that block sun is gone when you touch
down Oh wrong Hildegard yeah I think you
want a laser there
wait it's not gonna spend it all here
expenditures
no she's dead you're done no way what a
finish and Sonic wins all right Sonic
takes the first first two three all
right Victorious fox in the house we are
moving on now to the team set where we
will see Marie as part of a team
composition here very nice all right so
you saw we got that finish exactly as we
talked about multiple jump uh medium
kicks and Pops them up Pops them up and
then you're way up there okay and we
finally saw it towards the end yeah it's
so much damage yes and that's that's the
thing that when this character comes out
and everybody's learns their combo
routes that's going to be something you
see consistent when you want to Spirit
Bomb you got to get them real high
amplitude it's got to be way up here off
screen you got to get up there yeah
so let's check and see exactly what we
got here it looks like we're gonna have
maybe philia and and who else do I see
back there
Annie and yes gonna be on one side Annie
on the other and we will see the assist
game come out so this is obviously
something that changes it a lot when you
have a character that can project
something out there so right now we have
characters like peacock right you can
get George out there as an assist it can
confound a lot of game plans where you
go well okay man I just blocked it but I
can't even what can I do now nothing
right now you see something where
Hildegard could come with lasers punches
he may be played offense armored
shoulder strike all these things change
the dynamic a lot and it's something you
may not be used to because that's the
thing even heavy Lock and Load even
heavy brass these aren't moves that
leave him stunned the combo conversion
off those is sometimes not not so solid
but let's pretend you get heavy shoulder
strike in there that thing leaves you
stunned for a hot minute you're always
getting that combo oh man yeah that's
gonna create some crazy mix here we're
gonna see this I think Sage is rocking
hairball for this one too so imagine you
blocking hairball you get pushed to the
corner and then like re-shooting lasers
at you man like
oh
whoa right jumping
yeah
maybe we might see a double snap
showcased here
's double shot looks like nice nice
throw oh that's a pickup unfortunately
all right mix
State plus there can you see the
skeleton in the background he was like
no I got hit
I love these animations
set up again she just armors that
met you call an assist with that I know
she's armors and it's like it just comes
out oh that tag animation oh that's
that's also that's tight cool about
seeing here with a team here nice reset
so what's cool about the super
if you're Crouch blocking when that
comes out oh no they gave her an
overhead super and that's that's
definitely don't you ever block low on
me don't ever block me
damage damn
it there's so much towards the end
get back it up
nice throw
oh Dust Bunny goes out yeah she may need
an assist to pick up with those there
okay we're down to Philly that's not a
lot like hey some Fair neutral incomes
some classic skills don't get hit
oh she's flushed oh
come on come on you're stuffing up to
oh not the donkey punished
don't do it Sonic oh my God they're
gonna do it
this character costs ten dollars by the
way
let's go Eddie
Sonic said that Annie is their character
so they've proven it just like all right
enough of that
all right now we're gonna see uh
exactly so let's see what Marie has to
offer in terms of uh being the second
character here
right I mean especially on such a strong
character like Annie Annie already has a
lot of potential to get in on you now
you throw one extra layer of explosions
or or skeleton Fists
yeah how am I supposed to block this
oh boy
all right say he's getting started here
too
other side you thought you were safe
you're not safe
up there the overhead gets both ah too
far other side though you're done not
quiet the pain of hairball assistance
it's just gonna push him away whenever
you get something started there
trying to go for movement here and
calling hairball oh what a pickup from
Sonic
it's gonna be a run to reset away to the
kill here
level three damage though hold on
oh no
all right so off of level three hit I
noticed that's also tackables that's not
hard knockout off of level three so
important key to note there you can Tech
when you're when you get hit by it
level three nice rehearsal
all right down the classic skull girls
again with uh the Philly and Annie
oh the DP gets him
should be a kill nicely done there for
sage tying it up 1-1 very nice and we
find ourselves at 1-1 yet again it's
almost like these are both really good
players that's so strange yeah it's like
these guys are evil Champions it's so
weird like wow like what it's like we
saw my Grands last year like what
exactly is this seeming familiar to
anyone no but if you close your eyes
now this is the perennial match oh man
I'd love to see it
all right we're heading back to Marie
point to see some assistant damage
oh wow let's stop this
so that that shoulder tackle move is
that also a special move of hers
motorcycle back punch all right right
okay
uh plus I'm black or armored oh yeah
insane move the giver I wonder like what
was like
full properties we've seen both of them
do it where you're gonna get more height
by using jumping medium punch to save
your double jump okay it's really
interesting
that move where she like just rotates
the vacuum and hits you in Wall Street
nothing heavy kicking yeah I was gonna
say you can either just do it or hold it
to get the wall bounce yeah no insane
stuff insane set up there
[Music]
Tennessee
said you can wipe them clean with this
combo
can't block forever
oh sir
I just kind of gets the hit here against
the corner
oh the skeleton oh nice it scraps her
that reaches so far
insane move same move
oh no you don't want the bunny in there
with the assistance
that's cheap
get a creative mode here so the bunny
doesn't like actually attack you for
something like 90 frames right yeah it
stays out for about a second
but
now Bunny and then Hildegard and the
bunny arrives after Hildegard oh no
we're getting Cheaper by the year okay I
swear
nice double jump
I'm a huge fan of moving in uh Team
games like this yes when they use that
to like get around certain situations oh
nice pick up off the pillar
and goodbye Marie's we'll see you later
uh oh not again don't let it happen to
you again not again history repeats
itself time is a flashlight
okay just ready
all right stays up two one oh
sorry yeah I was ready for that come on
come on come on I love that
I know that
again the stage is amazing and that song
is also amazing they did a really good
job with this
I can't wait for this character to drop
whenever she's available
all right so he's using those little
footy jumps in to get in
nice pickup
uh go alone in the corner the classic we
said for school girls players
nice DP assist
that looked like a little car mode I was
like where's the reset Point what do you
mean I missed it okay that that hasn't
worked even once it's been sniffed out
every time but you can see but using
Hildegard to float him jump over and uh
cross up it's it's a standard thing
you've seen a million times but this
character has the potential to do it
from almost anywhere oh nice attack nice
man that button is so good it vacuums
nice air throw resets honest to go into
town with this one
suspended she is gone Alpha counter
that's what we want to see
yes utilize the tools oh level three
damage we just want it nice kill
it's an amazing pickup I wonder what the
race that's gonna be
fine Sonic smashes the meter out oh no
oh that almost happened almost the
trinity
[Music]
let's pick up one reset away
good block there nose Crossing was
coming
Sonic Relentless with the pressure
though let's go girl
the two of the fastest players in the
game man so they making the finals they
took every time nice pickup from stage
though hold on the stage gonna finish it
here
nice
simple combo here and Sage is gonna take
this set all right guys respect and we
go one set apiece give it up for the
kill sage and Sonic Fox
other times man no I know and if you
thought that was all we had today well
oh then I have bad or good news
depending on how you want to take it
because that is not all we have to show
you we have something a surprise for me
we have a surprise a secret a gift for
you it's time to check it out watch up
on screen and be amazed yes sir
and Sonic Fox takes it three to two in a
nail biter I don't think I could have
written a better Grand Final set than
that
[Music]
[Applause]
we back baby this is right a fully
offline skull girls Pro Tour yes it is
back yet again it's going to be leading
all the way up to our favorite
Tournament of course also run by private
people that means that if you want to
come out to tournaments in January all
the way up through May and June that all
of those are going to be part of the
points there and of course we've got
purse we've got points and we've got
prizes for everybody outperforming this
one is fully under our control and we
are going to run this thing straight
into the Sun so make sure to go to at
school girls and get all the news you
can because skull girls Pro Tour is back
yes that's what I've been waiting for we
needed this to happen for the scene man
and that's what's so great all the big
tournaments run by people that you know
and love out there making the community
strong these are going to be Points
events we still have more details before
we tell you exactly where and when and
when but trust me when I say it's gonna
be awesome man oh man excited to see
that one back hey just they can hear you
right now do you guys like that
[Applause]
remember to show support for this one
because skull girls is still strong here
in 2023 10 more years Man 10 more years
Go Girls exactly all right well I think
that's all we've got for right now Munoz
any thoughts on what we just saw
Great Character showcase there from both
players uh the season passes has been
wonderful I've just been like falling in
love with the game all over again it's
like since I've been playing since 2014
uh been a part of the scene been hosting
events and uh
yeah just excited for the future of the
game man this is gonna be great
hopefully I hope to see all y'all there
and uh to be a part of the scene more
like I host so many events uh follow me
on Twitter explicit there yeah
um
every Thursday we do mixed matches
online we're gonna introduce a mix
Masters for the scene for South America
and Europe as well
of America and mix Masters Europe that
you heard it right here that's so cool
and the expansion and one more big event
happening in December in New York City
at OS NYC we're gonna be able to hosting
big Masters which is like the biggest
mixed messages
follow us more the kill sage and me as
well are proud of mixed matches I want
you guys to be a part of it as well so
just hit us up and we'll we'll get you
there excellent all right well we
reached the conclusion hey they don't
want me to tell you this but you might
want to keep uh an eye on maybe some
more news not too far in the future
there's more there's maybe some more no
okay no no I'll stop I'll stop I won't
say anymore chill okay we're done we're
done all right thank you guys so much
make one more round of applause for
skull girls baby
all right we will see you tomorrow at
the community tournament thank you and
have a good weekend don't miss it y'all
that Sizzle that's the soundtrack of
Chipotle the soundtrack of Chipotle oh
yeah you come in you're gonna be hearing
that Sizzle that's how you know that we
always have fresh food
fresh is what you stand for exactly
[Music]
oh no
super Lola
Victory feels good
she over there
[Music]
thank you
registration for Capcom Pro Tour is now
open over 2 million dollars is on the
line for the season with the first place
prize of one million dollars to the
Capcom cup 10 champion
winners of the online and offline
Premiere events will also Auto qualify
for a spot at Capcom cup 10. open to all
players in good standing so check out
capcomprotour.com for scheduling and to
find a qualifying tournament in your
area
[Music]
till I fly in ways you can't believe
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my song
[Music]
brush it down
next
I'll be strong prove myself
[Music]
here we go
foreign
[Music]
laughs
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends all
born and the myths are forever when they
pin our Lord
inside of the room the world clear I
feel all the hopes inside of the same
fear
[Music]
s
is never worthy I live in there impact
as soon as I push forward and tell them
to hold that roll back I don't see any
limits they lacking the vision and
asking why the hell I would risk it I'm
basically different I'm everything they
say that I hated the arcade era living
to move on as soon as all the pressure
gets too strong feel like I was born
here for something to prove wrong what
was that moment
screaming one more round let the lights
flash over the main stage I'm still
Brave battling the Giants are still made
the real face that's that choice ignite
the fire of a brand new
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
this is the beginning imagine your boy
you're level two
still coming against
Shore number one Contender as soon as
they hit the door
on the plus but beard like art on the
wall if they didn't know they
know then Evolution's constant
constant final form
[Music]
the soul keeps Rising as I sing my song
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all alone
[Music]
please welcome to the stage the creator
of Rivals of Aether as well as a studio
lead for Aether Studios Dan Fortis
bye everyone
foreign
[Music]
it's up to me
foreign
[Music]
Maple returns to Rivals 2 as the fastest
character in the game so far
insane Dash and run speed make her
difficult to pin down
her donut air Dodge from Rivals 1
returns as well but this time it's
paired with an adorable wave Dash
animation
another unique feature turned to Maple
is her wall cling
while all characters and Rivals too can
wall jump Maple can hold the jump button
to cling to the wall
Maple's normal attacks complement her
awesome ground speed
her job is to repeating hits with no
finisher and is one of the best Jabs in
the game for setting up Jab resets
her Dash attack is great for a burst of
speed
her get up attack is a great get off me
tool
and her ledge attack has more range than
any other in the game so far along with
two hits that can catch unfamiliar
opponents who drop Shield too early
a new addition to Maple's forward tilt
and Rivals 2 means you can now angle it
up or down when attacking
Maple's down tilt is another quick way
to pop opponents up into the air
her up tilt actually has a surprising
amount of range as it creates two vines
on either side of her to attack up while
she ducks
while Maple's ground attacks complement
her speed it's her Aerials that push her
over the top as a rush down Menace
her neutral air is the perfect attack to
start a combo out of a short hop
her back hair has amazing Frame data
her fare is one of the best Edge guards
in the game
and her down air is one of the most
unique Aerials in the genre creating a
root projectile on the ground directly
beneath Wherever You Are
and finally her classic upbear returns
as a great move for juggling and killing
off the top
while her normals are quick and
frequently low range Maple strong
attacks are the exact opposite both
forward strong and up strong are slow
but come with massive range to catch
opponents
her downstrong has less range but more
speed and it synergizes incredibly well
into her Tech chasing game
the seed is back from Rivals of ether
this projectile is a foundation for
Maple's game plan toss it at an opponent
to mark them once marked any strong
attacks the Eland will wrap the opponent
the more damage they have the longer the
wrap then it's up to Maple Lawn if she
wants to extend her combo or wrap up the
stock
the Watchers Dash is a fantastic special
move for offense and Recovery as she can
still initiate a walkling even though
she's in free fall after using this
special
her forward special marks opponents when
it hits and can even be reversed with
some skillful timing
our favorite plant companion is back in
Rivals too Lily returns with all of her
actions from Rivals including bite rap
and Perry Stone
but she also has a new counter where
opponents can attack Lilly to briefly
stun her in order to combat Maple
players camping next to Lily and shield
Lily will also redirect your seeds up
into the air if you throw one her way
down special in the air is a downward
Watcher's Dash this special has a brief
stall at the start so it's a great way
to mix up your approach
it's also a great recovery tool because
you can surprise your opponent on the
path to the wall
Maple's up special is a simple yet
incredibly useful recovery option it's
also one of the best aerial kill moves
in the game
Maple can combo into it but needs to be
confident because she's a Sitting Duck
if it whiffs
Maple's recovery gets really interesting
when you mix in the tether recovery
unlike Rivals 1 the current input in
Rivals 2 is attack plus special at the
same time to initiate a tether
this allows players to hold a direction
of left right or up while initiating the
tether
depending on the input Maple will appear
either to a side or above the nearest
marked player
Maple can even use this mid combo to
catch up to opponents and KO them off
the top
Maple's get up special is a fantastic
way to change up the pace of The Mensch
While most get-up attacks are relatively
quick and share the same frame data
Maples get up special attack is delayed
she also jumps up during the startup and
Dodges most low-hitting attacks the
special also marks if it connects
Maple's ledge special is a new plant
companion named Terry
Maple stays on the ledge but Terry
spawns and attacks on stage Maple can
throw seeds at Terry to make him attack
again or she can tether to Terry after
super deep edge guards
Maple's special Pummel is another new
plant companion named Poppy poppy is
legitimately my favorite character in
the game now
attaches poppy to the opponent's back if
the special Pummel is successful
she can then toss a seed at the opponent
to pop poppy causing the opponent to be
knocked the opposite way they are
currently facing
Maple's speed and her new tools make her
quite the threat on the battlefield
we're extremely proud of how she's
playing and we can't wait to see what
players can do when they get their hands
on Rivals too in 2024.
it's awesome to have a platform fighter
on stage I mean the variety of different
styles is what makes this community so
special all right we're going to quickly
throw it on over to vicious for an
interview on the floor
thanks guys vicious here with EVO
connections presented by a t I am here
with a man of many different talents as
well as a player of many games we got
Jake Ryan here at Evo now I do have to
ask people being a man of so many
talents and obviously many games who are
some of the players that you have
connected with here at Evo or are
looking to connect with considering how
many different games play so I love that
I've had the opportunity so far in the
reversal TNS Suite to connect with
players like Angry Bird Big Bird Mana Rd
some of the strongest players in the
entire world especially for Street
Fighter 6 showing up to the largest
Street Fighter event we've ever had and
I'm so excited to meet all these other
players in bracket if I get out of pools
my first match is Phenom one of the best
Kens in the world and being able to play
that mirror match and see how I shape up
I think that's what Evo is all about
because even though I've got top eights
in other games Street Fighter is a new
beast and I'm coming back from four
played a lot of five and six I feel like
is the time to shine and playing all
these players across the world is where
we can do it and that's kind of like one
of the most intimidating things to go
into it but it's also the most exciting
gameplay but I do have to ask you for
the whole book of editor I need to know
the tech what did you do to prepare
yourself for Evo this year
watching what's on a mod review to see
exactly what play Styles I'm going to be
clashing with what my strengths are how
my strengths are exemplified in those
matches and what weaknesses I need to
shore up and putting that all together
to be successful in multiple games while
splitting my time I'd say it's like 40
Street Fighter 30 uh dragon ball 30
Marvel well there you have it you
already broke down the math for each and
every one of you Jake Wayne always good
to see you we can take it back all the
way to the main stage to see you there
so ever since Evo's Inception you'd be
able to see people walking around
carrying big CRTs to play games like
Rumble Fish too I mean Vortex Gallery is
still keeping the Spirit Alive over in
our community event area as well all
right let's check out so many trailers
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
that's how I feel
crazy
foreign
[Music]
a game that's been played for nearly
1500 years
finally got a new update
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
got what it takes to defeat the one true
king
Checkmate Showdown wishlist now
hey it's me it's Nick from fight.exe
here to tell you about fight.exe we got
a crazy fighting game with one button
specials that do cool things it got
input motions that do cooler things it
even got the parry and it's all got
these weird characters including me
Nick
I mentioned story mode wait
wait this isn't a fighting game
hey wow thank you so much for watching
my trailer there's a demo on Steam and
you can also wishlist it there
[Music]
you know honestly some of those games
look pretty sick they really do they've
been so many amazing trailers so far but
I'm not surprised because the indie game
Space has been knocking out of the park
when it comes to innovating and
revolutionizing the genre you know I
think it really speaks to the strength
of the fgc that there's so many of these
games that we can play but you're able
to find the one that sticks with you and
also create like excuse me around it and
then strive within that Community it's
really cool but you know what
we got some more trails to check out
before we go anywhere let's see it
make a knockdown
foreign
[Music]
thank you
you cannot possibly understand
him I will make sure you don't get up
against
stole her from
a pack that binds us
you can't survive my rock
you finally got what you deserve
listen everyone Joe does not lie we just
went through so many Indie fighting game
trailers and there's many more out there
for everyone to try I mean I don't even
know where to start absolutely you know
and also stay hanged right here because
we have plenty more Indie trailer for
you guys but first we're gonna take a
break and bring back some very special
VIPs keep a lot
your Chipotle order just got extra the
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code hdkn 236 and receive
250 fighter coins with your order visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
thank you
oh no
super Lola
Victory feels good
PlayStation
[Music]
foreign
I have a brand new when I hear my voice
[Music]
it is with incredibly great honor that I
get to bring out these next VIPs please
everybody at home and in this building
give it up for the co-founders of evil
Tom and Tony Cannon
[Applause]
uh thank you Joe for that introduction
um it's so incredible to be here uh at
Evo again
um
uh it's so nice to see all your faces
I've seen people come to this event for
literally 20 years and I see new cases
every year and this Evo is particularly
special for Tony and I because of course
you know uh we've taken a step back and
let a new team Carry On The Legacy and
we're so proud of what they've done to
put on the biggest Evo yet so a huge
warm congratulations to the Evo team
show them your love please
so we are delighted with the scale of
this event and and how
um it's become like a global family
reunion for the FTC
but this is
not possible without the work of so many
tournament organizers Community
organizers uh players who put their
heart and soul into rallying players at
the small scale
and we like to say support your locals
uh
it's become a model but it's more than a
model it's like a rallying cry it's how
this thing works it's all of us working
together
and we in years back uh had an award
that we wouldn't present to the unsung
heroes who were working behind the
scenes to get it done we call this Canon
award
and we put it down for a few years this
year we decided to bring it back
and so uh it's uh Tony and uh my honor
to present this year two Awards uh so
please bear with us it's going to take
you know a few minutes but we really
want to make sure that we recognize uh
these people who have given them given
their all uh to bring all of this uh for
all of us so Tony why don't you take it
away yeah yeah I'm so happy to be the
first presenter of the canyon award in
so many years
um this is a really a great story it's a
story about perseverance it's a story
about grit and determination and putting
the community Above All Else uh and
really about like support the games you
love support your locals right uh you
may know there are over 40 mil metal
events at Evo this year right there's
the nine big ones right of course but
then there's all these events in the
byoc right
um that are run by the community for the
community and the passion you see there
is no less than the passion you see for
the main games on stage uh for the
longest time a staple game in the
Community Center has been Marvel vs
Capcom right
I am happy to say
that Marvel vs Cop come will not be in
the community center this year
it won't even be on the main stage this
Friday right because you people
supported that game so well that Marvel
first Capcom will be in the arena
Sunday morning
like opening the show right it's amazing
right
this is an old game that was supported
by the community
that was brought back to life by the
spirit of the community
and uh no one worked harder to make that
happen
than our first recipient of the Canon
award
um he started off running his own local
events in Tampa in 2009 which uh grew
and has more recently transitioned to an
online event
um which is sort of a hybrid mix of
YouTube and twitch
um and uh exhibition events and
tournament events and he's worked
tirelessly behind the scenes have
practically every major you've ever
heard of he's been on the staff of CEO
for a long time he's working the event
at Evo today right uh I was just
watching an exhibition event he ran last
week for Marvel online I'm like man
you've got a on a show to prepare for
and he's just I don't know how the man
has time to sleep honestly I just don't
know how he does it um and so
I am very happy toward the first Canon
award in quite some time uh to Tong Lee
Tampa never sleeps
[Applause]
congratulations
I mean you can see it I mean that's the
passion right that's what keeps that's
what keeps it going for all of us thank
you Todd for everything you do
so we're going to keep it rolling
uh our second award
is going to go to someone uh
who is uh really stepped up
organizing tournaments uh when his local
scene lost their local
and
the scene could have died but he kept it
alive
uh he's been at it for a while
and grown his scene from a struggling
local
to one of the major tournaments every
year
he didn't stop there
is helped organize fighting game
tournaments across
lots of organizations not just his own
uh
he he's a bright colorful figure
but you always know that his heart is in
the right place and he's always fighting
for players and for the games that he
loves
uh I think the the greatest thing I can
say about this person is that the people
in his organization have gone on to do
their own great things and started their
own events and that's the mark of a
really great leader
and so it's my pleasure to announce the
second Canon award for this year
to the man whose name is a verb Alex
jabali
[Applause]
let's give it up for Alex
we're coming here and supporting us for
so many years if it's your first Evo or
if it's your your 23rd Evo like it
really means a lot to all of us
um when I reflect back
um I'm gonna get a little nostalgic and
I'll try to hold it together
um like we have come so far with all of
your support and the support of people
who run locals and people who run Majors
um and a few years ago we were looking
back and sort of reflecting on
where's the event been and where can it
go and what does it mean for people and
what can it mean for people
um
and I was talking to some people trying
to figure out how to bring it back and I
had a really great conversation with a
good friend of mine
um and who just had this vision and he's
always had Vision about a community is
not about a fiberboard cabinet that you
play on in the arcade it's not even
about the competition here although
that's a major part of it it's about how
we show up for each other and the
cultural Ties That Binds us right our
commitment you know and how it reflects
in the clothes that we wear and the
shoes that we will put on and the music
that we love and you know it's a
community that makes a community and and
no one has done that better ever
than uh my friend
um he he runs one of the most beloved
Majors ever
every year people go and say this is my
favorite event
and he runs it with a level of integrity
and passion and empathy that is unheard
of
in my experience he he understands that
as a community if we're going to win we
win together and that stands for to
standing up for TOs
it's for players sticking up for players
and it was a really great chat we
checked her for over an hour
um and uh
this guy's not afraid to speak truth to
power either a lot of people can be
intimidated by the the Mystique but he
was like you know we've made some
mistakes and like I think it was a real
big mistake for you guys to retire the
Canon award
because when he was coming out he saw
that as an aspiration he's like yes I'm
down for the community and that's
something I could strive for even if I
never reached that mountain it's
inspiring for me
and I never thought of it that way and I
recognize it
um and that's why we brought it back
um he went on to say
and I'm really disappointed because
I know that I can never win that award
now this was a conversation we had uh
when we were transitioning the
organization from Tom and I to um our
honorary third Canon award member of
awarding to to Rick Tyler
[Applause]
where's the fire
[Music]
the heart of everyone give it up for
Rick one of a kind
that's it we'll see you next year on
with the show thank you everyone take
care y'all
[Applause]
one more time please let's get over
everyone that's just one Academy what
everybody Give It Up Make Some Noise let
me hear it
[Applause]
you know it actually really is amazing
to see all these people in the community
be recognized but speaking of being
recognized we got some more Indie
fighting game trails to check out let's
cut to it
[Music]
foreign
questions
[Music]
foreign
peppers and ground acchiode balanced
with a splash of pineapple all combined
for the right amount of heat Chipotle's
all new Chicken al pastor is where fire
meets flavor
oh
thank you
[Music]
oh no
super Lola
Victory feels good
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
second is
deepest Dependable this is the beginning
when you're level two brothers
control
s on the floor has been feared like art
on the wall if they ain't in the know
better keep them from Evolution's
constant and this thing my final form
[Music]
run this back
brush it down
next
I'll be strong
[Music]
everything
here we go
thank you
[Music]
foreign
clear I feel all the hopes inside of the
same fear Shadows
[Music]
yourself worthy I live in the impact as
soon as I push forward and tell them to
hold that roll back I don't see any
limits they're lacking the vision and
asking why the hell I would risk it I'm
basically different I'm everything they
say that is
all the pressure gets too strong feel
like I was born here for something to
prove wrong what was that moment when
you felt that sound and heard the crap
Shake ground screaming one more round
let the lights flash over the main stage
I'm still Brave battling the Giants are
still made the real face that's that
choice ignite the fire of a brand new
age when I hear my voice
[Music]
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
foreign
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
still here
Corners down
[Music]
welcome everyone to the street fighter 6
panel here at Evo we're super excited
for today and uh yeah give it up for
some Street Fighters six
[Applause]
it has been a massive year for Street
Fighter am I right am I
am
absolutely and I'm Persia and I'm super
excited to be here because we've got one
heck of a panel ahead of us it has been
a long wait for Street Fighter 6 which
came out this summer and then just a few
short weeks ago now Rasheed has hit the
scene and we're going to be talking all
about it today
um so now we're here at Evo and Street
Fighter 6 is making its first
competitive debut here at this legendary
event even breaking records with the
most signups for a single bracket
tournament over a 7
000 players most of you in the crowd
right now
but yes it is going to be amazing but
let's go ahead and get to the panel
we're here with the members of the
Street Fighter 6 development team and
we're gonna speak about the recent
launch of the game along with the launch
of Rasheed and so much more is gonna be
awesome
and of course it's not a good panel
without having some giveaways and let me
tell you right now these prizes are
awesome we've had some amazing
collaborators with us to make it all
happen so make sure you put those
thinking caps on because these questions
are tough they're no joke but the prizes
are worth it so make sure you're ready
because we're gonna have our pal Andy
Wong helping us with the trivia a little
bit later on and more details on how to
answer the trivia we'll come soon so
don't worry about that but let's go
ahead and introduce our panelists we
have Street Fighter 6 director
nakayama-san all right
[Applause]
we also have Street Fighter six
producers matsumoto-san and sakuraisan
all right nice to meet you
[Music]
[Applause]
we also have sound designer and caps
gems member Terry Amazon
nice to meet you
and we have the project manager and
translator is going to be helping us out
today Hiroshi okum
all right from throwback arcade boxes to
next-gen consoles which is where we're
at right now the street fighter
franchise has had quite a riot with no
plans of stopping might I add Street
Fighter has collaborated with a few
amazing Partners this weekend and today
we're giving away those amazing prizes
so now I'm gonna give you the details on
how you could possibly win some of those
prizes so we would like to first off
give some special shout outs to
everybody who helped us get these prizes
together and we have to give some major
things to Chipotle we got some custom
skateboard decks for you guys High
Ground providing some keyboards and some
mouse pads we also have jada toys
providing some really cool figurines and
we have udon Comics providing a brand
new Street Fighter 6 comic for us as
well but the grand prize the very end so
make sure you're here until the very end
as we have a arcade cabinet from arcade
one up a Street Fighter 2 themed cabinet
which isn't coming out until the fall
and if you get that question right well
we'll send it your way right after the
event so make sure you stay tuned to the
end make sure you participate in all of
our Trivia today while we're going
through the panel all right so you heard
the prizes you know they're good and
like I said before we're testing your
Street Fighter knowledge with some of
these questions so make sure you're
paying attention Google might not help
you at this point they're that tough
all right so be sure so look to Andy
Wong the senior community manager who's
going to be helping us kick off those
trivia questions and he's going to be
also you know holding the answers he's
going to be able to tell whether you're
right or wrong so make sure you stay
tuned for that now actually I think we
should start with a giveaway right now
what do we think
[Applause]
all right sounds good where's Andy Wong
at I'm right here oh
so our first
prize for this is the Chipotle
skateboard there's a toy a collector's
edition a poster and a comic they're
gonna get right now
and we have we're pulling people from
the audience to answer the questions
these are difficult
all right you ready
this is according to the street fighter
website which two characters hate
indecisiveness
you can make a guess
I'm gonna go
I'm Gonna Go My Boy Honda Edmond Honda
and I'm gonna go jury
you're so close you got one of them
right sorry
do we have someone else that wants to
come up on stage
again the question is which two
characters hate indecisiveness
all right you look confident
you look confident
not at all
all right what it's the same question
which two characters hate indecisiveness
you got one of them right again but
that's not
it was the next victim this is on the
website you guys if you want to look it
up
all right
which two characters
[Music]
I'm bison no
none of those are right actually
creating a line here everyone all right
here we go
same question
no none of those are right it's not jury
you guys not jury it's a major hint
right there
we did hear the two names already but
not together
Chun Lane Honda it is only in Honda
congrats
all right
[Applause]
and this is all yours yeah yeah
congrats
all right back to you borsha thank you
so much Andy and now I think it's time
we go ahead and hop into the panel but
don't worry we got more trivia coming up
later but let's go ahead and get right
to it this question is for everyone in
our panel to kick it off how do you feel
now that Street Fighter 6 is out in the
public
my midnight
foreign
yeah this game has been in development
for many many years and finally it's in
the hands of of so many people so many
people that we're seeing right now so
we're all very excited that this is this
is happening thank you
and now this one is going to be for
nakayama-san
um what were some major goals that you
were trying to achieve to set apart
Street Fighter 6 from previous Street
Fighter titles
foreign
so yeah the intention from the beginning
was to deliver that classic Street
Fighter experience but then build upon
that with elements like a robust
single-player mode and a an area where
uh where people were like-minded
Fighters can also communicate with one
another so that's why from the very
beginning of development they always had
these three key pillars in mind of
developing uh fighting ground World Tour
and battle Hub and uh yes we definitely
feel like we were able to succeed in
doing so
and what type of players did you really
want to appeal appeal with Street
Fighter
foreign
[Music]
so we obviously wanted to deliver a a
fun and unique fighting game experience
to to our fans out there but at the same
time we acknowledge that there are fans
who may who may enjoy the universe of
Street Fighter kind of outside of that
core fighting game aspect of it so
that's why they incor Incorporated modes
like World Tour where they could uh
enjoy aspects like Avatar customization
meeting with familiar faces within that
world and hopefully by playing those
modes they will naturally get to kind of
improve their game while uh while
enjoying like a non-core fighting game
aspect to it and beyond that they also
included elements like you know Easter
eggs that fans of Street Fighter will
recognize and they'll hopefully kind of
enhance the overall experience of those
players
have there been any major surprises that
you've noticed in terms of how players
have been enjoying the game
foreign
yeah so the the one of the the most
surprising things that we saw people
react to was World Tour
um especially because there were so many
aspects to that mode that have never
actually been included in a Street
Fighter game whether that be things like
uh Avatar customization RPG elements uh
refrigerators and Home Appliances that
you could fight against so all these
things were very unique to a to a street
fighter experience and
um but people really resonated well to
those things so we're very happy that
people were excited that we decided to
include these elements into the game and
beyond that there's also the battle Hub
which is also a completely new challenge
to us
um but you know we were really happy to
see that people were saying that oh this
reminds me of of being an arcade which
was exactly what the team was going for
so yeah we're really happy with the
reception overall and we're glad that we
included that into the game
now as we've seen this weekend the
popularity has been explosive for Street
Fighter 6. how do you feel about
breaking the Evo registration record and
making Evo history
yeah so from from the very beginning I
mean Evo's history has been pretty much
in alignment with street fighters
history also and we were able to see
both you know both Evo and Street
Fighter kind of grow along with each
other and you know seeing this outcome
today and seeing all these fans here
playing together
and really enjoying Street Fighter 6 is
just it's an honor and we're we're so
happy that that people are having such a
great time with it
awesome now our next question is going
to be for saturday-san I'm throughout
the campaign for Street Fighter 6 you
know it's been presented in a unique way
compared to previous titles by having
the pillars of World Tour fighting
ground in the battle Hub so I'm curious
about that direction and what were some
challenges behind communicating that to
the masses yeah so uh as uh Amazon and
maximusan just mentioned uh those uh
elements are entirely new uh completely
new to a Street Fighter game so
um you know it was uh we had to think
about how to deliver how to carry those
messages in those elements in our
messaging very carefully
um because there are tons of content we
wanted to show to our audience uh each
time when we release a new trailer it
was quite difficult to balance
everything out uh put all core modes uh
visual gameplay in one single trailer
there was also a debate internally
whether to release all the core three
pillar game mode at very first time when
we reveal the title but we always had a
strong desire that uh all type of
players should experience and would have
fun with are those uh you know
intertwined three different modes and we
are glad we did it seeing a lot of
players enjoying them in their own way
yes we've definitely been seeing
everyone enjoying all these different
modes but one thing that always pops up
on social media is the ability to
customize your avatar are you surprised
at how the community has been
interacting with this feature yes we've
certainly seen a lot of you know
interesting work by fans but we are
super happy uh seeing everyone's
creative designs through
um it was uh you know also great seeing
uh the Avatar showcases in the battle
Hub both on Japanese and Western streams
seeing everybody is having their moments
and you know doing some weird ritual
stuff
online
besides those we are happy to see our
fans take advantage of the wide range of
Avatar customization feature creating
you know uh avatars with friends uh
different physical
um you know characteristic and utilizing
uh accessories making cool you know
outfits very very fun to see them
amazing now our next question is going
to be for nakayama-san Capcom celebrates
its 40th anniversary this year and
Street Fighter the series has been
running for 36 of those 40 years and is
one of capcom's main franchise pillars
how has that history been reflected in
the design of Street Fighter VI and what
inspiration do you think it will provide
for the series in the future
um
foreign
original
yeah so as mentioned you know this is
the we're celebrating the 40th
anniversary of Capcom and the 36th
anniversary of Street Fighter so you
know both the company and the brand has
been uh going strong for for quite a
while now and because we have such a
long and Rich history within our company
we were able to get uh a lot of veterans
from within Capcom uh who've been
working on on various titles for a long
time to to help us out with Street
Fighter 6 as well uh for example uh the
art director of Street Fighter 6 uh
kaname hujioka uh he was uh you know
mentored by some of the Legacy Street
Fighter 2 artists including akimansan
and um beyond that he's been involved in
the Monster Hunter series at a uh
directorial level too and also uh we
have uh
who was the scriptwriter for World Tour
he uh was very involved in Street
Fighter 6 as well but before that he was
also involved in the uh Breath of Fire
series at a directorial level two so
we're truly blessed to have such a men's
Talent within our company to really make
Street Fighter 6 do something very
special and actually uh speaking of uh
uh we're you know we're here to announce
that uh we actually have our 40th
anniversary website Capcom town and
starting next month you will be able to
play uh
the project that was involved Breath of
Fire uh the Super Nintendo version on
the platform for free and you could
already play games like Street Fighter 2
and final fight there uh as well so uh
please check it out when you have a
chance
oh awesome definitely looking forward to
that and I'm looking forward to talking
about some Rasheed up next but before we
get to that how we feeling about another
giveaway
oh no y'all are gonna have to do better
than that are you ready for another
giveaway
thank you thank you all right Andy take
it away
all right we are back so as you guys
know these are pretty hard questions
um whoever gets this one right this is
the next prize it's a PlayStation 5
Collectors Edition or a mad gearbox with
high grounds keyboard a high grounds
keyboard Matt a udon comic a poster and
a toy
so I was debating whether or not I
wanted to ask Frame data questions and I
thought this is the perfect crowd for
that
so the first question so this question
is
reuse crouching medium kick is minus
what on block
how's it going you seem pretty confident
it's not minus three sorry
next victim
real crouching medium kick as minus what
on block
25 no
little too high
maybe a lot too high
all right
minus two
nope
minus four
not minus four Closer Closer we're
getting closer
there's more Frame data questions later
guys
reuse crouching medium kick is minus
what on block
you said the last guy was you said the
last guy was less right
minus four is closer than minus two
minus three
no
all right
where's my real Mains at I'm a reumane
I'm a real main let's see
eight
nope
no but really close
so the next person better get it
minus five
no he just said minus five sorry no
uh six it is minus six that's it there
we go
is all yours actually
yeah take it right now
it's the arduous thank you all right
Persia back to you
all right all right don't worry you guys
there's definitely more trivia coming up
but I told you these questions putting
your knowledge to the test here it only
gets more difficult from here so get
ready
but yes now it's time to talk a little
bit more about Rishi the newest released
character in Street Fighter 6 and Rashid
made his debut in Street Fighter 5 and
has only grown in popularity people who
attended San Diego Comic-Con were able
to get their hands on the character a
little bit before the release but now if
you haven't had a chance to play Rasheed
you can definitely head on over to the
Capcom Booth j4 if you want to try them
out you might need a little bit of
practice with him if you're answering
this bracket because personally I'm
hoping we see a lot more receipts in
this bracket shaking up the meta you
know ruining dreams out there but we'll
see what happens this weekend
um so let's talk about it
I have the impression that rasheed's
gameplay abilities are deeper this time
around than in Street Fighter 5. can we
expect the same for the DLC characters
that will return in the future
um
foreign
hi
yeah so it's it's a little bit difficult
for us to get to uh deep into the
details of the future characters but in
terms of Rasheed uh yeah we definitely
wanted to kind of maintain and keep the
essence of the character that he that we
were able to establish him in with uh
Street Fighter 5 and
um but and kind of enhance some of those
uh some of those unique characteristics
that he has like his sense of uh his
usage of parkour and his breeziness and
so yeah while he does uh have kind of
like uh tricky movements in uh industry
fire six we've uh we try to also make
him a very fun character to play and uh
yeah we hope that players are also
looking forward to uh to the Future
characters whether they be new or
returning characters
I'm also curious to know what was your
approach in incorporating not only
rasheeds but future characters stories
into the world tour mode
[Music]
um
yeah so from the early stages of
development uh the team already decided
that you know future characters like
Rasheed uh will be included in World
Tour along with their their background
and and their storyline so that is
something that you can also uh expect
for future characters as well and
um in the case of Rasheed he happens to
appear in nicehal in the world tour but
uh who knows there may be characters uh
in the future that may appear in uh in
new different areas as well so something
to look forward to
um and then besides from the uh the
characters themselves uh we the team
also adds uh other like end game content
like the recent uh missions that we
included in um in the Rashid patch so
we'll continue to update World Tour and
I hope you continue to look forward to
it
and I'd also love to know whose idea was
it to make Rasheed a
or a food super
streamer in the world of Street Fighter
Iman is
foreign
ER back in Street Fighter 5 as well and
uh that idea came up from nakamasan and
so him and Iker Hassan wrote the the
storyline behind that for Street Fighter
6 and in regards to the question of
whether he's a popular streamer he is
moderately popular but he might not be
able to uh to eat off of just his uh his
streaming talents
fair enough streaming is difficult all
right fair enough so now so now to move
on to matsumoto-san what was the
inspiration behind including Rasheed in
the year one lineup and also having him
be the first new DLC character
I know arima
so yeah Rasheed was a very popular
character in Street Fighter V and we
really wanted to kind of um to to answer
to the desires of those those fans who
really liked him in the the past title
so we felt that we really wanted to
bring him back in Street Fighter 6 as
soon as possible
and um you know besides from that he he
has an interesting background but also
his movements and his his moves
themselves are very unique and very
different from the the other existing
characters so we thought that he would
really stand out within the uh the
street fighter 6 lineup and uh beyond
that uh because this game is developed
off the re engine uh we were able to
um kind of like Express movements and
Anime him in unique ways that were a
little bit difficult before but you know
with the lowering of of like technical
limitations we were able to uh kind of
like you know show his like the
animations of like the fabric of his
clothing and his hair to be more
expressive and uh we felt that he would
really shine in the context of Street
Fighter 6.
now the year one lineup has been fully
announced but I'm curious to know if
there's anything that they have in
common and what ultimately went behind
the decision to pick these specific
characters for Year One
um
foreign
so yeah because these characters are all
very unique and different in their own
way it's kind of hard to come up with
like a single Common Thread amongst them
but we felt like characters like Rasheed
are very uh you know unique both in
looks and how they play so we felt that
those kinds of characters would be a
very fitting very very fitting for
Street Fighter VI
um in terms of how we decided to come up
with the the four year one characters
um no we we obviously wanted to bring
back fan favorites but also uh include
new characters as well along with uh
with popular characters from the the
last title Street Fighter five so that's
kind of how we we came up with those
four characters
awesome now we can't forget to speak
about rasheed's theme music because
we believe we have we have something
yeah you got something
[Music]
um
oh and um so yeah actually since we're
all here today uh we felt like we this
would be a good opportunity for us to
share some uh some new art that maybe
hasn't uh been seen before so uh
a couple comments to share with you guys
regarding what what we'll show
that doors
so
foreign
hi
so uh yeah we uh we can't say exactly
when this content is coming out in the
game but we have uh four unique pieces
of art that we would like to
hi
so the last one was guile that's his
civilian outfit and uh that's might be
an outfit that he might wear when he's
going out to a bar or something and uh
hi so this is Marisa in a wedding dress
and the storyline behind this will
eventually be told within uh World Tour
so look out for that all right guys all
right next please
[Laughter]
all right so yeah this one is a very
popular amongst the the dev team as well
but this is kind of uh an outfit that
jury might wear at home when she's
relaxing and and uh just being lazy I
guess
so as you can see it's a pretty baggy
outfit and they spend a lot of time on
the texture of it but it looks very cool
when she's uh in motion
all right last one please
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
[Laughter]
yeah so this is DJ in this fancy suit we
wanted him to uh to let him shine a
little more so uh that's his uh that's
his new outfit
and today we can only show these four
outfits but uh yeah please you'll
definitely be able to expect uh
similar outfits for the other characters
as well so uh look out for that
yes how are we feeling about those
costumes
everybody's gonna be looking crispy real
soon I'm looking forward to it and I saw
DJ over there looking extra excited
about these costumes as well so we're
all looking forward to it all right now
we can't forget to speak about rasheed's
theme music and we do have teriyama song
with us to discuss it as well from The
Sound Department to give us some more
insight on the behind the scenes
development of his theme and the street
fighter 6 soundtrack so when you listen
to rasheed's character Theme I noticed
Middle Eastern sounding streams and
Woodwinds but did you use any different
or new types of instruments foreign
Muslim
[Music]
so yeah I mean considering that Rasheed
is a character from from the Middle East
we felt that it was essential to
represent him by including uh Middle
Eastern instrumentations within his
character Theme so if you listen closely
you'll hear a uh a uh a percussion
instrument a middle eastern percussion
instrument called a darbuka and also a
middle eastern uh string instrument
called a called an Ood and Beyond just
the instrumentation we uh they included
um kind of Middle Eastern like scales
Within the Music
and um and also in Street Fighter 5 he
kind of had like a whistling like sound
in his theme but they felt that that
whistling sound was essential to kind of
uh Express his like cheeriness and his
sense of speed so they Incorporated that
into this new theme as well
and did you refer to any other Middle
Eastern music as inspiration
um
so yeah the sound team did a lot of uh
research and experimentation to uh to
learn more about Middle Eastern music to
come up with rashid's theme but actually
uh not Amazon is a uh he's a big fan of
Music in general uh music from all over
the world and one uh genre music that
he's a fan of is uh is music that you
hear in this kind of like Middle Eastern
folk dancing called dapka which is done
in places like Lebanon and Iraq and so
he suggested that to uh Amazon and they
almost really liked that and thought
that that the groom of that was really
fitting for a character like Rasheed and
really kind of like represented his
sense of like cheerfulness and and sense
of like speed as I mentioned earlier so
they you might be able to hear a lot of
uh elements of dapka into in rushy's
theme
awesome and the theme song is definitely
fast-paced and Jazzy which seems to be a
great fit for Rasheed but I'm also
curious if there's anything specific you
want the listeners to be aware of
come on
um
so yeah for this particular piece uh the
sound team collaborated uh with a
trombonist uh outside of the company
named Mr asari and they first decided to
uh create the jazz piece uh first and
then beyond that they added elements of
like Electro and like the Middle Eastern
aspects of it to create something unique
and um and when it comes to jazz music
it's very versatile and it fits very
well with a lot of different
instrumentations but we felt that you
know this is very it's Unique in the
sense that it incorporates all these
different elements like hip-hop and
Middle Eastern stuff so we feel like it
came up to be something very special and
we hope that uh people enjoy it too
awesome now I know the future characters
are probably also gonna have new themes
but you know being a composer were there
moments where you set out to challenge
yourself when making these new things
[Music]
yeah so first off we just recently
released the uh the soundtrack of Street
Fighter 6 on uh on select streaming
platforms so we're very excited that
that is uh available to everyone now in
terms of challenges that we wanted to to
accomplish you know um uh he would like
to continue collaborating with uh more
musicians outside of the company so that
he could bring Street Fighter to more
people and then he's all uh 10 Amazon is
also a member of cap jams which is our
internal band that comprises of
different uh members from The Sound team
and you know he would like to continue
making like different band Arrangements
of the existing themes so that's
something that we would hopefully we
could deliver to you guys in the near
future and actually speaking of cap jams
Amazon here but the the whole band is
here uh all throughout this weekend and
we're excited to announce that uh cap
jams will be performing live on Sunday
during the top six finals of Street
Fighter six so
yeah it's beyond the competition
hopefully this is something you guys can
look forward to as well
yes live performance we're definitely
looking forward to it it is going to be
amazing and you know what else is
amazing how about another giveaway how
about some more trivia yeah yeah y'all
awake out there all right we're gonna
kick it on over to Andy
all right I'm back
um the third question the winner will
gets
A PS5 collector's edition uh the Mad
gear box uh Toy another high grounds
keyboard a high grounds keyboard mouse
pad a poster and a comic and you'll take
it home today
uh this one might actually be the
hardest one there is so if you want to
take break out your phones right now
um let's go for it I'll give you one
hint before I ask it though do not
overthink it it's it's much more simpler
than you think so the question is
when Blanca wins a fight against JP
he says you you smell like what
don't overthink it you smell like what
does Blanca think
when Blanca wins a fight against JP he
says you uh you smell like
blank
bananas nope
it's actually a it's a common phrase
when you see someone like JP you would
say you smell like death
what no
bananas no the first person said bananas
actually
roses no it's a super common phrase when
you see someone that looks evil
or something
hey you smell like
accounting books no he said accounting
books no
it smells like poop no
this one might take a while
uh
uh fart no it's it's not anything like
vile or anything
it's a description
rotten eggs no
look at that line right now it's kind of
crazy
garbage no
garbage no he does that garbage it
starts with the letter t
it starts with the letter t
you smell like
terrible
no but you're in the right Realm
t r
he said terrible
no good guess he said trash good guess
that's not it
TR
ish no it's not trash
o
smell like troll no
you smell like trouble yes thank you
there's this one right here
you take it all you show it up to the
camera oh let me help you let me help
you
need help okay show it off to the camera
a little bit all right thank you
congratulations to our winner so many
prizes he could barely hold them all all
right this is how it's going but don't
worry we got one more giveaway at the
end but for now we got some fun
announcements from the street fighter 6
team so
Street Fighter is an amazing game with
the backing of a passionate Community
behind it and Capcom wants to continue
to support that starting in September
Capcom will coordinate with local events
and Gatherings across the U.S to drop
exclusive gear and goodies
exclusive keychains and posters will be
available at partnered locals such as
barcode Guild House juicy game night
next level San Antonio fgc and so much
more they'll also kick off sharing these
events through the official Street
Fighter 6 Discord so be sure to join the
Discord to see where they're dropping
this exclusive swag and where to find a
local near you more details will come
soon but check out Street Fighter 6's
social channels and the official Discord
for more but that is not it we also have
some Esports announcements as well as
part of the celebration for the launch
of Street Fighter VI Capcom Pro Tour the
Capcom Pro tourist season has an
incredible prize full of over 2 million
dollars and a grand prize to first place
at Capcom Capcom cup 10 of 1 million
dollars as our season kicks off here at
Evo we're pleased to announce that there
are two more offline competitions this
season being in Singapore and France
respectively the first of these two
offline competitions will be part of
Gamescom Asia held in Singapore at the
Suntec convention and Exhibition Center
the tournament will take place from
October 20th to the 22nd for the bracket
the next offline competitions finals
will be held in Paris on November 5th
with the finals being held as a part of
Paris Games Week the qualifier rounds
from November 3rd to 4th will be held at
a venue leading up to the finals so make
sure you check start.gg for more info
regarding the events now the number of
entrants for the offline premieres will
be limited to
1024 entrants on a first come first
serve basis so make sure you're looking
out for that so you don't miss your
opportunity
now folks we are almost out of time but
before we wrap up how about one more
giveaway
all right we know that these questions
have been very tough so get ready I see
the line forming over there already now
before we get into though I have a quick
question Who at home owns a retro arcade
box anybody anybody because the folks at
arcade one up will ship a arcade cabinet
directly to your home after the Evo
festivities if you get this question
right and they were kind enough to
coordinate for us to have a Street
Fighter 2 themed cabinet so huge prize
right now good luck to everyone in the
line we're gonna kick it over to Andy
for our final trivia question
all right thanks Persia so this is the
last question whoever gets it right
um please stay behind so I can get your
information so we can ship the arcade
one up cabinet to you but today we're
also if you win you'll also get a uh a
PS5 collector's edition and a new
non-comic just to take home just to show
off
all right this one is another Frame data
question
um Manon players
is plus what on hit
plus four nope sorry
everyone's on their phones looking up
Manon Frame data
nope
where's all the monomanes at
hey
no
not eight
yes OD de Gage is plus what on hit
on hit
no not plus two
all right
OD de Gage is plus what on hits I'm not
gonna tell you what that move is
it is six
[Applause]
yeah
um you can take this home right now
[Applause]
you did you did uh that's all the trivia
we have now Persia I'm gonna bring it
back to you
congratulations one himself an arcade
cabinet doesn't get better than that now
thank you so much to our panelists for
providing Insight on Street Fighter 6. I
hope everybody at home and here in the
audience have enjoyed hearing about the
street fighter universe and don't forget
to stop by the Capcom Booth j4 if you
want to play some Street Fighter enjoy
the mini games and other games they've
got going on over there and of course
have a wonderful Evo
thank you
I'm so sorry I messed up the costume
this means drinks later
here's Chipotle order just got extra
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code hdkn 236 and receive
250 fighter coins with yours visit
chipotle.com sf6 for details
only a handful of people in the world
can do it
but it's dangerous these are incredible
steaks you're going to be forced to make
Split Second decisions that could cost
you your life get out whether you like
it or not you are in this race
get in the fight
Red Bull gives you wings
foreign
[Music]
thank you
till I fly away
[Music]
songs
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths are forever when they
pin our Lord I hear every Echo inside of
the world clear I feel all the Hope
comes inside of the same fear Shadows
defeated out of the life in the same
years when they tell us that it's gone
but y'all I'm still here
[Music]
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
my voice
[Music]
defensive practical this is the
beginning imagine your boy a level two
still coming against
us at least
on the floor my style is revered like
art on the wall if they didn't know that
[Music]
till I fly in ways you can't believe
I'm still here
[Music]
here we go
an al pastor is fire on every level
fresh chicken hot off the grill a rich
marinade of seared Marita peppers and
ground achiode balanced with a splash of
pineapple all combined for the right
amount of heat Chipotle's all new
Chicken al pastor is where fire meets
flavor
thank you
[Music]
oh no
super Rollo
Victory feels good
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
we connect with the community and where
is a better place to do that than right
here in the trenches pool play is
intense and we've got so many people
let's go ahead and grab someone from the
crowd hello how are you doing
let us know what's your name where are
you from and what are you looking
forward to the most here at Evo my name
is Marilyn June and I'm from Phoenix
actually yeah and I'm excited this is my
first time here and I'm excited to see
how far my boyfriend gets in the
competition how's he been doing so far
has he started playing already yes he's
done two and he's won both so far so
hopefully all right sounds like he's on
fire good luck to him wishing you guys
the best and I hope you have a great
rest of your weekend all right let's
keep it moving Street Fighter six pulls
obviously packed to the brim but that's
not the only pools that are packed right
now I'm looking forward to seeing how
everybody does how's it going what's
your name where are you from and what
are you competing in this weekend hey
I'm Chet I go by Bushido Brown I'm doing
all right today uh I'm in Street Fighter
Marvel 3 and Guilty Gear yo marvel three
let's go massive tournament who are you
looking forward to seeing the most uh in
the Marvel 3 Bracket oh I had jabril in
my bracket so I wanted to see him so I
could whoop him
but you know they moved him out kept
them safe so you know oh no I really
want to see
this is the biggest tournament we had in
a while so there's all the new blood and
then there's all the old blood
everyone's here I want to see it I want
to see the old versus new clashing
that's what I'm here for
it to you
go I love me some Marvel and we're in
that Sunday Arena so it's gonna be fire
thank you guys so much for hanging out
with us connecting with some people in
the community good luck to everybody
else in their polls and we're sending it
right on back to the main stage
all right now with the closed Network
text that just ended I know everyone is
feening for some more technique
information with that said please
welcome to the stage casuhiro harada
Michael Murray and Kasumi yoga to tell
us more
hey everybody at Evo how's it going
all right we love to hear it we'd love
to hear it all right we have our Tech in
a channel today and joining us today are
none other than the Tekken Project
Director and producer katsuhiro harada
and Michael Murray gentlemen good
afternoon how are you doing
I'm good I'm good
but I'm so sleepy now
I'm so sorry
I'm doing good I'm glad to be here to
see this year's Evo uh bigger than and
better than ever so looking forward to
some interesting matches this weekend
awesome cool so hopefully we can wake
Radisson up with some cool stuff that we
have for you today regarding our closed
Network test that we just concluded last
weekend let's take a look
um
so we just concluded the CNT test uh
spread out over two weeks and we'd like
to thank everyone who participated
yes so once again everybody thank you so
much for your participation thank you so
much for signing up and thank you so
much for participating we got so much
information that we are super excited to
share with you all we're going to give
you a little bite-sized look right now
um
foreign
spread out over today and tomorrow uh
today is going to be kind of an overview
of some of the key findings that we
think people might be interested in that
we found out during the test uh and also
some of our thoughts on what we plan to
do with that data and then tomorrow
we'll dive deeper into some of the more
uh uh the nitty-gritty of the game I
guess you could say
all right cool let's get started with
the first stats that we have for the
closed Network test
so the closed Network test was conducted
using the closed Network test version of
Tekken 8.
excuse me sorry everybody and through
competitive online players were able to
experience the new aggressive battle
system which represents the battle
concept of Tekken 8. so can you guys
tell us a little bit about what that
aggressive battle system is
uh sorry I'm getting mixed up in English
so this time uh you know we wanted to
really focus on aggressive battle system
in the the whole uh new design mechanics
had been kind of tailored around that uh
the new heat system which players can
trigger at any time once per round uh
which makes the character's abilities
even stand out more and adds more depth
uh to the individual elements that each
character possesses so that's one of the
biggest uh main changes for this time in
Tekken 8. cool so we have some stats for
you
about the number of testers tell us
about this number what led you guys to
choose like this number and stuff like
that
um
so you can see the number of applicants
was uh quite a bit and the people
actually got in uh is a smaller
percentage of that so you can see that
it's overwhelmingly 300 percent uh
applied in relation to how many slots
were open so we were able to gather a
lot of useful data because so many
people applied and got in
tell us a little bit about the different
weekends because obviously there may
have been difference in participation
due to the platforms that were used in
week one versus week two so let's look a
little bit at these stats
um
[Music]
foreign
so
keep in mind for people who don't know
about a lot about the CNT the first week
was PlayStation 5 only and then the
second week we open it up to other
platforms Xbox and steam so this data
shows the percentage of wired players
and people who are playing on Wi-Fi with
it broken down by Aryan region
[Music]
don't worry
foreign
we don't need to tell everyone here at
Evo that uh it's optimal to play on a
wired land connection because of the
packet loss and such it can occur on
Wi-Fi but we're looking at the data we
can still see during the first week on
PlayStation 5 you had a little bit more
than 40 percent of people played on
Wi-Fi
foreign
[Music]
another interesting point to note is on
week two we opened up cross play uh to
all the different platforms you see that
uh Wi-Fi drops to like 24 25 right uh
and this is not because it's the second
week per se but mainly because due to
the steam players on PC uh and we're we
have a hypothesis that a lot of people
maybe have more higher end PCS as
they're looking to play the game at a
higher level of Graphics this time
around so probably not on gaming
notebooks as much as you know a proper
desktop so as such they're probably more
likely to have a wired connection right
so that said it's not like uh
Playstation is the only one that's 40 uh
the correct way to look at it would be
consoles in general tend to tend to have
a higher Wi-Fi usage percentage
does any of this wi-fi versus wired
information affect anything regarding
the development of the game itself or is
this just general information that is
just good for us to know
everybody
um
foreign
[Music]
so you know obviously uh we were able to
see firsthand as we were all playing the
test at the time as well uh how
different it is when you have a wired
connection compared to uh Wireless right
or Wi-Fi so obviously it's much uh it
feels much more responsive when you have
it playing on the Lan cable inserted Etc
um
and you can this is not just because the
Ping because the Ping could be the same
uh you know it shows you in game right
but it's because the packet loss that
occurs during Wi-Fi it makes the
experience uh you know less optimal on
Wi-Fi uh that said we still really hope
that most people try to play on a wired
connection but we still do hope to try
to tweak the settings a little bit uh to
try to cover up packet loss wherever we
can
cool that's awesome so we noticed that
when we're playing the when we're
playing the test there were two
different icons that showed up so we
could tell the difference between
someone who is playing on a wired
connection versus someone who's playing
on the Wi-Fi connection
um tell us a little bit about the
intention behind that what is what is
the reason for that uh the indicator in
game you mean the wired connection
versus wi-fi
um icon when you're connecting to
somebody
I can't hear you what the network status
display
um
okay okay so yeah what we're looking at
here is you can see this shows up on the
bottom right of the screen and it'll
tell you the RT which is your overall
ping right so that is kind of an
indicator for both Wi-Fi and wired it'll
show you the delay frames how many
frames are rolling back depending on
your connection Etc rsr that's the delay
frames because of uh the connection
status and then roll frames uh all the
way to the right shows how many
rollbacks are occurring like how many
frames of rollback right and then the
one you really want to pay attention to
obviously is in red uh and this is the
one on the top is the optimal uh Lan
connection where the one on the bottom
is uh Wireless and the one on the far
where I will we uh
and the one on the right we're going to
explain in a later slide so uh wait a
second please
I know
um
[Music]
foreign
and so obviously you know again uh the
game is playable on Wi-Fi it's not like
it's you know uh something that can't be
done uh but we hope if you do have the
chance at a friend's house or something
if you could try uh wired and a wireless
connection you'll see for yourself just
how different it is because there's uh
less packet loss occurring also less
chance of air network errors and stuff
like that occurring as well the hill
I know
Siri
and of course uh in game you'll be able
to see whether it's a Wi-Fi connection
for your opponent or not as well
uh the next one or soon yeah so explain
you guys explained just a little bit
about this earlier with the with the
Arrows with the green and the Red Arrows
can you explain a little bit more about
how these arrows are super important for
your connection
s
so this uh screen the one where we're
talking about the far right this
indicator is something that only shows
up when either you're playing on PC or
your opponent is playing on PC uh
[Music]
foreign
this uh indicator is actually
interesting because you don't really see
it in many games yet uh and this is
because we wanted to let players know
more information about what's going on
uh for example when you feel that the
game is not very responsive it could be
due to uh you know the network
connection of you or your opponent which
you can see by the indicators we
mentioned earlier right this is actually
showing you uh how your PC is performing
if they're slowing down on your PC or
slowing down on your opponent's PC not
the network connection but the actual
machine itself because that also
respects the responsiveness of the game
yeah
so if you're playing and you feel the
game is lagging it might not be your
opponent it might be you right so you
can then take a look at this and if it's
green for you it's okay if it's red for
you that means your PC is slowing down
so you need to go to the options and
lower the graphic level or you know
upgrade your PCS
uh
um
and so another thing is the the game you
know the effects are very over the top
right so on certain stages or certain uh
characters effects it could cause the
machine to slow down a little bit as
well uh there's also maybe not that well
known but the first time that the game
is loading a certain uh effect that also
it needs to load up first which will
cause it to slow down uh so you know
well we're loading this the game the the
loading screen we try to load all the
shaders and stuff that we need but uh
there's still instances where that'll
occur for the first time uh so that's
another thing to take into a account
interesting so now that we have
for Steam
people don't have any excuses anymore
all right next slide everybody
um
so this feature is also quite
interesting as you can kind of customize
your experience by choosing to
prioritize Graphics or response so uh
and this is supposed to just affect you
and not your opponent
um
foreign
[Music]
so first off many people it seemed in
the CNT didn't even notice this feature
was in a game so we'd like many people
to check it out when they have the
chance next time but not just that we
felt like it wasn't fully understood
because there's something similar in
other games that lets you prioritize
like the the frame rates or the
resolution right right this is not that
what this is is it's all about uh
because Tekken is a 3D fighter right the
animations are more fluid uh and they
they cover more distance than for
example 2D Fighters so what this is is
if you turn on the the graphic priority
then it's not going to be so stuttery uh
when you have rollbacks or the
connection Jitters or Etc it's going to
try to smooth out the animation as much
as possible where if you prioritize
response maybe you know it'll be a
little it'll look a little bit jittery
but you'll feel like it's it's response
quicker so it's a little bit different
than other games
a
um
foreign
ERS behind the scenes that uh the player
doesn't actually see uh right now it's
just you know prioritized one or the
other but we could actually have it more
digital where you have various different
stages of each setting Etc
um so if that's something that we get a
lot of feedback that people want more
control of that's something we may end
up uh tuning before the release uh so
yeah if you have any feedback let us
know
foreign
so obviously we're gonna try to you know
make all the features look and feel uh
like we think is optimal experience
right but if users feel like they want
even more options or or more uh
bells and whistles and switches or
whatever you want to call it uh they can
you know let us know the feedback
in the middle of the closed Network test
brought us on you
act about this setting and you taught
people about what the different settings
do and there were a lot of people who
appreciated that and tried it out
because of that so your responsiveness
is super appreciated by the community
[Music]
so you know there's many comments in
regards to this and and some people
maybe misunderstand it we're we're
trying to make the user the the bad
person of why they don't have a good
connection Etc right that's not the case
we're just trying to make the game as
transparent as possible so they have
more options to figure out what's wrong
so they can address it and make the the
best experience or you know the optimal
settings for for each individual user
foreign
I know
today
[Music]
so this is especially helpful for PC
because when you're looking at the
consoles it's it's a set like spec right
right so it's pretty uh stable when
you're playing between two different
consoles it's when you're playing on PC
where there's a variety of different
combinations of graphic cards and
Hardware Etc and uh and you know how
powerful the machines are so it's more
of uh people can look at these tools and
kind of fine-tune the environment mainly
for PC
all right now going to our next Slide
the effect saturation settings
foreign
so many people have already gotten used
to the uh over-the-top effects of Tekken
eight uh but some people maybe would
like to dial it down a bit and so
obviously we have this option in game
for them to do that uh Right Now the
default is kind of uh very flashy so we
are thinking maybe as a result of the
CNG feedback we might dial it down a
little bit and then the user can choose
whether they want to you know push it up
higher if they want to decrease it
foreign
and so maybe uh many people didn't
notice that this is actually an option
in the game so next time you get your
hands on the game uh perhaps take a look
at it and you can adjust it for your own
monitor or the environment that you're
using right all right guys so we have
been talking about so many cool things
that we are actually
running out of time so let's try to get
through the rest of these slides about
the CNT because we have so much stuff to
share uh
all right
so let's get started with uh
foreign so uh we'll have more details
for you tomorrow regarding the CNT you
know find uh detailed stuff uh let's go
with a little bit more light and fun
topic here yeah
right so the top eight playable usable
playable character usage ranking in CNT
so what characters were used the most so
haradasan and Michael are going to go
through that for you guys right now okay
duh
so uh uh first off we have uh in eighth
place is Lily right so maybe I don't
know if that's uh if that's a surprise
to you or not but you can also tell that
depending on the different regions it's
also quite different uh but overall you
know she tends to be between uh first in
some regions actually so
foreign
let's go with uh number seven next slide
please
our Lord
um
higher but maybe it depends on the
region right yep Africa looks like what
second place yep Africa's second place
okay let's try please
foreign
is coming in sixth place right
so Gerardo was saying he was surprised
she he thought she would be higher up as
did I because it's the first time she's
uh returning after a while right and uh
you know the story trailers that we
showed off it was
right
but it really depends on the the area
right for example North America I think
she's quite popular
all right fifth place for Brian right
now
he was uh it was a you know a lot of
talks surrounded Brian I guess uh he is
a favorite of several well-known players
like me Etc right and uh I think Paratus
mentioning the the taunt is one of the
the main topics for for Brian
okay
King uh
we heard some cheers from the crowd when
King hit the screen
this is kind of expected you know we've
typically seen King uh very popular
across regions normally around third to
fourth place so yeah this this feels
about right all right so as we head into
our top three yeah three next three okay
so it's a bit surprising we didn't think
about uh so high in the ranking but uh
you know his moves he's got a uh
emphasis on the lower tax uh when he's
in the heat state but also the chip
damage he's uh able to use but you know
not also just his effects are quite cool
you know the the wind looking effects
that a company is kick so uh yeah I
guess I could understand that
don't worry about it it's it's still a
work in progress so all right let's hit
second place then yeah
[Music]
yeah that's fitting I thought that's
kind of expected right because you know
he is you know one of the title
characters
it's perhaps that uh on the character
select screen the cursor defaults to him
right so because we were just discussing
he is a Mishima which typically takes a
lot of uh precise uh inputs for his main
moves and the way he's played right so
it is a bit surprising he's number two
from a play style perspective but if
you're going strictly from the character
styling and how badass he looks this
time I guess I can I can understand that
personally I use them the most during
all right so before we hit first place
can I get some guesses from people like
who do you think is getting first place
I hear Oscar
all right like for about like a hundred
people just Edge in so let's take a look
at what our first place is
[Applause]
oh
he's very popular worldwide
so he's mainly first place everywhere
except for some reason Asia huh I wonder
why second place second place to what
do you remember oh in Asia yeah was it
kazia I think yeah
so I guess Asia likes the bad characters
huh all right cool but yeah I mean what
do you expect he's the main character
this time
uh his costume is it looks incredible
his playstyle is tweaked a lot the
special effects I like quite a lot yeah
he's kind of got partial control over
the devil and he can change uh whenever
he wants so you see the wing come out
just partially during the special moves
uh his eye glowing Etc he's got a lot of
pull tests to him so yeah he's he would
be my favorite pick as well
that jacket's really cool I feel like
that's kind of like a you jacket I feel
like you could rock that jacket
so next we got uh
so we'll be continuing this again uh
this was just kind of an overview of
some of the main details we thought
people would want to know about the CNT
and the feedback right so tomorrow we'll
be diving even deeper so we got a bunch
of data that we took on the back end and
I'm sure that all you second heads out
there are gonna love to see what we have
in store so check it out tomorrow at 1pm
I believe it is at the Bandai Namco
entertainment booth
yep not only that but our Bandai Namco
entertainment Booth is super popping
right now we have a bunch of stuff you
can play technique if you come back
tomorrow you can win and you play Tekken
8 you can get a shirt you can get a
lanyard you can get well we actually
have an activation at the booth tomorrow
where you can come to the booth and if
you are able to stay on the setup by not
losing three times in a row you can get
a super super limited Tekken 8 water
bottle and it's actually the only way
you can get it right now we didn't even
make too many because you know we wanted
to be competitive so we'll see you all
tomorrow at the booth for both winter
stays on and the tech and talk but for
now we're gonna take it to the pools
guys have you do you have anything
closing to say
um
so he's um he's not supposed to look at
the comments on Twitch but uh we're past
that uh and they don't they don't
disappoint right many people mentioning
no trailer uh it is Friday this is a
panel please keep that in mind and we'll
have more exciting info tomorrow uh no
trailer tomorrow either so hold your
glasses
so it's just more a deep dive into more
Tech in data and uh background into the
game maybe give you guys some insight on
what we're thinking uh leading up to
release so uh chill out a bit and uh
we'll see you tomorrow yep thank you
very very much everybody and enjoy your
Evo
thank you all thank you
all right hold on we got to make a
little bit more noise for Tech and name
haratistan Michael Murray and sue me
all right pretty great start from that
team cannot wait to get my hands on the
game as well if you are registered Tech
is also down there at the Dan dynamical
Booth if you are in the building so with
that said we're actually going to shoot
to a quick break and we're gonna get the
legendary Mark man on this day to talk
about some other game does we'll catch
you soon
real food always starts with the real
ingredients
whether it's in restaurant
however you Chipotle is the easiest way
to Chipotle
oh no
super Rola
Victory feels good
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hey what's up everyone we attendo are
Beyond excited to announce the launch of
some brand new merchandise for Evo
beginning with our new officially
licensed Street Fighter designs which
include premium embroidered hoodies and
more also we have new officially
licensed designs for the King of
Fighters 15 Guilty Gear Tekken and other
fgc partners each tenno product is
carefully designed by fgc heads with
only the best material for maximum
comfort and style trust me you don't
want to wait to copies
welcome back everyone we have another
amazing conversation for you all on this
stage so please welcome Ian Ramsey
beloved and Markman
all right guys what's up welcome to Evo
2023 we're going to be talking about
Indie fighting games here at Evo I'm
joined with two very special guests we
got beloved from the five Force Fighters
team and we got Ian from drag her so
guys talk to me how are you guys
enjoying the event talk about the game
be loved you go first hey what's up you
guys RB love gilinwa you know evil is a
great experience and I'm happy to be out
here to show off five first Fighters
it's a game created by myself my little
brother and my friend Ben and we're
really excited to talk about all the
mechanics and the diversity that we're
ready to bring to Evo with our Indie
fighting game
and Ian what about you what do you guys
got with dragger
we got a little game
it's a song yeah okay good yeah uh my
name is Ian I'm part of a small team of
six working on tracker it's a drag queen
fighting game
available with D12 uh we're just
out here trying to get a
a temperature check from the fighting
game Community see see what people think
about it yeah
cool so for both of you guys it's the
second time you guys been a part of Evo
I know for dragger you guys showed off
your trailer last year you guys were
here last year as well showing off the
game
this is the second time that you guys
here you're now on the stage we're
talking a little bit more about the game
I want to know a little bit more about
it so let's kind of talk about maybe the
roster that you guys have as well
um so for five Force Fighters it's we
have a very diverse cast
um usually with creators of games you
try to reflect what your character looks
like in and of your in yourself so we
have two leads that are young black
teens and then the rest of the cast is
you know other cultures you know because
that's what we see around the world as
different people with Shades and colors
like that but you know we want to
represent a lot of different type of
people so that's what we that's what we
went for one decided uh to create five
Force Fighters yeah and obviously very
diverse and speaking of diverse I gotta
talk talk to me about dragger this is a
concept I've not seen before but Ian you
got to tell me a little bit more about
the roster sure sure yeah the the
diversity in our roster is kind of the
star we've uh gone out and we've sought
out drag performers
got their likenesses brought them into
the game helped them design their
characters they're fully voicing it
they're on board but it's a roster full
of stunning drag queens killer drag
Kings it's phenomenal yeah it's
definitely fire phenomenal so one of the
things I wanted to talk about earlier I
kind of jumped into the roster
discussion but I wanted you guys to talk
a little bit more about the game
mechanics so we love can you little tell
us a little bit more
you have for five Force Fighters
everything has been about Innovation and
bringing something different so with our
mechanics we have this thing called
force and that's the name of the game
it's like a mechanic that is a bread and
butter of combat it links moves together
really easily and it also adds for this
diet this this seamless gameplay that
you can't really get anywhere else
because you just break down a lot of the
mechanics that make fighting games
really difficult but also make it but it
makes it really easy so you can break
into this game super easily because you
have the fighting game knowledge but now
you're just you're digging deeper than
what you usually would get into
all right Indian
well we are very blessed our uh our lead
technical designer Matt has worked on a
number of Indie titles prior to joining
the Draco team and uh he's really helped
spearhead a lot of our mechanics we've
got a some approachability in the
controls but a lot of high level mix up
uh it's
very very fun to play and uh yeah
yeah
come on down well of course people got
to try out especially if they're here at
Evo for you guys I got to ask you guys
especially getting the game out here at
Evo making sure people have their their
opportunity to have their hands on how
important is that for you guys we'll
start with you beloved a community is
huge it's humongous for Indie Games it's
something that you have to build up from
the ground up because you know it's your
first title it's the first thing you've
ever worked on and sometimes it's just
very difficult to build that community
so being here at Evo's tremendous seeing
the people that really love what you're
making and finding new people to try out
the product that you're you've been
working on for years so it's humongous
it's major and being able to be around
that is great it's a feel good Ian you
want to talk to a little bit about how
important it is for people to try it
yeah absolutely we've uh been surprised
at Evo there's a huge amount of queer
people in the fgc
so many people have come by it's amazing
to see uh the diversity out there and
yeah yeah cool so my final question to
you guys then where can people find out
more about the games is there a wishlist
option right now uh we'll start with you
you know talk a little talk to us a
little bit more about Dragon where
people can find out more information
sure you can find drag her on Steam
we've just launched our wish list
we're also available everywhere on
socials at drag her the game uh yeah
we're also at both D12
and below so you can wish list five four
spiders on Steam as well and you can
follow our socials at Kaizen Creed so
you can keep up with everything five
Force Fighters and you never know future
games that we drop at Kaizen Creed as
well cool guys that has been the Roundup
here for the Indie Fighters if you guys
are here at the event make sure you guys
check them out in the Indie section but
guys I gotta say thank you guys for
joining me here we will send it back to
you guys and again look forward to more
here from evo2023
[Applause]
we stay up here
's Chipotle order just got extra fighter
coins from Street Fighter 6. order any
entree in the Chipotle app using promo
code
hdkn236 and receive 250 fighter coins
with yours visit chipotle.com sf6 for
details Trump
I asked for an equal and this is what
you find sir perhaps a new hunting
ground Creighton wants a hunt don't give
him one he'll never forget better take
him out before they find the lizard
gunship won't quit
Bull gives you wings
oh no
super Rola
Victory feels good
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I have a brand new age when I hear my
voice
[Music]
you can't believe
in a dream
[Music]
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths of forever when they
pin our Lord every Echo inside of the
world clear I feel all the hopes inside
of the same fear Shadows defeated
[Music]
up run it back quarter on one cab 199
seconds is everything
yourself worthy I live in the impact as
soon as I push forward and tell them to
hold that roll back I don't see any
limited lacking the vision and asking
why the hell I would risk it I'm
basically different I'm everything they
say that is
all depression gets too strong feel like
I was born here for something to prove
wrong what was that moment when you felt
that sound I heard the crowd Shake
ground screaming one more round let the
lights flash over the main stage I'm
still Brave battling the Giants are
still made the real face that's that
choice ignite the fire of a brand new
age when I hear my voice
[Music]
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
song My Soul keeps Rising as I sing my
songs
[Music]
defensive practical this is the
beginning imagine your boy you're level
two my brothers
[Music]
constant
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
run this back
brush it down
next
I'll be strong
[Music]
Jersey
thank you
[Music]
tell us
foreign
[Music]
Shadows
99 seconds is everything
yourself worthy I live in the impact as
soon as I push forward and tell them to
hold that roll back I'll see me limited
lacking the vision and ask him why the
hell I was risk it I'm basically
different I'm everything they say the
arcade era live in my
foreign
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing
[Music]
all the questions
deep
[Music]
Thief isn't pregnant
trenches so coming against us
I know it for sure number one Contender
as soon as they hit the door
hurts on the floor
has been veered like art on the wall
in the numb Evolution's constant and
this ain't my final form
[Music]
keep aching My Voice keeps on my soul
keeps Rising as I sing
[Music]
rush it down
still here
Corners down
[Music]
I'm fine
here we go
[Music]
thank you
till I'm more than what they ask of me
[Music]
as I see myself
foreign
[Music]
till I'm more than what they ask of me
till I fly in ways you can't believe
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my songs
[Music]
on the floor my style is revered like
art on the wall if they ain't in the
nobody
[Music]
till I fly in ways you can't believe
I'm still here
Corners down
[Music]
thank you
hello hello and welcome back to Evo
connections presented by atnc I'm Persia
and I'm joined by c9u and Canadian Ed
who's gonna be helping us out with some
translations today now I gotta ask you
you've traveled so far to be here and
I'm curious to know more about the
differences between connecting with your
local community versus connecting with
the community here at Evo
Nissan
like in Japan everybody here is just so
warm and welcoming and open and
everybody she meets just is just saying
hey I'm rooting for you you just played
wow and all of that so it's it's a very
good feeling very welcome
awesome and we're definitely looking
forward to seeing you play in second
seven everyone's cheering you on but
with that said we have Tekken 8 on the
horizon how do you feel about technique
so far and what are you looking forward
to the most
um
she's really impressed that been able to
keep the poor gameplay of Tekken but
also introduce gameplay elements that
will attract new players she really
hopes that Tekken 8 will bring both the
existing Tech and community and new
players into a brand new community and
drive the series forward amazing what
we're looking for
well thank you both so much for joining
us and we're going to kick it right on
back to the main stage
[Music]
all right I guess we got some uh Killer
Instinct fans in the house so we got Ki
fans out there
[Applause]
but as you know we got a little Killer
Instinct exhibition coming up but before
I got another question for everybody in
the crowd who out there likes Chipotle
Burritos let me let me
[Applause]
I got another question who likes
potentially
free Chipotle burritos and bowls
[Applause]
all right with that to everyone Chipotle
is proud to support Evo and bring
incredible opportunities and even better
incredible food to the fgc now there
should be a code behind me
there is not a code behind me there
should be a text code for you guys to
potentially win a free burrito oh
everybody take out their phone I want to
see phones in everyone's hand right now
I got in the pocket in the pocket in the
pocket
can you guys see now
[Music]
everybody please taxes number for a
potential opportunity to win a free
burrito or a free bowl of Chipotle thank
you very much to pulley for supporting
Evo we really appreciate it everyone get
the text in
we're not starting so everyone gets to
Texan
I see you guys still looking at your
phone so we're doing it
all right that's it we are good are we
now ready
pressing the Killer Instinct
[Applause]
oh my God
[Music]
all right we're going to start bringing
out the players right now can I get the
players the first player can I please
step up
oh here he comes
everyone give me some warm welcomes for
the man Rico's the water
[Applause]
all right my man is coming up a legend
in the scene Give It Up Make some noise
from my man Hollywood sleep
[Applause]
yeah
all right here we go this is about I
know this is going to be a big one I
don't even have to introduce this
individual give it up give it up for
Nikki the k i Ledger baby Mickey yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah and here comes our last competitor
please make some nice for the men
first
[Music]
all right I'm not gonna hold you guys
any longer hey say jam the charbach
let's get this going
[Applause]
what's up everybody welcome back to
Evolution 2023 oh I hear the music now I
hope you're all ready I'm joined by the
lovely Tarbox for this Ki exhibition how
you doing what's going on I am so
excited that Ki gets an opportunity to
be on Main stage and there's some
players up here that we haven't seen
playing in a while all of them household
names in fact this is my Killer Instinct
Mount Rushmore yes that is actually the
perfect way to describe this I think
right it's like we got some Evo
Champions we've got some players that
are up there for the greatest of all
time right some really storied Legacy
players here for Killer Instinct so it
should be a good time and I was really
excited to see that not only are they
here but we're having an exhibition and
people seem so excited for it I know I'm
so excited I mean like sleep I haven't
seen him on this game in the longest and
right no I haven't either Nikki and bass
a little bit more active you know but
all these guys are Gods on their own
rights you know you have Rico Suave and
you have sleep those are both World Cup
champions and Evo Champions yeah and it
was so good to walk in and you see the
wall of Evo Champions and you just like
look on there and you're like whoa
there's Ki right there right cool so I'm
happy that this exhibition is happening
thanks for everybody who's tuning in at
home and also everybody out in the crowd
out there who are ready for some Ki
action hope everybody is ready to dig in
there and hear the music out there on
the main stage I hear it pumping I can't
wait to hear it again because it's been
a while since I've heard it in in Evo
you know what I mean out there on the
main stage so yeah it's so exciting you
know Ki always has a home at combo
breaker which is awesome and you know
that Rick is the one pulling the strings
on that so it's no surprise that we're
getting it here on the state on the main
stage but like you said it's been a long
time since we've seen anything like that
it looks like the players are just kind
of getting their peripherals ready let's
go with the big tricks yeah it looks
like we're gonna have Rico versus base
that's not I think what we saw earlier
so that makes a lot of sense they have a
double limb bracket it's gonna be three
out of five matches it's pretty normal
four players obviously it's not not too
long of a tournament right this is the
shortest tournament at either it is yeah
and it's an exhibition in that right but
you're getting the three out of five so
that's
they look pretty relaxed yeah okay
button check action you know the usual
fighting game everybody's like I gotta
check my buttons make sure everything's
good yeah sun's not in my eyes yeah
yeah this was before we had the whole
like the one that you have in Street
Fighter now yes see all the buttons on
the screen with the display inputs and
everything like that new fancy stuff
this game came out in 2013. it's been a
decade yeah it's the 10-year anniversary
all right little button Tech action as
you're mentioning
back into it I love that the menus wow
look at that crowd out there what's up
everybody hopefully you're enjoying Evo
it's lovely to see all your faces out
here to see the crowd hear the music
hope everybody's ready for some Ki
action here on the main stage big Friday
afternoon
spinal classic classic bass yeah for
sure and we'll see what character Rico's
gonna go with Rico's a he's a father
he's a family man dad now yeah he's been
uh playing all kinds of games lately so
we'll see how he's doing Omen is like
maybe the pick he's going for here I've
seen him place a moment in the past
I've been watching a stream recently and
this is usually who I've been seeing in
play it's also worth mentioning that
this is a pretty frustrating matchup for
spinal it's kind of hard for him to
anti-air the way that Omen kind of
swoops down on his Dome Crossing him up
and everything like that it's kind of
aggravating for his final to deal with
it's gonna have to be able to reposition
himself with teleports you know I mean
you face a character specialist right
he's no stranger to this matchup exactly
it's gonna be a good one tough one to
deal with that airspace I'm sure if you
haven't seen cat before you don't know
about all the air dashes and air
movement and a character like Omen has
he also has great projectiles he's got
good normals on the ground and he's very
slippery and hard to keep down once you
hit him right he has the shadow Escape
part of his three meters down there you
see in the bottom right be very tough
for sure as he flies in right back to
the front great block there from base
look at the names victory in a second
there as you can see at the top that's
not Hollywood sleep but we'll get that
fixed and ready for you here at Evo
jab jab pressure just kind of nice and
safe so far as we get some Shadow or
pressure Rico's just trying to put the
pressure on here he's trying to get base
to open up and it's just not happening
right now oh great anti-air that's those
fundamentals that's the dad fundamentals
right there they never leave you the
older you get the more those
fundamentals sink in you know what I
mean he's like I'm ready he's changing
diapers and Auntie aren't at the same
time
oh nice teleport checks him with the
sword Rico trying to up back gets it out
of there nice and safe and sound both
players being so smart about the way
that they reposition themselves on the
screen here Rico gotta confirm there he
decides to go for another mix-up whose
Shadow order he's gonna put these
Fireballs on the screen base might lose
this first life bar without being able
to pop his Instinct oh there it is
the teleport this is a big chance now
for base and I guess break right on the
mediums just the pixel now he teleports
backwards into the projectiles the first
light bar there for Rico as he runs away
from the instinct
Rico looking for this opening again base
is just opting to block here going for
those antiers is more likely to get him
to open up big lockout this is going to
be a level three yeah level three on the
cave uh KV meter there a little teleport
out
and again that's the one thing about
Omen he's so slippery it's really hard
to deal with Rico's trying for the
crunching light light into the slide
there but the second one just missed
it's about minus two there Bates the
reversal out
oh early lockout but doesn't get to
capitalize on that at all yeah I mean
rika's been going for a lot of early
break opportunities and then bass just
hasn't been looking for a big combo's
watch try to catch him guessing there
with the counter break and oh
big opportunity here activates the
Instinct neutral jump on the throw no
punish though and the stuff on the
shadow nice so pretty even match here
especially since Rico's instinct's gone
away
yeah Rico's got a little bit of instinct
here we're gonna see if he can get
something started with it he does have
the ability to lock out base's meter and
there it is just as I say it space is
not going to have access to that meter
even though he has a build
oh catches the jump there not a great
Fireball pattern to be honest with you
no omen's Fireballs are all random
actually and it's kind of up for the
omen player to just play off of them oh
nice and the Ender is enough game one to
the family man I'm liking Rico swap dude
this guy Rico came up to me was like you
know man uh I've been busy with life you
know doing other stuff I don't know if I
can still game the same way that's an
EVO champ right there he gets game one
yeah you can never count him out and
here it is his base is going right to
the center this is kind of a staple
thing for him to do in this situation
because you know Cinder he kind of has a
flash kick like up kick except you don't
need a charge to do it and it's much
better as an anti-air option against the
character like element yeah down up kick
right it's easy peasy yeah
one thing that it's like so funny about
this game is explaining to people like
yeah it's like a charge move without the
charge yeah it is what and you get a
comb off it yeah
and then you get to go wild that's just
kind of the whole game you know oh yeah
so here we go back in as you mentioned
Cinder I think a better choice right you
can control the air a little bit more
and a little bit more control in general
and how the pace of the match goes I
think versus final it's kind of a
Sitting Duck
yeah the Fireballs that Rico are gonna
throw out the ones that he's gonna want
the most are the ones that are gonna
stuff the Fireballs that face is gonna
throw out because that's kind of how
Cinder makes his way in right like a lot
of his forward movement is really really
risky
he's got to land a fireball on you and
then the threat of the explosion that's
how he gets in right just right now you
see that in firebar there's gonna pop it
and an immediate breaker on the jungle
light punch doesn't want to see any of
that combo to the recap and anything
else
setting up the bombs now and again yeah
Rico it's on him to approach now a lot
of these instances gray blocks he did
not want to open up on that one at all
catches the back jump with that yeah
these confirms are all going into these
launchers and Rico's not getting much
off it
the nice thing about having an
invincible reversal like that right we
see moments like that where there's
pressure and you just you know down up
kick he's out of there he doesn't have
to worry about trying to anti-air oh he
almost got the explosion off but the
fireball actually hit him
oh going for some chip here Rico just
Waits it out he knows that he has a
light bleed and those Fireballs aren't
doing that oh [__] it's not really
muffin that he has to worry about oh
bait zipper wasn't ready yeah he was
fired up so he gets the extension here
burns the arms and I chase that with the
Trailblazer what a confirm
I wake up from Rico I had the instinct
to uh pop and be plus after so it makes
a lot of sense front throw again with
the orbs no combo afterwards but just
real more pressure in
big moment here can you get the cash out
no the breaker these gas breaks from
Rico have all been accurate I think he's
been right every single time yeah and
and even when he's been wrong basis
combos have been so short it really
hasn't hurt him that much
that was one of those moments where the
breaker was really reactable right so
it's like I know that you know I'm just
gonna do it so really cool yeah at that
point
nice little fake out on that jumping
down heavy kick gets a little fake out
throw empty like that a lot so dead even
here oh my God he almost got the whip on
it for that
okay
both players sitting on all their meter
right here
we're gonna see the shadow orbs pressure
I'm sure here soon
oh my God despair this is gonna put
your base and cash all these
all this can actually kill him right
here
oh my god do it Rico Suave gets the game
just like that that is one of the rarest
moves that you can ever see in ki
because you need all of omen's bar to do
it and I mean if it doesn't work out for
you it's I mean you whiff the throw you
lose all your meter it's not really a
good situation for you to be in for a
character that's so meter dependent as
Omen is and yeah it's basically like a
raging demon that like I have to hit you
again to kill you yes exactly that's the
perfect way to put it it's I I cannot
believe that it's really risky too like
I mean if you whiff like it's so much
meter but yeah
dangerous to go for it doesn't work out
on this counter pick so even if you know
Rico loses this game right he has the
choice to switch if he wants to wow beat
the anti-air
and he's gonna go for a burnout here now
this means that every time the RICO uses
his punch specials it's actually going
to increase his white life and that's
why Rico just used all kicks on these
confirms here yeah I think you really
don't mind getting your arms burnt out
as Omen that much you know like sure you
don't have fireballs and some other
stuff but he's got really good kicks
anyway and he's got a good case specials
though yeah he's pretty versatile in
that sense he doesn't have to totally
rely on the punch buttons as much as
other characters do
yeah some characters it's a much bigger
destroyment for sure
oh this is going to be a reversal here
yeah not too much damage but you got out
of the situation and that gets baited
the other way breaker on the medium
doubles
base probably looking to connect so that
he can pop his Instinct here he could
get a Juggle off of this very nice oh
he's gonna capitalize off of this
lockout he might try to go for a
mid-round burn
oh okay a battery under is nice too
batteries level three or four it will
carry over to the next life bar if it's
level one or two I wouldn't bother with
it it doesn't even matter yeah and the
battery under gives you meter back right
so it's always a nice thing to have
might as well take the resources oh
trailblades are right over but the
fireball saved the day for Rico there
that was so smart That Bass actually
canceled that right there because Rico
could have Shadow countered that for
free and he definitely would have oh too
early on that that is a lot of light to
eat away
especially for Center who usually
doesn't have big damage opportunities
unless he burns you yeah Cinder is kind
of the character that he has to hit you
twice like you said before to really
like really do the damage what a confirm
he almost confirmed that Rico's still
alive here two bars an instinct back
throw into the corner very nice bases on
the board yeah it looks much better than
that game and that's kind of what I
expected when we saw the counter pick in
the first place right so I'm very
curious if Rico has another character
hero that he's gonna go to or he's just
gonna stick it out against uh so yeah
with the omen like although I think that
Cinder has way better anterior options
against him but I don't really think
that this is that terrible I think that
the random Fireballs floating around the
screen can be really obnoxious to
Traverse but I was gonna say Rico has a
really really good gargos and the portal
punches are pretty obnoxious for cinder
to deal with and a lot of Cinder players
think that this is a pretty terrible
matchup you know why play a five five
when you could play a six four well he's
thinking about it yeah he's kind of
hovering around the screen on a couple
of different characters we'll see if
he's just gonna go back into the omen he
does okay so it doesn't lock in with the
gargos despite it maybe this is just his
comfort you know like it's the character
he plays the most as you mentioned yeah
I mean this is what you've been playing
lately right Rico's been uh brushing up
on this game lately on his stream to get
ready for this exhibition yeah every
time I tune in he was playing Jaime so
you know it's a little different I was
like wait a minute
oh my God he tried to chase that back
dash down with that fourth though
oh my God the Double Dash and then the
big DP just challenges oh but this is
the recap but it's okay though
still some damage up there because of
the KV wow a couple of drops face
jumping back trying to set up and
re-establish a neutral here it gets
counter hit on the triple
oh he's fishing for another confirmed
there I don't know if that was a drop or
a reset attempt there from base Rico's
gonna try to get some Opie started here
Shadow order
the combo here oh it didn't quite reach
actually lots of combo drops in this
match
not a bad pattern to approach that at
all so yeah Rico trying to get in there
with this ore bottom still gonna be
Shadow pressure the orbs are gonna shoot
out yeah catches him on the anti air
repeats the throw butt no punish no
throws in this game they have so much
recovery so easy to punish I'm very
surprised if that didn't catch there
Rico on the verge are closing out this
health bar and that lockout is going to
do it
around the world a lot of meter built
there too for Rico so potential that we
could see it happen again actually he's
about to have full meter
oh there's that mind game now now the
mind game has started the last time we
saw base break that or our Rico counter
broke him on there rather yeah huge
meter lead now for Rico
and he breaks right again man his guess
he's been so consistent so far
oh and the orb on the inside great
awareness the block from base
breaker on the board heavy too I mean
it's reactable so I don't blame wow he's
been right so many times I'm telling you
today with these Breakers he is psychic
he has not been the wrong one not a bad
trade there for base he kind of really
just disrupted the whole order setup he
forced Rico to spend another bar to get
something going there and he just
challenges with a jab the trade wasn't
too damaging but he is down on life so
that could end up being a factor lots of
chip on this
wake up in the trade man Paces down so
much life though
finally gets that health bar but he's
got such a long road to do it here
Instinct pop big opportunity now
plus frames there oh my God no
capitalization on the throw and Rico
does not bite and that's huge he's gonna
take opportunity to get some potential
uh life up there that was a great uh
phase out there from Rico getting out of
that situation there's a break base
really had no choice there had to do it
chip is gonna be a problem here soon he
goes for it needs to get out of this
position can he do it so low on life now
got some bombs to work with Misses the
jungle but fake out a light punch
fissure this is a chance now and the
wake up jab Rico Suave 3-1 moving on
over base
the game never leaves you in that sense
man
you just don't beat the active players
even if you haven't played a fighting
game in like a decade you know how to
match dab on wake up you know what I
mean you got to do it I mean at that
point you know that I mean he saw the
faint from base he knows that he has to
get kind of like you kind of got to mix
it up you gotta color Outside the Lines
if you want to get that opening he has a
lot of reason to match jab on wake up
there and Rico was like yeah not dealing
with us at all I love the way you put
that color outside the line you just got
it yeah you gotta make something wild
happen right yeah you can't play on
Rails like that when you got to make the
comeback you got to start mixing it up a
little bit you got to get a little weird
yeah there's our first set wow I'm I'm
kind of surprised honestly Rico looked
pretty sharp I gotta say you did up
against someone who's still very
proficient at this game too right which
is the cool thing about this same thing
with our next set you know another as
you mentioned CAD cup and Evo champion
in sleep up against Nikki who's someone
who still Champions the game to this day
right oh yeah he's a combo breaker champ
he's a CEO Champion I've seen the belt
it's heavy it's like heavier than I
thought it is I've seen the best I've
seen the belt yeah it's pretty heavy
yeah
um these guys are both ridiculous
players sleep uh he's more playing
Street Fighter right now but I mean
playing Ki you know again you're dealing
with a World Cup champion and an EVO
champion
yeah I mean Street Fighter has 7 000
entrance I think everybody's playing a
little Street Fighter absolutely yeah
definitely and so I guess my big
question here is what are we gonna see
because I know that Nikki is an idol
player as well he has a pocket Idol
sleep recently I have seen him playing
Idol so I'm not really sure if that's
who he's gonna be going with interesting
yeah yeah I'm actually really curious I
mean that's the one thing about this
game you know whether it's your prime or
something you played it later on
everybody has a lot of characters yeah
there's very few people who only play
one character in this game I mean the
characters in the game are so cool it's
hard not to dabble you know what I mean
so a lot of people have secondaries or
third characters that they play in
certain matchups especially if they're
just like I'm not playing that match if
I refuse to do it so tournaments have
all these counter picking back and forth
and stuff like that same kind of thing
we saw in that first set right same same
matches the characters all switched up
and everything so I'm curious we're
gonna see the same thing here Nikki has
a bunch of characters so he has a couple
characters you can mess with so we'll
have to see and like Ki is a game that
has such wild characters that when you
explain to them the people on paper you
just explain them in the vacuum with no
context of the rest of the game and
everybody's just like that character
sounds top tier and I'm like it's
actually like bottom five yeah he's like
terrible yeah like this character can do
all this left right upside down while
saying he's like the worst character in
the game you're like what how is this
character bad
but I mean that's cool thing about the
game everybody who's played Ki can tell
you that the characters are super fun
the music is super good I mean hearing
the music in this game is so funny
because it came out so long ago now and
you're like damn
these are the game soundtracks are
pretty good but that Ki Oh my God it's
one of the greatest soundtracks of all
time that was like Mick Gordon doing
that as well
made some really really sick tracks for
that game some straight up Classics yeah
all the music in this game is incredible
the sounds are good the menu sounds when
you like toggle through the menu
It's So satisfying the first time I
noticed that that was happening I was
mind blown yeah it's so good
all the little details man everything
about it's really really good so looks
like they're set up on the stage doing a
little uh butt checking maybe idle
Conrad interesting yeah we'll have to
see I think I don't know I can't read
lips for sure but I thought I saw a
button check on there so we'll have to
see
yeah so I think that this is Nikki going
with Idol here and sleep is going with
Maya I think I'm not sure if they're
ready to rock right here but I do
remember when they had these Microsoft
tournaments in New York sleep I think
sleep won one of those with Maya yeah I
believe it that was a while ago but he
has like a really really strong Maya
yeah she's she's another example Great
Character design really really fun in
this game now letting the intros Rock I
assume this is real I
and we're gonna get the start of the
intro they're showing us that Mage Idol
is actually what we're getting from the
start more of a zoning body so sleep is
going to want to close the gap right at
the start here they're ready
making his way in there you go with the
Mantis pushing into the corner back
Fierce getting the party started right
off the bat the media mantis is like
such a big tell too you know what I mean
it's like what's up I'm just gonna do it
well I went for the counter break and I
you know people know Nikki likes to
break it early and often right so I kind
of like that idea double meteor has not
gotten Warrior body yet there it is
nice reversal get off of me pushing back
into the corner he's trying to throw
these daggers because he's either going
to kind of confirm or he's going to get
a pit which is going to benefit by a lot
uh DP right into the Instinct this is
where it gets scary for this character I
mean he's a really strong character but
it's especially dangerous
yeah top five instinct for sure yeah
this is really just the worst yeah this
spot look at how much damage the shadow
does Alone by the way
meteors again I can't see help yeah
there's not a lot you could do off of
that and Nikki almost picked up a
recapture confirm off of that stuffing
that reversal yeah I send DB did for the
trade there very nicely done so look
again we talked about how strong the
instinct is yeah Nikki basically just
you know died and then was like oh cool
I'll pop insane character became God for
about 10 seconds yeah
that was really really smart there that
um he was trying to go for something on
a confirm there he knew that sleep
didn't have any part of Shadow counter
that so he's just gonna swing that all
day and take these plus frames and that
head switch is actually Invincible yeah
he gives you an idea about what the
opponent is trying to do sometimes too
right which is really nice oh no breaker
that was a medium blinker or meet a
manual there
I'm gonna get a pip here this is
actually gonna give a run cancel to the
opposite body so the warrior body right
here is going to get a run cancel there
it is yeah well when the reversal caught
the jump there so a chance now for Sleep
needs a throw Double Daggers oh the
breaker and now you can pick both of
them up yep
this is neutral that is that is really
scary to deal with yeah
oh it didn't have time for the lights
actually it was able to break in time so
I'm lucky there for Sleep body gets to
slip it in
oh
body swap time just in time
this is really close to killing one
chance scenario you might just go for
the setup here I don't know I'm just
gonna kill him I think he's just dead
right oh no a pixel oh I'm in the chip
anyways and the taunt
we'll have to see but yeah if you if you
don't know Idol with a stance
characterist right he has two bodies
that he goes between without your choice
he just does it whenever he's feeling
like it right and uh when you Instinct
you have the power of both bodies
combined and it is super scary like it
is super messed up his instinct's one of
the strongest things in the game I think
top top five maybe top three Instinct
it's really really without a doubt
without a doubt any character that does
a DP and then has a meteor come down
after it is yeah definitely a problem
summoning a meteor is already pretty
powerful but to be able to do it off of
your DP seems pretty good and this is
more of the staple character that we're
seeing here from sleep is Arya this is
kind of his classic pick
breaker right there on the medium
doubles just ready for it oh he was
already backdashing though trying to set
up with the assistant see Nikki so much
pressure now the swap to Mage form gonna
be zoning yeah teleport
one of the most challenging things about
fighting Idol is how much you have to
shift gears like that was not uh the
greatest call on there from the Shadow
from sleep it's really really hard to
make those choices between the different
bodies and he's got two Pips here which
is really important you do the dash
cancels you mentioned earlier tried one
right there
oh and the DP whiff
yeah that was definitely gonna be Dash
cancel too so you got to be very careful
float makes up lands but
it's the break right away
that uppercut assist is so strong it
actually counts as a physical attack and
sleep is gonna lose this body here and
this actually means that Arya is not
going to be able to get that assist
either Aria is kind of moving into a
different phase now where she's gonna
have the blade body she's gonna have the
booster behind her or rather the base
body behind her and she's going to be
able to pop an instinct and get Mix-Ups
yeah which is a good spot to be wow no
breaker on the recap but then breaks the
lights after
looking for that heavy punch just trying
to find some space Oh my God the empty
jump load Nikki finds it has lots of
Shadow meter here too
yeah this could potentially hurt a lot
he's gonna get a setup off of this as
well oh he switches to Mage body yeah
the where's your setup right there just
walk back you're like oh God
on the shadow counter that was such a
smart Shadow counter a really good
defensive option for a character that
only actually has a reversal with meter
in this body oh and gets locked out no
meter to extend so not the biggest
damage ever but on this body it still
hurts
those Pips for the run councils too and
wow gets over it
oh no man this is a really rough looking
round for sleep here you haven't even
seen anything yeah
we're gonna see the Instinct pop here
from Nikki yet yeah there it is right
there
a shadow Club caught the back dash two
doesn't get the combo teleports to the
other side and catches them trying to
escape
oh my God this character is absolute
chaos sleep is in huge trouble here in
the corner oh brutal spot so instinct's
gonna wear down but let's sleep the The
Comeback Factor here is not that High I
mean
you have Instinct but it's so much life
to chew through here pops it
oh my God he just woke up this is
exhibition his wake up buttons the
exhibition right now yeah wake up a
media button immediately says oh it's
Ultra time I don't have to care about
anything else 2-0 Nikki looking good the
crowd happy to be here he's trying to
Hype him up
sit right back into it let's go wake up
buttons I did it I match let's go
that's how I am at home
break confirm on that that's actually a
pretty hard move to punish there yeah
the crescendo out of the air like that
especially because a lot of times
there's an assist back in it up and
other stuff's happening so it's not
always used to it yeah we haven't really
seen sleep like take control of the
match and like start his momentum yeah
Nikki's kind of been in control for the
past two games here it's not really been
able to establish wow that was a great
block even better Shadow counter oh got
the swap to the Mage form
and Sing Pop
yeah
that freeze right there is this gonna
beat out the armor very nice oh and
counter breaker at the end insult to
injury there from Nikki he's gonna get a
pip there it was already a three-way
guess oh yeah it's like why not
and the meteor while he almost got to
recap on that yeah he's been going for
those confirms and it kind of shows that
he gets those often if he's gonna go
over that there yeah oh the overhead
connects
gotta guessing yeah guess who's wrong on
the Ender there good spot in here for
Sleep he's gonna have a little bit of
instinct to play with at the beginning
of this round but he doesn't look like
he's gonna be able to get to play with
any of it because Nikki kind of just
back through him in that situation yeah
I like that the DP on the dash cancel
too oh and that time he does choose the
break interesting that's a a spot where
counter breaker is not a bad idea a lot
of times too for the same reason right
you know what the strength is going to
be you're ready to break wow what a [__]
oh my God what a block on that overhead
both players stand on both meters here
oh no punish on any of that man yeah he
just did not even try maybe a little too
afraid it breaks wrong oh that is huge
gonna take the command grab here at the
end yeah it gives you the pit for the
other body
yeah that pip is gonna give the Mage
body multiple special moves by just
using one strength you could kind of
like surge it almost like Shadow jigo
double tap the button
oh it didn't bite huge punish here for
Nikki
wow what a break from sleep he knows
about that
scary spot but still the instinct's
pumping oh that's gonna be huge she
might just be dead not quite
a pixel that kills at the very end there
man Nikki cleans it up oh yeah
the taunts I think he was trying to go
for Ultra he's trying to go for all
kinds of stuff
press here on the stage thumbs up so
he's playing Rico in Winner's side here
I like that little sequence that was at
the end there from Nikki because the
crouching heavy punch that he went for
and that goes into an instinct pop has
such a small window for you to break on
it yeah but sleep knew about that
because he was like preemptively
breaking it he saw that he had Instinct
and he knew immediately what he's going
for in that situation so that just goes
to show that sleep had the awareness
there unfortunately it wasn't enough to
pay off so he's going to drop down to
losers I think he's gonna be playing
bass in there yeah
man what a wild little bracket here cool
exhibition I'm happy when Evo was like
yeah we're gonna do a little Ki
expression I was like dude that sounds
awesome you know it's really cool
there's games that came back like uh
they're doing Marvel right here as a
throwback tournament I'm sure a lot of
people looking at that their game in
mind you know they're like oh is it time
to do a little throwback tournament but
then an exhibition for chaos I'm
satiated you know I'm satiated yeah I
can handle that I was like all right
that sounds good to me it looks awesome
I would love for it to be the throwback
game on here would be dope yeah it would
be really sick would be
but anyway we got our losers match it
looks like up on stage uh they're ready
to play here it's not not a very long
bracket for this exhibition no it's not
you know so it's easy to keep track of
you're like there's four people Grand
finals two in here and Grandpa yeah
Grand final's here like you know you
figure it out pretty easily which is
cool I love that a lot and I appreciate
Evo having it it's very very dope happy
to be here doing this so it's gonna be
uh based up against sleep sleep
literally just played you know they're
just like hey sit in that seat it's keep
it nice and warm you're gonna be doing
some gaming right now usually if
somebody wins they tell them like stay
on that setup they usually don't tell
you you stay on that setup if you lost
yeah usually not yeah loser stays on
that's very rarely the format for a
fighting game event so there we have it
wow look at this camera shot you can see
some of the stages in the background
it's like a giant horseshoe is how I
described it of stages for Evo this year
there's stages all across the walls and
then obviously we're here on the main
stage with killer instinctive which is
really cool
yeah it really is I was looking for the
main stage earlier and I was like I
don't know these all look pretty main to
me yeah yeah all of them even though
they're the community safe just like
straight across from us even that stage
looks like a main stage too I was like
is this what's going on here so
characters it's Eagle Aria look like to
me she makes sense giving these two they
both do play those characters we just
saw the Aria for uh sleep obviously and
bass definitely placed an eagle himself
so we'll have to see
good to go locked in
yeah Eagle is a really good pick for
base this is a character he has so much
tournament experience with he uses this
character all the time even if the
matchup isn't necessarily totally great
I think it's kind of art it's hard for
Arya to do Aria things when you have all
these arrows coming from all these
different angles shooting Ari out of the
sky cliff and ursus it's really annoying
I think the real downside here is that
both characters have crazy mix but Eagle
is the one with the bad reversal options
yeah we're gonna see if sleep can get
something started here yeah defensively
pretty whack uh that's like kind of his
big thing right the the bird explosion
is sort of his main way to deal this
stuff but it's not the best thing in the
world oh man basil throw the bird there
it is the bird saves the day but then
you lose access to it for a little bit
which can be a pretty big factor in this
match honestly
you need it for mix you need it for the
Screech you need it for doing the arrows
or something you know
a lot of uses for it try to Antioch
there and get stuffed out of that shot
pushing into the corner here he's gonna
call his assist sleep is going to try to
keep the Mix-Ups tight enough to where
the bird cannot get through the Gap and
we have a pause no Bubba it happens just
like that oh right back into the match
they're going whatever
even the bird he was like are we done
you see him laying on the ground dude
imagine being in the exhibition and
being like I'm taking where's the judge
I'm with an EVO exhibition it's my time
uh uh wow float over but the Instinct
Bob lets him see it I like that jab
confirmed he knew that there was going
to be enough recovery frames on the
ground there nice yeah pick up the
arrows you can see in the bottom left
for uh Eagle there you got to keep track
of those arrows and you lose them pretty
quick sometimes right so it can be
pretty pretty difficult once you run out
so that's what the birds for that's what
your body's for you gotta go pick them
up
one arrow in the chamber here
yeah Eagle does have a super where he's
able to pick all those back up and he's
kind of just gonna slide and he's gonna
jump over over the counter grab him jump
back put sleep in the corner here
nice and the Screech covered it there
gets the DP oh this should be a DP I
think here right oh no yeah I'm not sure
what sleepers yeah there was play body
okay I was gonna say it maybe there's no
blade body and I didn't see but mix up
yeah okay he actually got through that a
lot of the times that'll trade with the
reversal oh he's hugging the screen to
try to keep the arrows off screen yeah
now goes to the mix-up so he's gonna get
the arrows back in a second here but
trying to get some pressure here there's
not really a lot that you could do about
that bird and it recovers so fast too
it's kind of like the core of how eagle
gets all these Mix-Ups off
yeah it is really cheap he doesn't
Screech he shoots the arrows over her
head and he goes low and you're just
like well three frame slide slide or
Shadow slide into the Screech also very
good for when that assist got clipped
there in the process
yeah blade is just gonna hit oh with oh
I'm surprised she was plus there if she
was buzzed yeah I was so scrambly in
that situation it's hard to tell right
goes low afterwards
and sleep yeah this pressure is so hard
to deal with pops the instinct to see
the mix of it's gonna be a shadow
Arya is so low on life here wow welcome
crashing light kick shotguny
nice break I mean at that point you got
to make something happen you have two
bodies left now one
yeah Snipes the body trying to get those
arrows back I mean it's so neck and neck
here goes low finds a hit immediately
into Ultra I like that idea there from
base to go low because it is such a
staple Arya thing to do to just do that
jumping heavy kick at the start of the
round because it actually does hit
overhead it hits really low yeah so it
was really good at clipping people who
were expecting throws and all that stuff
and for basically just kind of stay low
mashing the light it stops the approach
it avoids The Jump covers a lot of
options it was a good choice yeah look
at that sea of Gamers out there there's
a lot of people here
I like that just manual sweep right at
the end holding steady oh my God I don't
know if that Arrow was unblockable if he
holds it long enough it's unblockable
and it's like just was like I'm not
trying to hold it I can't say I blame
him yeah and you can see sleep is trying
to DP out she says I don't want to deal
with the pressure I'm just going to try
to get out of here I like that idea
there's a sign of scramble avoid it but
this body is getting beat up oh it just
goes for the raw Swap and there's a
punish
yeah you got to take the good with the
bad there you got to kind of take the
hit on that body in the process You're
Gonna Save the other one though and
you're gonna get a reversal it's a
pretty good trade gets hit by the arrow
on the way out man sleeves bodies are
getting beat up oh holding it looking
for the unblockable trying to charge it
all the way as you mentioned now this
body is getting destroyed see the cash
out not enough to kill it's so close and
another tag
these raw body switches from sleep are
not working out in his favor right now
face with a huge life lead and I think
that other body is still alive right
yeah we might just see the Instinct pop
here maybe oh the controller again
what's happening up there
going for this pressure high low
pressure here Shadow sly
side Swap Man and the body is taking
share damage here so these hits are
really gonna add up
sleep trying to go for more of a zoning
approach here he's got a really good
anti-air assist he's got an anterior
super there
yeah trying to push base away from these
arrows as well exactly it doesn't do
much damage that NCR super as you
mentioned but it's like really strong it
hits everything
all the Snipes from base yeah now that
he has such a big lead I think this
zoning is a pretty good idea
yeah it's actually working out for him
right now
plus frames there he's gonna bait out a
shadow counter and that is gonna be the
ultra this kicking out the window you
don't get the sea stage Ultras very
often so I'm glad that we got to see
that here on the main stage falling all
the way down the building the crowd was
doing it they're like falling all the
way down
stage Ultra cool to see
I have some knockoff Supreme
that's not true
looks like we're back to characters like
they were talking about the the
controller situation they're like hey
man what's going on with your controller
bro let's go you got batteries in that
bad boy get some Double A's like what's
up yeah every console has its weird
controller issues right like PS4 like
it's on the responsibility of the
previous player to disconnect it Xbox
controllers that want like updates in
the middle of the tournaments sometimes
how it goes they got to keep you up to
date the newest and latest firmware so
you can get your gaming done going with
glacias here this is kind of a tough
pick here I mean he's gonna get
liquidized he's gonna get to avoid some
arrows here but these are coming in at
some awkward angles and it's gonna be
hard for sleep to get some hail out and
get anything started yeah the one thing
is that uh held Arrow especially in this
matchup too is a little bit annoying to
deal with right it's a lot of stuff
going yeah I mean this spot is miserable
for every character but oh yeah
absolutely
those are the puddle punch and the slide
right under the hail gonna go for a
mid-screen mix up here oh my God that
puddle punch oh double hail and he's
ready for it with the shadow gotta guess
and he guesses wrong that's the life bar
he's gonna collect his Arrow here in the
middle of the round
again
watch out with the arrow too it was like
perfectly fine
you shot him with the arrows bam right
in the head all right they're back into
it
man he had a long time to think about
that puddle punch you know I like that
he said time out of time in yeah
wait a minute let me think about it
it's multiple choice he's like what do I
want to do yeah it's a real life
Instinct Bob
his little liquid eyes fake out in the
face I like using the bird right there
too and yeah these Snipes have been
really good from base to just like jump
shoot the arrow or shoot the arrow to
stuff the hail start up use the bird to
stuff it you know just really I think
smart play on the spot I hit in the
front oh punish
another big lock out there base does not
capitalize much on that though he's just
gonna go for the mix up here
which is happening a little scramble
situation here
that was such a smart wake up from sleep
it's projectile immune he's gonna push
all the way into the corner here
oh nice unblockable hail's there to link
off of it I like that with the heavy
and goes for the jump down are you
trying to hop out of there he's got a
guess on the break oh this is the big
chance now
and the breaker ain't a good break
jump the screech in from the other side
jump over throw not enough to kill now
but he's gonna be able to set up
Instinct pop goes for a bunch
base gonna clean it up three to zero
there I like that you called that a real
life Instinct Papa I can't get over this
yeah it was like the controllers with
the freeze frames yeah so you can see
what's happening I like that that was
close a little scrambly at the end there
and I like the glacias pick actually it
looked like it was doing okay despite
the matchup being a little you know
dealing with some stuff but yeah it's so
awkward because glacias is a character
that he kind of plays like a turret
almost like yeah does that have like a
conventional Dash they gave him a dash
because they wanted him to have a dash
like everybody else but you shouldn't
use it it's kind of just like he's
rooted in one place yes that's kind of
awkward because you know Eagles coming
at you from all these different angles
and it's really hard to get yourself in
the right position to get set up when he
didn't used to have a dash and people
were like why doesn't glacias have a
dash so they gave him like a really bad
Dash yeah they gave him like this weird
slide it's like really awesome looking
and they're like you go he's got a dash
and everybody's like take it away I
don't want it yeah because now you get
it by accident yeah you're like I got my
Dash by accident it's no good so you
know that's just how it goes you
shouldn't have asked for a dash that's
what you get you don't know it's like a
monkey's paw like almost like a patch
wish you know what I mean wow look at
all the gamers that Eva this year holy
smokes can the crowd out there to Make
Some Noise for Evo this year
wait wait I'm curious I want to ask a
question
how many of you by way of noise is this
your first time at Evo this year
that's a lot of people that is a lot of
people that is a lot of Gamers out there
buy some noise out there how many of you
are not new to Evo you've been here
before
that's still a lot of people it's cool
to see love to have everybody out here
so many people have come up to me and
been like yeah I got into fighting games
during covid and like you know this is
my first Evo or I came last year and
it's my second time here it's really
really cool to see so awesome
damn that was a lot of people there is a
lot of gamers in this venue I'll tell
you what
Nikki gonna go with the rash pick here
rational though
let me go looking like he's still gonna
stay with omen
I don't know if we're gonna go with a
button Checker we're just gonna go right
into it I have to see the star
winterside match looks like a fist bump
ready to go rash omen
I'm digging the rainbow rash I love this
skin yeah rash is so fun he is that's
what we don't talk about enough right
because we're too busy talking about how
cheap he is he's super fun yeah super
fun super cheap really cool character I
can't believe he's in the game I can't
either
he has uh if you don't know much about
rash he has a tongue that he can use to
move around the screen it also eats
projectiles because he's hungry he needs
it yeah it feeds a meter when he eats
your projectile he's also got that's a
wrecking ball oh my God big punish on
that DP could have been a little bit
more damage but I like that Nikki just
opted to go with the light for the fast
confirm yep yeah um
Wrecking Ball in excuse me
Shadow so much damage on this a wrecking
ball in there for the uh wall Splat and
went to beat the throw
Rico didn't bite at first but then a
little whiff after tried for the meaty
boot
no confirm going for the throw reset I
like that little tricky Mind Games there
yeah especially because a lot of times
you're looking to you know break some
medium or heavy or whatever
oh he eats the Shadow or eats the orb on
the reversal the spinning Timberland as
tasty Steve calls it I like that I like
that
oh and the shadow horns this time yeah
and we were talking about terrifying
instincts before and this is one of them
yeah oh and the song thrusts on the main
stage at Evo the recap with the bike
oh and went for the counter breaker Rico
didn't bite
yeah that's where Shadow locks out the
uh meter not gonna be a factor yet but
might just be oh this this pressure is
going to be hard to deal with oh good
throw tech there Nikki finding his way
out he's got his meter locked out here
and Rico might be trying to keep that
meter locked down here there's actually
an Ender that Omen can do to somebody
where he just makes it so that you can't
use a bar even if you have it yeah
oh we're back dash oh he went for that
again I like that he did he's willing to
dump the meter just to say are you awake
are you ready for all this yeah that
forward heavy punch is actually
something that Omen ticks into it and
Nikki knows that he's ready for that
yeah he was ready for the job I mean I'm
sure he saw it after the last set right
he's like oh yeah he's gonna do that
that's what we're doing in this
exhibition that's how you feel yeah
I like it got stuff there oh tried for
the jumping heavy kick didn't quite make
it
wrecking ball again lots of pressure
Rico not able to find a good answer yet
pops
fades it with the car and that's a big
lockout has Shadow meter to dump here
and goes with a reset onto the card for
the recapture lockout again this should
be ultra game one here goes then Nikki
with the really clean sequence right
there that was such a smart sequence
from Nikki because he put him into a
situation where he knew Rico's locked
out I can sneak this shadow in here it's
not possible for you to break it here so
it's just gonna push him into danger and
I'm gonna go for the ultra I like Rico's
like what is happening he's like what
are you doing to me up there you're
doing a thing and you're flying and
doing this yeah could you run that by me
what are you doing or break that down
for me
I like that he kind of just challenges
to get over the ball he jumps over it
and he confirms into a lockout
good damage on that too for no meter
nice breaks on the lights ready for it
this time wow big wrecking ball doesn't
get a Juggle though
oh he confirmed off of that crouching
light kick too that was really good yeah
into the standing jab jab park on the
RICO at the break though and this time
no break no back throw though yeah I
really do not hate that break at all
from Mickey that counter break attempt
was really really smart
oh a little early on the throw
trying to find some pressure I like the
jump tongue though
not quite enough chip will do it though
yeah wrecking ball so hard to Escape
right there it's such a hard thing to
deal with that's kind of why you see
players block it because if you don't
challenge it with the right thing at the
right spacing with the right strength
it's just gonna go wrong for you you're
getting opened up yeah it has armor on
it too so he just flies in and you're
just like well Shadow wrecking ball
other side tongue action caught him
and he has huge Corner carry on those
combos right he gets to use the Ender
with the uh the wrecking ball in there
and it takes you so far for the wall
Supply
oh
no wake up Instinct here from Mickey he
might lose this life bar
oh oh we got stuffed then you got
Rollins things instead yeah and he just
flies out on the bike yeah that worked
out pretty pretty well for Rico oh oh
Shadow boot wrecking ball plus the car
he gets the link off this will Rico try
to break here is the big question oh he
did
a recap on the car too huge damage one
for the throw reset and Rico's out of
there but he lost so much life
yeah that sequence definitely worked out
in Nikki's favor so hard you have to
guess all the different strengths when
the bike is in play
oh big and that was an immediate you had
to break so fast on that heavy kick
otherwise it was Ultra right away and
the hip thrust again from Nikki
yeah his top button is definitely
working today I think he's taunted in
both of the sets that he's playing the
crowd is loving it a rash taunt is like
very special too like who doesn't love
the rash pelvic thrust ones
he's the only character with two tones
yeah he needs it he does need it they're
both two different dance sequences yeah
so we see him switch over to the gargos
we were talking about this earlier right
this is another character he's very
comfortable with I personally don't like
this matchup because it's so scary if
gargos gets knocked down this is another
character with a lot of really
unconventional reversal options yeah
he's Gotta Throw immune command grab he
has a decent back dash he's got an
extremely punishable reversal that's
like really easy to save meaty so it's
gonna be a big question of Ken Rico just
stay off of the ground and stay out of
some really scary spacings and Nikki's
clipping him immediately Rico breaks off
the bat
yeah and that's why he can fly they gave
him wings for that very reason he
actually needs it
oh bait's a throw there doesn't get the
link with the horns but still not a
great spot for Rico in the corner
although he finds a way out
using the crusher there I mean it's
really nice to get some space like that
while closed low that was so far away on
that crushing medium kick
big lockout on the heavy Auto this might
be the life bar actually yeah he snuck
another heavy Auto in there and Rico's
gonna die with his first instinct and
the thrust
oh my God so high and he gets the juggle
off of it
should be an answer here from Rico oh I
love that that's the most gangster
antier of all times he's grabbing
somebody raw minion summon right there
but he's gonna use the shedding of the
stone skin there to make it safely yeah
minions still moving around the big man
so a little cautious there from Nikki
while Dodge is the command grab Shadow
right through and it hits the minion
it's got one Health left
in the neutral Dawning in the neutral
not a time like this in the nude and the
neutral unbelievable and that minion is
gone now Rico's gonna try to get
something started here in the corner
he's not going to be able to get a
minion call off of that safely actually
because it's not a Hard Knock though
yeah you didn't used to be oh yeah those
were the days
Instinct again
went for the heavy kick
all right that's gonna be a chance for
Rico here to set up a little bit portal
punch both minions out now it's a party
for sure and this is so hard to deal
with
big break and the little guy's dead the
big guy just gets swatted and killed too
God and that's gonna do it here right in
the ultra 3-0 Nikki looking like he
never left
Victory lap here
not going for the second Ultra
damn that hot pink controller though
yeah I'm digging it he's got the
kennergy
yeah so what happened was you summoned
the minions now I did a wrecking ball
because I just didn't care about either
of them yeah and when you know when I
was thrusting my hips that's a taunt
that's how that works so it's our winter
side match there of course Nikki moving
on looking great we're gonna have Rico
versus base a match we've seen many many
times in our lives throughout this game
of course that'll be our losers side
match here you can see a rerun of this
which we saw earlier of course and then
after that winner gets a chance at Nikki
and we're gonna see how everything plays
out in terms of the order of who's who's
winning the exhibition what place
everybody's gonna get and all that stuff
yeah which is cool I mean it's nice to
see the exhibition up there everybody
back gaming again whether it's been a
while or they've been gaming the whole
time in Nikki's case right so it's cool
to see up there yeah I'm actually liking
how Rico is playing right now overall
like I really like the way that his Omen
was yeah really strong the gargos wasn't
bad at all either it's just rashes just
so oppressive and I mean like you try to
take like one flight and you get hit
clipped by a tongue that's it it's
pretty wild the thing too that he won
Evo for this game
a decade ago
like it's been a long time since then
you know so cool to see him back and
play in the same game that we were all
uh fans of then and fans of now
yeah and I think like the big question
like we were talking about before is
when you play so many characters and
then you stop playing the game and you
come back the big question is like what
characters am I Really Gonna focus on
here like what characters are gonna pull
from Rico is really good with gargos
he's really really good with Tusk he had
a really strong fogore I mean like he
played like half the cast yeah he played
a lot and character Shadow Jago and bass
is kind of the same way I mean these
guys have played thousands of times
casuals you know they've done
tournaments oh yeah
see here getting their buttons all set
up ready to go here
it's gonna be loses finals action of our
exhibition you see the characters Omen
versus what character for bass he tried
spinal he tried Cinder obviously Cinder
was the character that he switched to
after he lost so let's see
era interesting choice okay both of
these characters have a really similar
move kind of like the mist and the
shadow form yeah they're kind of a move
where they just their hair box kind of
disappears and they just teleport into
another place okay we're going with
gargos here interesting and bass is cool
with it he's like all right I'll play
miragos you thought about we didn't have
to have a blind Pixar or anything he's
like I'll let that rock ooh the best
stage in the game best theme in the game
Thunder theme this is my actual favorite
theme in this game for sure
and this is one of the most commonly
played uh tournament stages
but it's a different theme it's getting
Orchid theme on this one yeah which is
great by the way so this is another one
for Rico this is just gonna be like a
game of traversal Mira has like really
really impressive Oaky and it's gonna be
just a matter of wanting to stay out of
those spacings
yeah bats out early too great projectile
stuff to deal with yeah bats have such a
scary presence on the screen but the
thing is that portal punch is instant
and it tracks and if Mira gets hit the
bats go away so it's kind of like a
pretty good trade-off in this matchup
both of them kind of air superiority
kind of characters
nice antsy over there from Rico yeah
that is not easy to do she is tough to
keep out of the air but just a heavy
kick there oh
breaker on the lights and a command grab
right away
another one after a little headbutt
really trying to summon again
I like that he kind of backed off he's a
little bit more cautious about that
summon in that situation
I like that debate the throw that was a
smart little Choice especially with the
minion out whip on the sweet crotchy
medium into the psycho Crusher and break
it right away
yeah and then minion only takes three
hits before it's gone Rico's spending
the bar to answer here with that shadow
portal punch there
oh using the triple jump get out of the
way the bats they just hit right at the
end
oh
scary time now wall Splat Ender
pretty good damage on that actually
because the Instinct missed oh this
might be a scariest thing pop here for
Rico oh my God yeah
and the burst gets out of there
immediately close first light bar here
yeah it was a really good use of the
Instinct there I mean he got the he got
the minion on the screen and that's
really what matters here this is what
makes gargo's shine as a character
overall
then right into the shadow a little bit
of Chip will do it man his antiers have
been so clean and the command grab the
hop on the ground
it's a summon afterwards too so good
little spot for Rico even though yeah he
might go down here the minion gets hit
loses one little bit of uh life but it's
got two more hits left so Rico pretty
good spot I think all things considered
and I love on this stage in the second
how far it just starts pouring yeah
it's downpouring
oh minion dead just like that and the
lockout Shadow available this could be
huge look at the damage on this
oh missed it yeah usually you can punish
that oh chance he was trying to stand
light kick into the command grab I think
the verse
Abby is on the screen nice anti-air
stabby he's so skinny he didn't get hit
by the shadow there so pretty lucky for
Rico oh command grab again man he's
landed so many of those yeah his
placement of those in the situations
that he's Landing them is really really
smart
other minions out stabied not hit
against he's still alive he's got one
more HP oh he hit from behind now the
minions are out there that's a sandwich
oh this is really good defense despite
everything on the screen here from base
another anti-air there and the link
right into the ultra dude stabby was MVP
he was the antsy aired he hit her on the
ground he has like better fundamentals
than a lot of players he does he ends
here is way more consistently his
antiers are good his footsies are good
you really can't jump on him I think
stabby could make it out of pulls it
even he probably could I'm pretty sure
he could get a Chipotle card maybe not
the bag yeah
but that's for sure so game one Rico
even though it was kind of a bit of a
scramble there
Rico relying on that standing heavy kick
that actually that pillar that goes to
the top of the screen is just gargo's a
standing heavy kick it's like a really
cool anterior upper body Invincible but
Mira has a lot of these deep jump ins
this is going to be a huge lockout and
huge damage too so far in this round
grab jumps it heavy Camp block
and a media versus does not want to see
any more of that
is going to get some of that gray Health
back Rico's in big trouble here wake up
buttons didn't work out there yeah chip
will do it so you got to be pretty
careful that's gonna Whip and a punish
no didn't get oh it's good furnace on it
just the width there I got the portal
punch so huge lead now for bass
oh and that's it command grabs have been
Landing every time Rico's gonna try to
get a summon here I don't know if base
can get a punish on gargos but he's
definitely gonna get a hit on that
minion there
Wow and his Ender got him out of the way
the minion's trying to hit him there
another command grab ah you don't get
damage out of it but you get your life
back and you get Space karaoke
I tried to grab there but that was throw
invincible
oh that's a big breaker right there and
that's also big if he counter breaks I
mean Rico might be dead it's pretty
close yeah there's such a crazy mind
game involved with that Linker there
from Mira because it's really it is
through our die she has one of the most
high damage characters in this game so
you better think twice before you break
that
and these hop command grabs have been so
huge so far both minions out really good
spot for Rico now God I'm trying to hit
stabby he did it stabby but no got
punished for it wow tried to break I
like that attempt there because Rico
could have gotten a safe counter Breaker
by shedding the stone skin but he ran
out just at the last second there
yeah unfortunately Snappy dies there too
and yeah so does the big fella
to the low side other side and a little
smidge of life left for Rico here block
correctly
oh Instinct pop and yeah I don't know if
you have the ability to miss out there
he didn't have much life left he'd use
so much
yeah with base having this amount of bar
this is actually chip territory for base
but he's not gonna need it he's not
gonna need it yeah it could have been
the shadow pillar gets the chip or get
whatever he wants to do so pretty good
spot bass goes up 2-0 and I think the
character switch is all he really needed
to find some comfort here
yeah we've seen a lot of character
variety only between four players on
this stage so much character variety
yeah we've seen like six or seven
characters at the least or something
ridiculous like that in four players
repertoire which is really cool
yeah we're gonna see the omen here I
think this is what we were originally
about to see where Rico opted to go with
gargos here
like I said before these characters are
really similar they both kind of have
like a missed like Shadow form that kind
of thing they have like the Fireballs
having an obnoxious presence on the
screen they have the swooping
projectiles right a lot of air
superiority stuff going on
so
bats out
especially before you have metered a
shadow counter miro's pressure is very
annoying oh yeah it's very Plus on block
um you get a lot of Mind Games off of it
chaining into itself you get the command
grab off of it
yeah it wasn't too long of a combo I
think you just wanted to take you know
destroy a little one build a little bit
of bar
get the next interaction while slide
caught the jump
yeah basically he's trying to jump out
of this pressure a couple of times Rico
trying to keep it tight I like that that
command grabs really fast yeah that was
a really really smart command grab it is
throwing Moon and it got him out of that
shadow where to set up
medium that time Rico thought it was the
heavy I think
damage under really good damage actually
oh Pizza throw beats it again and the
heavy gets broken
oh lets him drop interesting in the
middle I want a mix up there from base
Rico not able to use his Instinct this
time around
yeah she has one of the gnarliest
cross-up buttons I can think of in a
game and or air Dash is really fast
a big bait this is huge then oh it could
have been huge damage
he is going to get a setup off of that
in the corner mirror's only about like
plus four or so off of that
no answer from Rico even with the
Instinct pop that's just how deep that
jumping hit yeah shadows out again
doesn't want to deal with the pressure
there's a lot of gray life up there for
bass which you know you use for all your
moves with Mira your mediums and your
wow that command grab ants here is huge
the bite and another one
it's gonna be wall Splat just takes the
front throw get a set up here with the
bats yeah when your opponent is locked
out you never have to worry about them
attacking the throw and Rico has been
going for a lot of attempt to throw
Techs in this set
shout us out gets the throw base is a
huge lead here to try to eliminate Rico
send him home with third Shadow drill
there's no meter to Shadow counter for
Rico so he's kind of stuck
oh what a break and does base pop the
instinct is the question here it might
wait for the next lifeguard no he pops
Shadow right through could it be the
ultra it should be
man nicely done there from base
very smart awareness there it's really
kind of scary to go for okion characters
in this game when they have Instinct
because like we were saying before you
just get the freeze frame you get to
pick the correct option based off of
what you saw and if anything you're just
getting the person to not do anything so
that you don't have to deal with the
baiting you know what I mean like you
don't have to deal with the freeze at
all exactly
but uh so that two one I'm curious if
it's gonna be a character swap the app
looks like it
who else on the list right can we see
something new something we haven't seen
so far
Shadow Drago is definitely a possibility
this is the character that Rico actually
won the World Cup with yeah
he's thinking about it
bolgore
[Applause]
hovering a couple of characters here the
locks in on the full Gore very
interesting okay this is the character
you want Evo with yeah yeah man those
are wild Services yeah
great
yeah the problem with fogart at the
start of the match he's gonna be the I
don't know okay
something going on here there it looks
like they're fixing it
yeah I don't know if they wanted to run
back a different character decision
there or yeah I'm not sure there's like
some kind of control scheme change some
people change their controls based on
what character they're playing actually
oh that's true
think about it
and it's wild to see the Evo stage again
I feel like I was literally here last
week
man look at that crowd what's up
everybody out there hopefully you're
enjoying all of our Ki action and
everything else here at Evo this year
it's a pleasure to see you all out there
hopefully you're vibing chaos stage main
stage at Evo even all kinds of Legends
up here yeah at first was the tournament
10 years ago at Evo which is pretty wild
to think about it's insane it makes me
feel incredibly old I can't believe it's
actually the 10-year anniversary we were
saying it um at combo breaker and it was
I still can't believe it yeah 20 2013
this game was out is that Evo guys
remember I was here for a couple of
years and then after that it's been an
exhibitions combo breaker other events
all over the place so they're figuring
out some stuff on the stage here but
hopefully everybody's been enjoying all
the matches so far
gonna lock this on and then see who's
gonna make it into our grand finals up
against Nikki who's five and in the
crowd he looks like he's having the time
of his life yeah I mean he was doing the
taunt he was just chilling out man he
was screaming on the stages getting
everybody hyped up yeah which is always
a good time I mean everybody here is you
know is here to have a good time like
imagine if you're a Ki player and
they're like hey you want to play in a
Ki Exhibition at Evo you're like dude of
course like why not right yeah I saw
Alex v walking around speaking of hyping
up the crowd he was going crazy at combo
breaker the last time we saw him yeah
which is awesome he was just going nuts
yeah the other thing I was going to
mention about ki2 is it was one of those
games that was one of the first ones
that I ever remember having rollback
and look at that sea of Gamers out there
for Evo that's the community stage you
can see straight back which is all the
way over there on the other side of the
ballroom this is all of the tournament
setups everybody playing walking around
here on the show floor at Evo these
people don't even know we're watching
them right now oh these people do what
up it's insane dude it is one of I mean
this is actually the biggest fighting
game tournament in the history of the
world numbers wise there was 11
000 people coming in and out of this
building today and the street fighter
brackets the biggest one seven thousand
which is the biggest that was him right
there yeah he's a party animal he's
always having a good time
what up everybody down there
it was close
I believe you
I believe you he didn't get the Chipotle
card
that's tragic to see it not the not the
Miss on the Chipotle card
gotta get the burrito bowl man that's
how it works
or you could be a burrito gamer or
whatever else you got I'm a bowl enjoyer
though I don't think the card judges I
think you could get whatever you want
with it that's true yeah if you get the
card and it says in parentheses you must
get a burrito you're like oh oh my God
yeah yeah you made it on losers you
don't get to choose yeah we give you a
random meal you don't even know what it
is you're like what it's like a Carnitas
Bowl you can't yeah and you're like I
don't want Carnitas I want the El Pastor
chick yeah
that'd be really funny if you made it
out on losers they gave you a card with
a random order like you have no choice
yeah
it's like already up on the stage though
maybe
I don't know I thought I thought I saw
it Maybe not maybe I'm misunderstanding
they're figuring some stuff out in the
meantime hopefully you've been enjoying
all the action all day today has been on
the main stage as they did last year all
kinds of cool programming interviews uh
panels with all the developers I saw
Street Fighter was showing off costumes
and stuff I saw Tekken was talking about
their data and everything there was uh
arcs and stuff earlier today all these
developers have been up here all day
long showing stuff off which is really
cool we got the uni 2 announcement today
which is really tight for those uni fans
out there which myself included yeah
that was insane I was not expecting that
at all I think there's a Nickelodeon
All-Star brawl two I think yeah they are
doing something here yeah the developers
think I read that um
there's a Nodge for King of Fighters
yeah that's true there is Project L yeah
and Mary school girls MK1 Tekken eight
yeah I think for this build of MK1 I
think Lee May is in it and I also think
that they added the dash blocking I
heard about that I heard the movement
sticker I saw that that's like the first
thing that those players are gonna pick
up on especially the ones that are gonna
go to Evo they're gonna check things out
I saw like all the tweets oh yeah I I
don't know if I'm gonna have time to go
play it I know I I'm gonna be I'm
usually behind the curtains working so
I'll have to see if I get the chance
otherwise I'll just check out the
gameplay
what up everybody there's the crowd
howdy howdy howdy that guy was hype I
love that he's screaming his head off
look at all the gamers what up what up
what up hey I recognize those gamers
looks like we're good to go here locking
in pick Thunder stage Big Thunder theme
let's go I don't know what I love this
Terror skin for full War that's a good
one this color scheme is so cool
by the intros Rock I think this is where
are we at on the score here is this
losers final losers finals I think was
Rico on the board with two
uh two on base I need the refresher
there we go everyone we're back at it
here Rico going for Okie here teleport
in the front safe little pressure and
check from base there yeah punish
nothing too big for Rico though just the
jab
cars like blade Dash wow reversal bad I
like that
oh nice throw bait there from Rico and
he's uh using the fact that bass was not
going for a shadow kind of there at all
nice missed out not trying to be in that
corner
we jump in and gets the regular throw
again this is one thing that's kind of
like the Hallmark of Rico's full Gore I
think
wow okay I'm not sure what bass tried to
do there but that was a super strong
round
like his football has lots of resets
right I think that's one of the things
that he does more than anybody just like
wants to throw resets never does long
Combos and this gets on makes that back
to the front there's a lot of damage
potentially
oh yeah this is so much damage and Rico
is sitting on a lot of meter here as
well as his Instinct he's gonna get
antier here I think that the reason that
he didn't do that is because he was
worried about the Miss exactly yeah
didn't want to risk it why and here gets
stuck chance now for Rico set up in the
front regular throw
all right
we'll tried it again we'll find base
attacks and uh
lose the position for Rico oh my God
those for the medium gets the life back
on the Ender here and the reactor for
Rico is completely slowed down but he is
sitting at a full bar and you see
forwards mirror segmented into Pips it
means that he can cancel his specials
into his specials which makes him one of
the deadliest zoning and mix up
characters in this game oh yeah his
Mix-Ups are better zoning is better back
dash get out of the range of the throw
oh no tried to Shadow counter
Miss picks up back to the front oh my
God this is gonna hurt potential damage
on this is huge
so it's like that 50 on that hip hop
again
oh air to air puts him in danger baits
to throw regular throw again not enough
a chip
oh my God he got that command Rod Rico
this time that meaty Fireball there
shadow on the other side
to avoid it yeah it's it's a teleporting
tracking Shadow terrifying 2-2 we're at
a game five here for these two and we'll
see character swap or no it's possible
I'll have to see
a cycle back repair to select here at
least think about it for a little bit
does he go with spinal Cinder or
something else or
back to the Mary does go with spinal
very interesting okay oh yeah this is a
matchup that bases God I have a ton of
experience with dealing with Rico before
dealing with Nikki a ton of times this
is a matchup that I think that forward
can deal with quite well but I think
that where it's really difficult for
Fogo to deal with is the start of the
match because it's kind of hard for him
to get into a comfortable space and
without spinal running at him like yeah
exactly that round starts jab check
skull go for a little pressure after
this is I think classically one of the
matchups for players find very annoying
right like
definitely be an annoying one for the
character doesn't have the best way to
deal with some especially when his
resources get locked out
pressure base ready for the uh throw
there oh my God such an early lock out
there he's gonna get to get some skulls
from this level four skullander he's
fully loaded here
and cancel off the skull with on the
overhead get some punished it's gonna be
huge he's got the shadow here it doesn't
even need a damage Ender doesn't even go
for the damage doesn't even need that
end or big lead here for base yeah and
he is gonna put a curse on Rico's meter
which is gonna make it tough for him to
build he just you see that reactor
spinning he's going to be able to build
up all kinds of Pips here oh yeah check
out the dash from base it's really good
there too cars up late Dash catches him
with the fireball into the laser again
and this is really close
yet
oh and the regular throw bad news for
Rico Instinct pop for base
oh that's gonna be plus because we
charge that up yeah this is terrifying
these skulls are going to be bouncing
all over the screen here
Rico's face recycling here that's what
we do gotta keep it green oh he's two
plus the skulls oh my God what a combo
there base is so good at confirming
those manuals off of that I don't think
this is gonna kill this actually is
death right here that'll do it 56 on
that combo base with a huge pickup and
gets his run back against Rico who's
gonna go out here with third place our
Evo champions
both of them out there you have it so
I'm gonna have our finals base versus
Nikki
should be a good one I think yeah this
is a very typical one and again this is
just a question of what are the
character choices going to be here base
as Eagle you know he's got a Shadow Jago
he's got a Jago of his own he's got the
spinal
Nikki with the entire cast as well yeah
both of them play so many different
characters and so that is truly the
question right like what character are
you gonna select here you know who are
you most comfortable with we'll have to
see
these two this is like a match I've seen
so many times in this game this is a
classic yeah
it's like the past the present and
probably the future it is yeah no this
is definitely I would like to see full
Gore and spinal selfishly of course
yeah the classic match I don't think
we'll see full Gore into the spinal
though that's the thing yeah
unless he's forced off of it on a
counter pick or something but
ripped or
wondering if this is what Nikki is going
to go for here I mean this does this is
a pretty good counter I think to a lot
of bassist characters and this is a
character that I think that Nikki I'm
gonna be honest here I think that Nikki
is like the best Ripper I've ever played
yeah I think that his rifters
specifically he really understands how
to keep it simple with the frame Trap
game he doesn't you know ripped her
she's got a lot of crazy stuff but I
think the best thing for a Ripta player
to do is to just play the strike throw
game and then move from there you could
kind of start mixing into things later
and that's what he does so perfectly
this is such a frustrating matchup for
spinal for that reason because he
doesn't have that conventional reversal
so the pressure from rifter because that
jumping heavy punch so hard to hit here
yeah wow Kilgore Kilgore rip Thor is our
star of the grand finals very
interesting yeah that's definitely not
what I was expecting to see but bass
does have a really good Kilgore it's not
something that you commonly see in
tournament but he has one very very good
space control with this character yeah
here we go Grand finals of our
exhibition here at Evo 20 23. thanks
everybody for making some noise out in
the crowd hopefully everybody at home
has been enjoying all the action so far
we have a robot with uh machine gun arms
versus a dinosaur as our match it's also
worth noting that Kilgore runs on
gasoline yeah love is one of my favorite
facts about him yeah they could have
made like another another robot that's
like you know hybrid yeah a little bit
of both right
more friendly for the environment
missile's not going to hit there a
little Fireball On the Border but
nothing too big and so far Nikki not
been able to establish a bunch of
neutral which is you know ripped are a
little bit weird in the neutral a lot of
times
yeah base is just gonna try to cut the
nonsense on the road but Nikki is not
having he just runs up in headphones
anyway nice bait on the reversal there
and that is so much damage that is a 17
opener there from riptor
one thing I like is we already saw the
Predator stance pressure early on most
of the throw
it's gonna be big actually yeah it's
gonna hurt
see how much damage we can Chuck out on
this thing both Shadows tons of damage
on that and he's gonna get so much
distance off of that as well he's heated
up in his Instinct but he's gonna still
get the same distance he's retaining all
the distance of his normal uh character
archetype oh I caught the jump there
yeah
she's got wide hips got clipped by the
uh projectile there oh ants here on the
shadow no it doesn't reach oh but no
punish
starting to put his pressure on base not
having it with that reversal Nikki
breaks the combo and gets a mortar set
up off of that as well oh he's gonna
jump to you and then that's gonna be the
wall Splat end of the throw very nicely
done there from Nikki wow that's once
again taunts have not stopped and then
neutral jump heavy kick try to check
goes for The Stance light kicks try to
get the plus frames but face is out of
there
I love that little side switch there no
punish on the reversal there's just too
far away oh needs to throw this time off
the plus frames knock down border action
and the teleport away just gets him out
of the setup
he's gonna go for a missile knockdown
set up here nice antier but I think
that's gonna trade he almost got a combo
off of that yeah that recapture had so
much plus frames actually even after
getting hit jump heavy kick
to go so good damage on this missiles
are out cross up on the other side that
was filthy with that cross-up metal ball
oh my God that could have been it this
is it that's it right there huge damage
all on that startup cross-up right there
that's the ultra Rock You Gotta think
about it
[Music]
this is the second kill board Grand
finals I love the salute the salute at
the end the time the second kilburg
Grand finals that we've seen in recent
memory that's true back at CB yeah
dude I thought that was a rip door right
it was killboy
character selected is so Nikki now has a
chance it's not okay I goes you know
somebody wins then we see what they're
just like there's no way I like it
though because TJ does have an
invincible role the roll is Invincible
to projectiles and Nikki has been
working on this character lately I like
that he's willing to pick him in this
situation why not you see the flex out
there dude I love this uh TG outfit by
the way yeah that's fine this one's
great
you got what it takes to yeah this is
the old one nobody ever uses it with the
eye patch and the ripped up shirts so
fire
let's get a little outfit dancing around
star let's look for the back fist yeah
trying to see if base is willing to
swing there all right let's look at the
corner carry on this too the Power Line
enter for the wall slab
flash jump heavy kick and man this
pressure is tough to deal with yeah that
reversal there from Kilgore is almost
like a little spot Dodge and bass did
that because that Target combo Juke that
Nikki is doing is pulse on block and
Nikki face that immediately putting base
in this really really scary Corner
situation and if it's one thing that TJ
is not lacking it is damaged yeah he
hits hard damn it that's all right after
two
on that too
bro missiles throw again
we're gonna see a reversal from Nikki I
like the roll bait there from base oh
punished though and break on the heavy
knee ready for it raw power line
for our power line is one of the
scariest and crystals in this game it's
definitely terrifying yeah armored
advancing dashboard so a heavy bunch of
roll pick up there I like it
foreign
this was like probably the one character
pick from any player on the stage that I
was really not expecting to see and it's
working out for Nikki right back to
character select he's like all right all
right spinal dude spinal it is bad
matchup for TJ that's a tough one
did you see the rotation back and forth
back and forth but bases up a game which
is the big one right so he owns this one
I can go 2-1 then Nikki can counter pick
Etc back and forth back and forth oh
yeah counter picking always favors the
one in the lead
take care
all right so final it is locked and
loaded
and we got the theme and everything this
stage is so sick I would love to see a
stage with the Wrecking Ball yeah the
wrecking ball in the background
I'll throw early and pressure now for
Nikki
you gotta stick to him here right this
is the goal right oh yeah
no cancel right there that's a big drop
and the breaker early from Nikki rolls
in tries to find it but base ready with
the down jab check
that jumping heavy punch is so
impressive when it comes to TJ his
aunties are so awkward
turn around punch two and the counter
break that's huge
and he's just gonna go for the uh damage
under there oh he drops it as he gets
around the world unfortunately you get
everything oh
it's the cash out after anyway that
shadow oh oh anti-air sword yep
the shadow counter teleport out I'll let
the skull hit him too
all this pressure in the corner is so
hard to deal with I don't know if he's
gonna try to roll here
I like the combination of him just
throwing the power line punching spinal
in the chest than him just dismantling
right there on the stage yeah yeah rolls
up other side again lightning this time
and our Breakers ready okay those are
tough to see the TJ combinations
rather
there it is it's huge damage on that 40
percent
oh and the command doesn't get a
follow-up after though but really good
spot here for Nikki activates overhead
and that's gonna be ultra 2-1 on the
counter pick still Nikki the goat TJ and
the dancer
oh my God tournament Point here for
Nikki with TJ combo
what is going on we're running it back
immediately here
putting the pressure on here in the
corner getting the curse on early making
it hard for Nikki to build meter here
back this oh punish on the throw whip
again
and the knee no break it's gonna be good
damage once again usually
you looking low face trying to find some
offense yeah those pains Every Time
tough to deal with finds the shadow
counter this time very very smart good
option to confess that pressure there
I won't let it rip he's gonna absorb the
whole thing gets the skull gets the
punish that was such a big call out
there
just go for the power devour on wake up
like that
to already saw the jab out but he
doesn't do anything about it so Nikki
the first light bar again still hasn't
popped instinct
he's gonna get a free roll through that
and a punished throw
nothing after though oh and he loves the
shadow real quick stop a little too far
I think no role there crouching medium
it's a great catch so far away
oh it's so fast overhead links after a
little drop but
that'll probably do it not much you can
do there it's a pretty bad spot for TJ
so I'm gonna build up some resources
bass has curses right now on Instinct
and meter right now this is going to be
really tough for Mickey to get anything
going unless he gets these curses off of
him teleport nice block from Nikki
anyone for the command grab actually I
kind of like that check but face was
ready for it full pressure runs yeah the
Run pressure off the heavy punch too
that's the shadow rip and that's a
punish
fake damage here base keeping the corner
he's gonna go for an upskull oh my God
that's so hard to deal with
to be close then he gets the breaker one
last chance here for Nikki
[Music]
oh my God that was a scramble but it
worked out for base now the big question
here is on the tournament point
does Nikki stay with TJ we're probably
gonna see a character swap yeah
character swap now he gets his choice of
counter pick against final
saberwolf interesting choice I think
he's got a really good wolf as well I
think there's been a lot of debate over
the game's life on who wins this matchup
but I think most people think that this
is actually a hard matchup for spinal
the crouching light kickman plus unblock
no recovery blows up the teleport it can
be tough when wolf gets started yeah I
think historically that's kind of been
the way for like one of the things
that's really hard for spinal to deal
with especially when he was when he was
weaker wolf was so much stronger you
know and then the game
look at this blending into the stage
background the color tools yeah that was
like the smug Classics used to play that
blue Dudley on the National Rail Yard
stage he's a cheater
just take the damage under and yeah
crouching lion king biting the ankles
goes low with the crouching medium bad
spot no bait or uh Noah throw but it
doesn't fall for the base no answer
what a bait on that uh Shadow Eclipse
there is he gonna go for the side switch
here yeah I like that keeping the corner
here lots of pressure go back to ABS
that was such a perfect backlash there
from Nikki
the front slide and then immediate
breaker neutral jump threatening that
teleport
big now medium break again Nikki ready
for the doubles
a heavy kick manual too
oh nice try to get over the dive kick
but it doesn't work out I like it oh and
that skull is going to cover him there
no feral cancel there yeah this should
be it here cleans up it's the Ender a
little scary a little bit of instinct
lets out the how
God I love this character you gotta let
him know
Instinct out for Nikki about to have
some Shadow yeah I love the harassment
with the back heavy punch so Plus on
block not easy to Shadow counter
and no break right there a little little
Miss time so a good opportunity here for
bass to build some resources reset here
but Nikki has wolf Dash we can get out
of the corner yeah just like that yeah
in between round is so huge and chaos
especially because I just get the move I
had it again and gotta say a lot of
these Shadows have been called out from
base so far wow the Double Dash through
gets the throw overhead this time
crouching a heavy kick with a manual on
the wall Dash through other side Shadow
this is a lot of damage already it's a
little drop though and a chance for base
this is huge
fight under punish the skull's gonna hit
him oh
by the Run lock out that's huge because
of the Shadow here
and a breaker oh and he is one confirm
away from closing this out but so is
base oh my God does he miss it and that
should be the ultra there you have it
Nikki are Killer Instinct Evo 2023
exhibition champion
oh the pop-off too let's go I don't know
what he's saying I don't either saying
damn I'm nice this game is sick let's go
top one I think that's what he said
yeah wolf top one you saw it GG is well
played there from Nikki stayed in
winterside the whole time
and played that super super well fun
little exhibition here we appreciate
everybody coming out and I'll be
checking it out in person but of course
everybody watching at home very nice of
you as well it's really nice Vevo to
have Ki here on stage right the main
stage on Friday yeah that was awesome
I'm glad that we got the show this game
out in some shapewear form yeah you know
and the other cool thing is like
everybody loves Ki people are still
supporting it into this year of course
it is the year 2023 10 years after the
games come out people are still fans
still playing in tournaments still
playing it online still playing the game
all the time yeah this game has such a
presence there's a DMC 3v3 there's the
Revival Nikki has tournaments he's got
Monday Night Mix he's got Friday night
set play these guys are still playing
this game out here this game has great
net code it's got a great roll back yep
and since the beginning which is a nice
thing right which is cool so glad to see
everybody up here that's going to be it
from me and you I believe we're gonna be
throwing to Rick who's on the stage the
GM of Evo let's hear from him
hey everybody
mike check
so for those of you that I saw just get
up if you are a Killer Instinct fan like
myself who has been celebrating and
playing this game for the last decade I
would advise you to stick around and
turn your eyes to the screen
because I have one more thing for you
oh what's up dudes Max here
we're expecting to see here but I wanted
to give a huge shout out to the
community I wish I could be there but
seeing Killer Instinct come back to Evo
after so many years the game has been on
Hiatus is absolutely awesome to see the
game supported in so many ways all these
years is truly incredible but there is
something else and I would like to
introduce James Goddard who is the head
of Killer Instinct over at Microsoft hey
thanks Max can you believe it's been
special Showcase in Evo showing Ki for
the first time
with the developers from Delta Helix I
think you were out there and wow it was
incredible the energy was so great all
the combos all the combo breakers people
going is some of those common Breakers
we did with counter Breakers
the whole time we would listen to our
players and it's time again where this
Ki which we've been having so much fun
with it's time to evolve them one more
time evolve so does that mean that the
the Killer Instinct that we are still
currently playing is gonna get something
new of some kind yeah we are going to
start with updating all the matchmaking
and other services to Modern playfab we
actually picked that off back in May
we'll migrated everyone started
migrating everybody's accounts but we
are also going to take advantage of the
Xbox series X and S and optimize ki4
with a 4K patch and more
more so we're 10 years into Killer
Instinct now and obviously it's been
five years since there's been any
substantial updates to Killer Instinct
in any way are you saying we're actually
getting that update well I'm very
excited to say that we have some friends
back also working on the game and I'd
like to reintroduce you to Adam Hart
from Iron Galaxy our league
hi everybody we're back we're doing more
Killer Instinct uh it's pretty amazing
that after 10 years the number of people
playing this game online every week is
still incredibly high and there are
online tournaments and offline
tournaments constantly throughout the
year the level of play keeps getting
higher and higher and higher it's pretty
astounding and I'm pretty amazed that uh
we're back so uh James how are you
feeling about it I am so excited about
this and we are officially doing
um balance patch not not just a balance
patch like balance update
coming in the fall
it's been five years since our last
balance update which is kind of amazing
and unprecedented to be able to revisit
a game that has kind of had the dust
settle for this long
um I think players have really pushed
the upper limits of everything that's
possible with the game and uh maybe it's
time to ask some of those top Minds who
are still playing the game what they
think needs to change to keep the game
healthy and keep it interesting and
refresh it a bit and on a personal note
you know our final character eagle
he only got a couple of game updates
because we only had a few left after he
came out so this is a very exciting
thing that we're going to be doing for
you guys a new balance batch for KI and
we did promise that if enough players
entered Kia combo breaker we'd find a
time machine and Nerf rash so uh we
found the time issue wow yeah I I feel
like I'm in a time machine right now
because Killer Instinct is the game that
just keeps on going and so many people
are still continually playing it like
you guys said and now there's going to
be an even bigger reason to jump in and
check out Ki this balance patch I'm very
much looking forward to and I can't wait
to see what you guys come up with so
James Adam thank you all and to
everybody at Evo don't worry there's
more information coming soon and we'll
be back with more on what's going on
with Ki for this 10th anniversary update
not bad right
so
just so that we can prove that's not a
fever dream that I'm really excited to
be here for please welcome to the stage
the health of Killer Instinct over at
Xbox James Goddard
[Applause]
hey everybody
thank you so much and I am here I just
want to hop up real quick to say hey
it's been an amazing 10 years I want to
personally pass on the thanks from all
the development teams that have worked
on Ki from double helix to iron Galaxy
to of course my home and Xbox all of us
I mean it's unbelievable what I just saw
10 years later you know we shot to
launch Ki season one eight characters
you know we thought it was going to be
cool and amazing who would have thought
29 characters
10 years
four incredible players two Evo
Champions just insane gameplay I mean
you guys made this happen this is why we
did it and this is why we're doing a
balance update and a major major upgrade
to all playfab services here matchmaking
is a lot smoother tournaments are easier
and more Ki for the next 10 years let's
go
[Applause]
and for everyone else still here we're
going to jump to a quick commercial
break because we've got some bills to
pay but immediately after that Mortal
Kombat 11 top six
[Applause]
a Sizzle that's the soundtrack of
Chipotle the soundtrack of Chipotle oh
yeah you come in you're gonna be hearing
that Sizzle that's how you know we
always have fresh food
fresh is what you stand for that's
exactly
[Music]
oh no
super Rola
Victory feels good
of course
[Music]
thank you
the Capcom Pro Tour season is just
getting started and there are two more
offline events on the schedule the first
will be part of Gamescom Asia held in
Singapore this October the second will
be held in Paris in early November with
the finals being held as part of Paris
Games Week winners of both events will
qualify for Capcom cup 10 and a shot at
the grand prize of one million dollars
registration is limited so please check
start.gg for more information
foreign
[Music]
my voice
foreign
[Music]
ignite the fire of a brand new age when
I hear my voice
[Music]
you can't believe
Marvel
my voice on my soul keeps Rising as I
sing my songs
[Music]
I've arrived when it's the only option
studies
[Music]
number one contender
War I got Jaws on the floor and it's
been built like art on the wall if they
ain't in the know better keep them
informed Evolution's constant and this
ain't my final form
[Music]
back
brush it down
next I'll be strong prove myself
[Music]
Jersey
till I'm more than one
[Music]
Horizon in a dream
thank you
[Music]
foreign
when I hear my voice
[Music]
on a blue
dream I hope my hands keep shaking but
my heart keeps
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing my songs
[Music]
beautiful
too
must have been veered like art on the
wall if they ain't in the know better
keep them informed evolutions
[Music]
My Voice keeps on my soul keeps Rising
as I sing
[Music]
this
still feel
Corners down
[Music]
here we go
foreign
[Music]
thank you
believe you could be so much more made
for the moment in the era I forged live
from the minutes where the Legends are
born in the myths are forever when they
pen our Lord I hear every Echo inside of
the world
below the hopes inside of the same fear
[Music]
s
yourself worthy of living the impact as
soon as I push forward and tell them to
hold that roll back I don't see me
limited lacking the vision and ask him
why the hell are we friends cause I'm
basically different I'm everything they
say that the arcade era living my
foreign
[Music]
order just got extra the fighter coins
from Street Fighter 6. order any entree
in the Chipotle app using promo code
hdkn236 and receive 250 fighter coins
with yours visit chipotle.com sf6 for
details
Red Bull gives you wings
[Music]
oh no
super Lola
Victory feels good
thank you
PlayStation
[Music]
ways you can't believe
my soul keeps Rising as I sing my song I
can hold myself
when is the only
options
[Music]
all right all right listen we had a good
time today we saw a lot of panels we had
some amazing guests up here got some
information on some new and upcoming
games but
it is time to bring it back to what Evo
originally started at and that is a
tournament
[Applause]
with that said I need you guys to make
some loud noise for our first top six
event of Evo
2023 I need to hear it foreign
[Applause]
that's the energy I want this entire top
six but that's never going to start
bringing out our players let me get a
scorpion rocks to the stage get up here
keep the energy high right now for my
man a foxy Grandpa get up here foxy
[Music]
all right our next TOPS oh all right yo
yo feel it go ahead feel it man get it
all right our next top six competitor
please Nicholas get up here Nicholas
Make some noise
[Music]
all right now we got a vet coming up I
need a big one for Ninja killer
all right coming up now more noise more
noise for the mighty on just
and now to round out your Mortal Kombat
11 top six give it up four zombies yep
all right now that the stage has set
everyone in this thing and this floor
excuse me one more time for the top six
of Mortal Kombat 11 Evo 2023 give it up
give it up
all right we're gonna check right now
the intro video let's get this pumping
[Music]
oh
very good lady died
[Music]
my soul kill yourself
the justice
I am alive
[Music]
and welcome one and all to the top six
of Mortal Kombat 11 at 2023 here at Evo
I am Mr Aquaman joined by the one and
only catch up here and these players
these six the culmination of four years
of determination gaming and Mortal
Kombat have all come to this baby
the big story about this tournament is
that it is the absolute final Evo for
Mortal Kombat 11. yes it is not long now
until the next chapter in Mortal Kombat
is opened and this is the one and only
time to make that final Mark and there
are so many stories for this both of the
twins winners side foxy going up against
one of them ninja going up against the
other
it couldn't be more perfect if you ask
me looking at this top six there's
nothing but storylines you've got Old
Guard you've got new guard you've got oh
my goodness International Players you've
got any represented here everything you
can ask for is sitting before us all we
have to do is sit back and simply enjoy
from here on out because top to bottom
this is going to be classic after
Classic and we're going to be finding
out some answers that we were left with
from the previous Evo right coming into
this top eight uh last year no ninja
killer we saw what foxy and Rewind were
able to do up against these twins and
now a different story this time around
here in 2023. the big story about this
matchup is the character choice I hope
you like the Terminator
a possibility we might see that at some
point foxy just has a philosophy and
that philosophy is ignore tier lists
play the way that fits me best and use
characters that fit that Terminator
Sub-Zero
RoboCop as we can see a packed out crowd
of everyone I hope is enjoying their
time here the first day of Evo plenty
more games left to go and the ggs have
only just pick up thank you so much for
being here with us yes thank you
everyone players ready to go into match
number one as a reminder foxy writing
Terminator all the way to this top six
at the bottom of almost every player's
tier list what is going on here at Evo
23 what's in the water in those machines
over on the sidelines
look I'm gonna be just keeping a close
eye
I'd like to see some Terminator because
it fits the way foxy is currently been
looking at the game which is look at the
end of the day
the Terminator is going to mix you up
overheads lows command grabs the layers
upon layers they can exist but at the
end of the day I'm Point Blank you're
guessing one of those he puts it on his
opponent to Simply do one of two things
block rate or incorrectly and you got to
respect that in this day and age where
all these guys are doing work on so many
layers of metas and os's Foxy's overhead
low grab
but we have to talk about scorpion procs
the thing about the twins from Chile is
that you program a computer to play the
game the best it can be possibly played
you've basically got the twins their
execution is completely perfect their
movement is perfect their combo
optimization I mean if they can squeeze
out an extra percent they will do it and
it's just bizarre because these are some
of the younger players in our scene
that it took a while for them to start
playing and now they top three most
events
almost everyone here a couple of wins
from a repeat I mean both of them one
win away now for it scorpion procs a
foxy Grandpa match number one of this
top six Make some noise for both of them
out there it is time to get this show on
the road and it's time for the
Terminator I mean I can't believe I can
unironically say that in a fighting game
look there he is here he calms them at
himself and total card here we go I
better hear those command grabs out
there in the Crowd Oh yeah you're a
soccer player you're a total player it
makes sense I understand yes
this is just a simple yes yes I am going
to terminate you and we back forward too
and here comes scorpion prox a knock and
it's gonna be a lot of offense really
from both right here and Foxy both of
the challenge colaconda up close it's
not really something that you see him
pick it's more the keep away but he's on
the break
and there we go the pick-ups just begin
it's command grabs at the moment look at
him for the wake up one two tick throw I
mean look we're starting out Brave and
Bold and it's the tournament for it the
advancing this is the corner position
get out of my space you see a big game
played around the downforce base of
Terminators between everyone up alive
let's see how Scorpio that he can be
adjusted for later I hungry with a big
pickup and sit back down Big Boy the
sun's getting real low bro now look dude
look at that situation and you think why
is Foxy letting scorpion props out of
the corner Terminator does not need
various screen positions to get the
Mix-Ups on Deck that's the real big
thing about this matchups oh meaties and
that will be the round for sure we're
gonna facial blow and absolutely do
enough damage here and that first round
goes to scorpion prox I'm a big kid
coming up a hefty resource there needed
to take the rounds
I like how this has started though both
players are getting their game going not
one way whatsoever let's see if foxy can
establish some more mix here and you're
right really anywhere on the screen as
long as he gets a little bit of hip
Advantage making it down four it's big
city population you broke all right we
Dash in we go we go for the capitalist
version you know scorpion prompt is
going to be good enough but if there is
a Flawless block of the Gap
you're gonna need a lot of match-up
knowledge against that iron grenade in
particular you see I'm already abusing
the forward movement of course we'll get
through it so there's some of that
before look at those simple walking and
Scorpion across the boldness and the
sexy conversion to side swap sit back
down Big Sir
there it is folks he sees the delayed
wake up and that's gonna be free mix up
City it's not gonna be enough to take
the round but the next one might do wake
up up three short hop that's a cool out
one round a piece
A fitting way to start our first matchup
got a little bit about Foxy sometimes
was on the screen you don't know what's
going to happen
the case perfect duck in the pizza not
much gonna do at that space and a huge
column by scorpion once he got into the
range of big total there safe with the
disc and that gives you perfect pushback
against the normals of uh Terminator as
well
foxy dedicates to the low but doesn't go
for the combo version just really didn't
believe that was going to connect
there's the patience though wait for the
reappear and Colton can't forward one I
mean as far as fast enough to get the
job done nine times that attempt is down
Force come at that teleport as well
really
jump one and here comes the mix Fox is
not falling for a single one of them
gets a turnout those three one twos that
could have gone anyway yeah foxy can
tend to kind of just sit there and wait
for his turn the second Terminator he
gets a turn it's gonna be mixed up
lovely he's a command grab from scorpion
frogs though who hasn't really been
overwhelmed by this Terminator hit yet
but right down four not challenge
they're not check scorpion frogs oh
that's the game game one is just like
that
you see him just like a few others in
this tournament you know scouting
especially with your phone you saw the
people scouting the teleport and simply
just walking back and you see even
scorpion proxy implementing that really
well just let him teleport let him
understand wait it out he's doing a good
job for him here we'll see if foxy turns
up the heat a little bit try some
quicker teleports out wow
walked up with his Chestnut just crashed
and just shows so much confidence
through scorpion results there to just
Dash up like that and hit a raw come on
grab against someone like Terminator who
has fast mode and against foxy who
that's kind of pissing to do hold on a
second that's Confidence from the young
man
wake up up three Scout it out and I'm
gonna grab you again scorpion Brock says
you know we're gonna try and mix me up
all game long but I got Mix-Ups too and
uh that command grab is definitely one
of them hey we talked about taking away
certain no lessons in this game a mid
command crap will most certainly do that
maybe I guess where your life is
mispaced it barely but Terminators T-Rex
list they couldn't reach had the right
idea to base it out Interruption as well
in a rare drop of Scorpion box too
punishment
I hope he didn't manage to get it
earlier over there's the overhead now
she's gonna break away you can't do a
wake-up attack and that's gonna be
overhead low grab you name it
wow different staggers
fall for the disc
all right who gets the Breakaway out of
the foxy now a little bit vulnerable to
them on crap mix up so there goes
another one
one more good command grab or anything
substantial down one reached the Heavens
to take him out of their scorpion
process now on a match point to be in a
position just like last year to be in
winners finals right here's the question
foxy is he gonna change character and if
so which is it going to be we've seen
Sub-Zero we've seen RoboCop
will we see the day one cool now it's
gonna be RoboCop
a bit of a different in the matchup here
for those that don't know RoboCop has
some of the highest health in the game
which means that as a natural keep away
character even against someone like coal
you start the round with a bit of an
advantage you have more Health to work
with
develop if the counterpick can work for
him here on paper kind of one here yeah
two big characters beefy characters a
lot of Health uh kodal Khan without the
cat see if your struggle to maybe close
the gap but that's the thing called
Scorpion and proxies all that cannot
matter when it comes down to the play
itself and the Mix-Ups that exists come
on grab as well if you believe it but
there's the moon that's what I was gonna
say is is Foxy going to actually help
Implement a little bit of an aggressive
RoboCop here production we'll see
give me that oil
that's a BP oil spill here live in
Mortal Kombat
now the original plan to just try and
mix up Scorpio frogs kind of looks like
it's just gone the other way these
command grabs have been such a pain in
the backside for foxy oh no with the
jumping well that was a huge amount of
damage left on the table one of the only
times I've ever seen his command grab
not give up on us in a situation like
that the awkward jump over from RoboCop
casting I'm usually counting on it with
scorpion Bronx no pun intended on the
cold outside
that's gonna be a match point for
Scorpion Crocs who has looked very very
comfortable in this matchup so far a big
jump in wait for the inevitable button
and now it's my turn to party and Hiccup
another command crab
nice aggression from foxy here in
performance corporate Fox wake up the
buttons so you're gonna have to me to be
properly young man
that's right you want this
okay
goes into the mid now I feel like that
was such a deliberate attempt from foxy
that the regular throw comes off that so
much the Scorpion frogs would have known
so that was a next layer to establish
the mid not that it really did anything
of course but there we go the anti-crime
spikes a little bit of sun to counter
the chip damage there I like it
oh no
that's gonna do so much damage and it's
not gonna kill but that's gonna be good
it's a crab it's a gas and a neutral
jumping scorpion prox we'll take it
three to zero over a foxy Grandpa and a
young gun back to joiners final work
short work that was and uh just like
that a minimum top three finish for one
half
The Duo and with our next matchup I mean
it's going to be a pretty wild one to
see
if the twins can
face off against each other in that
Winners finals because if we look since
they made their North American debut
really whether it was CEO combo breaker
Evo they turned up took Everyone by
surprise and before you know it they're
basically getting Grand finals against
each other every time this is the
tournament
to complete the whole cycle because if
anyone can beat them
they are in this bracket yes ninja
killer is one of them foxy was one of
them obviously didn't turn out too good
sorry foxy but I mean I'm looking at
this next match because this is a
matchup that fans have been waiting for
for ages yes ever since the last Evo
basically and now here it is every
YouTube comment every twitch comment
every single comment out there where's
Ninja killer he's here he's right there
ladies and gentlemen you see him that's
it it's time to put it to the tests
because look what can you say about
Ninja killer that hasn't already been
said a million times over the natural
Talent of this player not just in Mortal
Kombat mind you the infinity fighting
game the embodiment of the man the myth
a legend
sometimes ninja killer will be at an
event just for whatever reason might not
actually enter it you know it doesn't
matter you're not always obliged to
enter things
but it's such a unique case because I've
never really seen a player in the
netherrealm scene that will attend a
tournament and just not really feel like
entering it but they could win it if
they did so the opportunity to see Ninja
killer play at this level is actually a
lot rarer himself has a mercy mechanic
on the netherrealm community
you could say that you could say that
word a certain way but here it's going
to face possibly his biggest challenge
yet since final combat
the Twins and guess what if he wants to
win they're right now both in his path
back to back and we begin
and this is why it is such a scary
situation for so many players to even
beat one of these players is difficult
as is
but then you have to fight the other who
plays basically exactly the same and
because they play at such a ridiculously
high level that has currently been too
much of a task to conquer
and with this being the final Evo for
Mortal Kombat 11. if it doesn't happen
now that opportunity is gone it will
just be cemented that scorpion frogs
Nicholas are just the top two but we're
getting a wind God mirror match fujin
execution all over the place had a
feeling we've seen a lot of food in this
tab eight
ninja Nicolas procs also the strength of
fusion is definitely something that is
grown as Mortal Kombat 11 as a moment
we're so used to seeing Jackie Briggs
centuries other characters that have
been top five positions the final
character to be maybe even within that
top three area is fujin because at the
highest level this character does
everything amazing movement amazing
buttons just an option for every
occasion if you have the execution
sometimes you're playing a different
game with the ability to control the the
screen you can see it all here
looking for that solo back to one at the
moment
that width push gonna be Paramount in
this matchup it doesn't do a lot of
damage but what it does do is shut down
anything at rage very quickly
using those wave dashes to try to you
know
what is it
the side switch being able to put ninja
killer in the corner that's a fantastic
way to start however Niche killer has
done a great job of fighting his way out
of the corner and the round it's
possible it's gonna be a difficult
anything substantial is going to do it
but the nature is to get in and out oh
trying to punish but no one home on that
one round
like he does
if you're good enough to execute you can
really squeeze out those extra few
percentages but it's not easy
all right now to hit
anyone there's immediate Shopkins
I sleep for Ninja so walk up back what
my Nicholas
these two they're moving a fusion you
see the foreign
potentially closing
here comes a quick little two hits low
thank you very much
okay it's not enough point nine four get
there there Brickle is gone
another tech
oh my good Lord what a first game the
man refused to be thrown
crowd liking what they're seeing out
there here
so let's reiterate ladies and gentlemen
this is year four of mk11 the game dies
three years ago and look at where we are
today
and how efficient a player could be from
this point to when the game first again
is not even close to comparable I would
argue that this Evo is the most that the
world has traveled for Mortal Kombat
ever we have had so many different
players in this bracket from genuinely
all over the world it's believe it or
not that's not something that you see a
lot in more as we've said being the
final chance to make history
and that on top of them being so young
and going into Mortal Kombat one things
are looking mighty good aren't they
the full screen we go the push checks
you never know if from a push check you
get a wave Dash up into your face or
back to
a 4-3 in this matchup they're almost on
the break
we're going to take a lot of damage from
that one down one into plus frames
trying to answer back he's taking a turn
but we're punished ninja killer so
you're in a situation where you really
want to press something and punish again
I'm gonna get a side switch down two
down one into the Flying Kicks with the
Fatal blows hang on a minute oh
nice down one check from Ninja but
robbery was sitting right up there in
the top left with that feedable Nicolas
I see a fujim with a fatal blow when I
get nervous I can't help it I'm about to
damage this character gets it's
ridiculous at least I swear just a
little bit more that threat starting to
get a little bit crazier
this inner Corner again
all right here comes ninja killer on the
offense the Escape failed quite smartly
going for the opposite direction of a
throw and that isn't a self-estate
failed which means the next throw if
untapped is a crushing float
they're in neutral push Jackson ninja
slightly adhere and get onto it
safe here so far once ninja got that
lead
I guarantee you that was not an
intentional down too
he's gonna throw the bucket of guts no
here in the bottom I've called US
Coliseum and get the KV what were you
pressing out there you pre if you
breathe wrong that's gonna get you
our face will blow the inside way back
into being relevant in this round
Nicholas saying things up for the KV on
the Wind push ninja killer just trying
to escape 13 seconds on the clock and
whoever has I mean Look fujin's
Backwards movement and forwards insanely
good you're gonna have to chase him down
that could have been it
and that will do it can you believe it
both of them kind of letting go of some
rounds here the first one ninja killer
had an air day I believe it was that
could have gone into a victory there
my word
I can't say I'm surprised to have the
threats of a timeout like yes a Fusion
mirror matches two characters that can
move fast and the damage can be high
you have to keep in mind it is that
backwards it's one of the greatest
strengths of this character to just get
in and out that sort of Hit and Run
style of play that if you are having to
play defensively you can play
defensively far away a lot better than
most characters so it creates such an
interesting neutral but now what game is
all right Flying Kicks to begin
I'm out I'm gonna trade out damage look
for a whiff punish but almost like
you're able to get it and there's that
reverse throw again crushing clothes
this character has amazing mids amazing
buttons as is you throw a crushing blow
to throw on top and it's a nightmare to
do
Shenanigans here at emo
let's take the breath out of the young
man a little bit give him some breathing
room
settle here
I ate the first time we've seen that in
this top six in it probably ain't gonna
be the last season
all right again
big damage on that flying kick then
she's gonna try and jump out of the
corner reposition just a little bit oh
Risky Business you know a risk that
could have gone either way in this case
is going to do it back and forth
continues and what a Beat
only gonna eat a wind push forward but I
like that test tape and showing that
he's gonna bait ninjas
all right back one again
says you want to press the button well
make up my wind switch my friend the sky
won't confirm I'm gonna get all three of
those just take the damage to where we
can get it the humans oh
I believe
in a punish as simple as that to think
of us making a paint iron prices for it
here I mean you know oh mate you've
already used to crushing blows you used
it five seconds ago that's 140 damage
oh it's just in our blood as Mortal
Kombat players
you can't help it I've seen players in
Mortal Kombat one
down and don't work in that game
very true very very true look at this in
and out movement
to mirror match though just makes it so
much more Dynamic and the woman
Dash
absolutely has created so many whiff
punishes in this tournament oh no it
wasn't talking about just moving forward
what's their ability to go more forward
whatever they want the implications
the Breakaway right at the end I mean it
did save ninja killer for that last
second sadly wasn't enough to really
mean anything but either way looks like
we're gonna be straight into restart
match we are not thinking of other
characters we're not thinking about the
stages I feel like it's gonna be this
for the remainder
because he has the interactable that can
play his own aerial Shenanigans off with
the generator I'll do a big shot
every throw in Mortal Kombat 11 is a
substantial gamble the punish damage you
take is so insane and I hate to say it
but you have to tell yourself when you
fight these twins that are machines
it's just the fact that they are so
ready to react to the throw Tech and
they just have this
that is more than likely gonna be enough
damage and if flow will lead into a
match point what am I talking about of
course it's enough damage
massive healthy Monumental Health wake
up wave Dash
there's sheer audacity at this point
that's what he was fishing for earlier
well either way I command this is gonna
be a match point for Nicholas one more
round and it will be a Chilean twin
Winner's final
again basically
I come around here though
we have to remember we're in Vegas baby
a player like ninja killer any North
American they are gonna be the people's
account right it's such an important
part of EVO to show that support
whenever you can
mk11 like I said it's the last chance
Amy massive damage rain called he wants
his super kick back
one thing we did not see in that trailer
by the way
a story for another time a story for
another time because right now Nicholas
has got half the job done 50 left to go
unless the whole string Rock it's not
gonna be unsafe to turn ninja killer
needs to make something happen quick
time is running out Aquaman it's a
miracle it's a turbine a full release
something to connect here
you're right how crazy is that between
losers
both their neutral is the defense
and patience here at full speed not
following before those speeds Like a
Rock forward
no winter respect Fuji
I don't think there's been a single hit
20 seconds
you're gonna have to play so much more
Capital than before because for Ninja
killer this is where the winners the
racket lies in the balance and hang on a
minute a full combo the final Breakaway
that we're gonna see from Ninja killer
in this matchup goes in for just a
straight up jump in and eight seconds on
the clock I don't think we have time at
all anymore wait wait wait let's get a
freeze time
It's Gonna Hurt it's gonna do so much
damage there's still time there's still
time
oh no we just needed an extra second
Aquaman oh my goodness
[Music]
ninja Killer goes to the losers side of
Evo 2023
the twin will meet his brother in
winners final how do they do it how have
they been doing it has been complete
look
we've already established anyway
collectively as the fgc though I hope
y'all like Nightwolf siblings are broken
right yeah twin twins in fighting games
it's an unfair Advantage I agree ketchup
hey look only one of us has an Eva medal
on this desk right I can't
I'm not going to debate that yeah you're
right that's a debate for later
shout outs to mustard love you bro but
look
that is
such a continuation of the sheer
dominance because when I think of a foxy
Grandpa when I think of ninja killer you
think of the absolute cream of the crop
that the best of the best
and somehow
both of the twins from Chile Nicholas
scorpion frogs they have managed to
be that next layer above like by all
means we could still have a different
winner like this tournament's not
finished but winners finals with both of
them but they are says a lot they are
guaranteed top three still both of them
which means that they no matter what
have never been lower than top three at
a major for Mortal Kombat
if someone is going to win this
tournament that is not the twins they
have to do what no one has been able to
do in this game yet which has beat both
of them in the same tournament that is
that if that happens here could that be
the biggest challenge going into Mortal
Kombat as one what a storyline that
might be if it happens here you go
oh we've got plenty more games left to
go here
we're saying that this year because yeah
but I feel like that may give our
community a nice little something to
work towards in Mortal Kombat one taking
out these young guns that have shown up
here in a later stage of MK 11. now I do
believe we are going to be going to a
quick break for some shout outs and what
have you so thank you so much for
joining us here at Evo the top six will
continue after a few minutes
Chipotle's new Chicken al pastor is fire
on every level fresh chicken hot off the
grill a rich marinade of seared Marita
peppers and ground achiode balanced with
a splash of pineapple all combined for
the right amount of heat Chipotle's all
new Chicken al pastor is where fire
meets flavor
thank you
[Music]
foreign
call
I'm ready
[Applause]
welcome back everybody Evo connections
here presented by atnt my name is
vicious and we're here at the Evo stick
museum with none other than Director of
Business developments here at Evo Mark
man and I feel like there's plenty more
titles under your belt but one thing is
for sure I think you're number one on
the leaderboards in regards to stick
collections if I'm not mistaken is that
correct I don't know about number one of
the leaderboards I definitely have the
largest collection in the world I
brought a lot of the collection here out
to evil 2023 right in the place we're
standing at right now actually happens
to have one of the more prestigious
prizes that Evil's been rolling out for
quite a few years now I think we have it
right behind us in this glass case if
I'm not mistaken for the gold fight
stick first was introduced in 2010 again
this isn't something you can buy this is
something you could only get from
beating everyone else so we're bringing
it back this year but we're doing it
with a little bit more Flair not only
does the winner get a gold stick but
second place will get a silver stick
third place will get a bronze stick so
making it more like the gold silver
bronze medals kind of like in the
Olympics that's something I really
really do enjoy when it comes to
awarding such a prize what is it about
that type of connection between the
player and the fight stick that makes it
so special to you you know it's crazy
because you go into tournaments I mean
you know this is a player I know this is
a player that you are so connected to
your weapon that you go into battle with
it is one with you you want to be able
to feel comfortable with what you're
working with but you also want to be
able to Showcase like hey this is my
personality this is who I am now I know
this is going to be the toughest
question I'm going to ask you for today
what is your absolute favorite stick in
your collection my favorite stick is the
Mad Catz Street Fighter for Arcade Fire
stick tournament Edition from 2009 and
it's just one of those sticks that's
iconic you know most people see it as a
controller but it really started
becoming a lifestyle from that point on
people started collecting them buy more
than one it's really a cool time in
arcade stick industry culture so we've
seen a lot of the different art styles
but more so of the traditional style of
fight sticks but there's been a little
bit of an evolution of said fights can
you kind of harp in on that a little bit
so more and more people are shifting to
either using control pad but also even
these new types of control is called
leverless controllers we have a section
here at the arcade stick Museum that's
dedicated to the leverless controllers
in the history of those controllers so
everything from the hitbox sticks even
victrix and Razer they're getting into
the mix it's really nice to see again a
different segment of the industry really
growing in its own and I'm always
excited to see what players use to their
advantage to be able to play these kinds
of games and win with them Trailblazer
in the community and also one that kind
of set the wave for a lot of us players
to finally get our hands on a fight
stick Mark man it's been an absolute
pleasure I appreciate your time Big Time
let's take it back to all the action
here at the main stage of evil where
we'll catch some more fighting game
action
when people need help people show up and
that is one of the most powerful aspects
of what we know as our fighting in
community so if you guys are listening
out there please think about just
supporting the cause and you know making
sure that Raiden really lives as the God
of Thunder as he should be and I think
the focus there and spreading awareness
where not only could it save his life
but maybe save the lives of many other
kids that might have to go through this
find out how you can help by visiting
fightful rare.org
welcome back everybody to Mortal Kombat
11 top six live from Evo 2023 my name's
ketchup and I'm joined by the one and
only Mr Aquaman we're going into a
loser's bracket lower bracket whatever
you want to call it elimination
territory our first matchup on stage
after this break is going to be foxy
Grandpa and zombat
zombie formerly known as combat if you
guys recognize that name one of the best
Mortal Kombat players on this planet
huge result of final combat across the
globe
and here make it a top six performance
another one that you know could be said
we haven't really seen him fight with
the twins never I've never seen zombat
fight either of them and there is a
certain type of Mortal Kombat 11 player
that
played it a lot in the first couple of
years and sort of drifted away from it
for various reasons and even Evo there
are players here that I feel like almost
everyone that's playing in a tournament
is also playing in Street Fighter 6 but
zomba is one of them foxy is another one
I believe both of them are still in
winners I think
um let's go it's the
Evo is here for Mortal Kombat and the
fact that it is the final send-off as we
transition into Mortal Kombat one I
think it has motivated a lot of players
that we used to see
and the results have been kind of here
and there in the case of someone like
zombat who to be fair was grinding a bit
extremely good results so far
someone so naturally gifted at the game
still using you know his conventional
characters I've seen the gears about out
there in the pools one of the few
gearses that's made a big run here at
Evo also has the Johnny that we see in
action some of the greatest matches I've
ever seen with that Johnny combat can
light it up but someone sent me with
foxy what are we gonna see are we gonna
see the mix and I see
a clutch up
a foxy gray
wait wait I saw Kung Lao and thought
that zombat picked the character I
haven't seen I've not seen foxy picked
Lau in years it's time what that's gotta
be excited too
I'm just a little bit taken back at the
moment because I I genuinely have not
seen foxy pick hung Lau since year one
now is it is it a foxy move where he's
just doing it to do it or is it a
matchup specific maybe player specific
thing here from foxy you truly never
know sometimes well this variation does
still help foxy play the way he wants to
play that Z hat is Paramount to pressure
to chip damage the throw mix up which is
something that foxy really was one of
the innovators for in this game catch up
here online I haven't seen that Z hat in
like six months in the competitive
setting
and there's the instant jump kick dive
kick that dive kick is the armor breaker
for Kung Lao and now maybe just a little
bit foxy could be throwing something
something to people that they haven't
seen in quite a long time either and it
might take up a little bit to get
readjusted to the Zia that was a
delicious Flawless block from zombat
though to shut down what might have been
the end of the round that Z hat has been
fantastic for foxy grandpa so far I
can't believe we're seeing it come low
it's the last character I expected and
it's weird to say that
It's a Wonderful Variety in this top
stick so shout out to the players for
that too still gonna go punch up that'd
be recovered from that until the corner
Beetle this is that big cool loud damage
it's a sit down midi see it no changes
things up each combat alive
a lot of the Z hat charge up the cancels
into I think you're gonna go for a grab
so here comes the forward four I confirm
it into a spin this is stuff that I've
genuinely not seen from foxy since the
game came out in its first year it's so
bizarre to be seeing it now but it even
more bizarre to be seeing it working
like things never changed yeah indeed
doesn't look like combo breaker 20
a long time ago 2019.
zombies gonna be able to force out that
break away from foxy Grandpa though and
is on the verge of evening up these
rounds that Z hat has eaten him alive
even on block
it can add up
definitely forces you to Flawless block
to shut down that chip obviously Grandpa
can tend to hold that one two one the
factory four now strike throughout a
kill interrupts to start because he had
two maybe should be checking him with
some more of those straight projectiles
shutting down the startup of that
all blow is still a possibility but
nothing can be landed Foxy's gotta be so
careful here and unfortunately he can't
deal with it second you blocked that
first projectile didn't have enough
meter for the last breath and now it's
one round a piece the Kung Lao versus
Johnny Cage I mean I've been in
nostalgic here we're going back in time
now projectile with Johnny's it's so
quick that when you do just try to micro
move in neutral you're forced to block
it because it's so fast look at the
Flawless blocks from zomba as well the
whip punished say cheese you're on TV
throw no tech there from foxy and a
really good situation for someone at the
moment the one two one that's gonna be a
full combo no break against on that
respecting the dive kick armor breaks so
much about the defense now guess the
throw Escape build to the seven there
foxy likes now he's got mix up on top of
mix for his opponent to worry about
multiple hats coming
build some space
this is where he's actually liked to
play the matchup so far outside of the
fourth range of Johnny that's a smart
way to do it again really good use of
flawless blocks however foxy kind of
happy to still throw hats at that point
looks for a whiff punish not quite able
to get it and that's a punish on the
advancing mid from foxy that's the first
game the zombat but a long game it was
now are we going into Kung Lao again or
are we thinking of changing I don't even
know what the potential could be I'm not
even sure what motivated the Kung Lao
pick in the first place I think in
denim's own mind he's just rolling a
dice and whatever it lands on we're
gonna get possibly
there's a lot more potential we could
see Sub-Zero we could see
the Terminator again okay it's gonna be
Terminator
you've got that nice solid neutral there
Johnny Cage but can you deal with my
overhead low I guess we'll find out
Johnny's gonna be able to deal with the
iron grenades really well in neutral but
not the foxy release of a neutral and
awful lot almost never uh straight
project out of Johnny may give him a
little bit of trouble we'll see how this
matchup goes
an absolute Rock Solid Johnny Cage from
zomba as you expect at this stage and
we'll see if it can continue currently
one game up here
foxy can you turn on the blender and get
it on Max baby I want Max blender
well haven't had the chance just yet
because that Johnny Cage forward throw
has other plans right starting off with
the overhead in this case armor break
still getting the mix up and take away
the Breakaway you'll love to see it here
comes another one hey
what's next oh crap that counts as mix
another one you're getting next oh no
foxes I've dropped my combo I guess I'm
just going to have to mix you up again
that's a foxy Grandpa round right there
start to end mix-up after mix-up until
your life seems to just cease existing
is one of his mission parameters
typically the subject that gets mixed up
is terminated exterminate life
throw the overhead throw them all look
out
enough of that
Scorpio wake up down four he knew that
he wasn't right there and it's not
something Johnny's gonna meet you with
really every mix up and by the way that
back one is tactically timed to either
side switch or keep the same side
you time it differently depending on
which version you want so it actually
gives you a lot of create
creativity depending on how you want to
end your combo
all right the downfall in this case Dash
into another one it's on Matt just
trying to fight his way through does
manage to get the block and finally gets
the punish we'll be keeping an eye on
that for sure
have you ever seen it yet because Foxy's
just been right so much on the guests
with punish combat is gonna build
breaker but will he be spending it nope
knocked down into potentially one more
mix
oh no a few more oh the string was
coming and that is the mix-up with iron
grader really any variation just what
this variation is able to do to take
away the grab after the four two that is
the fix up
combat trying to make that big crazy
like he did the end against Kung Lao
knew that slight punish on that awkward
string you don't see really stagger a
lot from the Kung Lao there at the end
not able to uh thread the needle fight
sometimes you don't feel like you've
made mistakes yeah just guessed wrong
and for everyone watching at home
dude I'm gonna ask you ketchup where do
where do most people put Terminator on a
tier list for those that don't know
people consider Terminator to be quite
bad possibly the worst in Mortal Kombat
11. a foxy grandpa says just another day
at the office you give me some tools I'm
going to mix
and here we are one game a piece here
zomba sadly has guessed wrong a fair few
times and I've got to point that out
another low and a low that is not looked
out for but how can you it's a mix-up we
haven't even started talking about this
character's teleport yet
time displacement equipment
he's just getting combat to whiff in
these last two rounds
showcasing the spacing of Terminator the
slight movement you know he doesn't move
very fast or far but that down four is
damn good and it's a huge part of the
neutral this is
but the Terminator is going to be a
contester
I was on that off to a decent Beginnings
here the down four again into another
mix-up that is not blocked correctly in
this case 30 and Beyond 35 for a
successful low and this variation of
Terminator never really looked at but
you're looking at things that you see in
a lot of characters 35 for a bar mix
side switch capability like you're
talking about the ion grenade this
character's cooking a little bit Foxy's
showing us
what's what's still capable here in year
four in this game good luck on that low
from zomba unable to fight his way out
of the corner at the same time right
teleport one good patience to just wait
for it and then down for yourself
prevents the opportunity to just take
away those plus frames and there's the
breaker armor break and now potentially
one more mix
well an error an execution error oh good
lord
one round a piece and Foxy's gonna be
kicking himself for that one they both
just gave each other a thumbs up on the
stage for that and he was like Oh no
you're doing that great buddy
it was going to be a button but the
button wasn't there
oh nice use of the one two as well good
start here for zombac looking real good
is that one mistake and it costs foxy
huge in this
momentum he had he's gonna put in a
Johnny Cage prison right now known as
the corner
this is locked down
aggressive use of those low Folks by the
way the thing about those Mix-Ups is
they aren't incredibly fast I mean
they're certainly not terrible but
Johnny Cage is down three it's down one
they're so quick they interrupted and
this is a great turnaround for zomba and
every stagger that he's done puts him
outside of the range where he can walk
back and let Terminator with it down
four two
but never say never is the miracle gonna
happen no doesn't get the full convert
off the one over that lands and combat's
turning this around Mighty quick off
that one grenade that went out to the
nether realm and couldn't save foxy if
there's one thing that round gave zomba
it was momentum and that momentum
carried over all the way into the rest
of the game and now you know folks he
just has to be careful that that
momentum doesn't carry over into this
match zombat has been feeling it with
these buttons and strings and they've
been so fast they've been shutting down
the startup of the mix-up tools and
another one zombat oh my Lord no the
reader's trying to come to play aren't
they getting inside the mind a little
bit of foxing this pressure right there
that Ginger when foxy is gonna throw it
down four but the push back on that
string allows Johnny to play around that
range and it's been locking foxy down in
this corner
all right that's gonna be a whip on the
throw the armor break a potential
comeback is there but zombap trying to
fight back all right punish number one
backs off gets the knock down keeps the
corner positioning overhead really good
block from zomba and match the points
I've got to deal with this Terminator
like it ain't no big deal Aquaman the
one game foxy one was combat trying that
right there calling out the string of
the overhead this time if foxy would
have committed to the iron grenade gave
it a different story
a foxy going for the grab Ender again
we're going to keep those plus frames
wake up up three a good choice there
from zombat stealing a turn back at the
same time
oh looking for the approach on that on
four and he finds off in the back of the
corner again this is for Foxy's
had to fight out teleports this time
I like the respect for foxy reappears
from the teleport but doesn't try
pressing a button oh must have been some
kind of anti-air attempt but whatever it
was it just got beat by that jump clean
and now zombat with Terminator in the
corner not afraid to put himself in the
corner either
get off me
another throw attempts give him a fox
opportunity to get some mix started here
we go
early wait a second cut it off the armor
break another one that'll be the round
of the foxy Grandpa stays alive three
Mix-Ups in a row three of them hit
successfully that's just the nature of a
character like this but foxy still has
to fight for his life because zomba is
on Match Point and this is elimination
territory
match up to the top six
just lost block there didn't see
anything off it resources are there for
him though that overhead eating combat
for breakfast late back to the corner
you go you gotta love the side switch of
this character capabilities
punish on the overhead really good block
on that and zombot ready
the breakaway's been forced out from
foxy probably the last one he's gonna
get in this game has to be so careful
zomba on the offense blood in the water
I suppose because now we're continuing
to chip down that's higher the corner
oh no
it's a really weird range near the
corner either way and calls it to this
low into meal blow he just did it the
Terminator still has life ready to go
get over here is it enough to kill
though is it enough yes it is he paid
for the DLC you betcha
hahaha
a final game to decide which of these
two is out of Mortal Kombat 11's final
major event here at Evo 2023
living or dying By The Sword is Foxy
right now I am loving this straight hit
Advantage 50 50 bet it off
Skynet program The Terminator to do one
thing it's live and die by the mix-up
and that's what we're seeing right now
you guys are so good with all your
defense with all your footsies try
guessing
another one it sits Mark oh and we're
starting to extend it now zombat feels
kind of comfortable being knocked down
from far away and having the speed of
the buttons to challenge the command
grab is deceivingly fast
turning this into a 33 32 33 wait a
second
big checks and balances right now with
those down fours
he's chipping away that Health piece by
piece at the moment teleporting out of
the corner respects the downfall in this
case does it back to back a full combo
for zombat though and a side switch to
boost
either
oh just getting some hit advantage
he's gonna put the full use here
another throw Tech foxy and the command
grab she adds the layers to do that with
how many resources combat had you know
with fatal blow locking loaded fights
your audacity to get back oh boy
another joke get out of there Sky don't
break away for you keep guessing back to
back overhead zombart just ever so
slightly too slow on that punish
however things slowly starting to
crumble here on the bright side he's got
him in the corner I was about to say the
same thing but no wait he finally got
the right read on a 4-3 to go under and
all of this the reward you're back in
the corner it's time to mix another come
on guys foxy wasn't come on grab all
series long and now right near the end
he's starting to time to add the extra
however combat full combo crushing
what's next
397.
we're about eight seconds away from him
having a cancer foxy Grandpa it's going
to end this three to two and take it
over zombat zombot your journey was a
hard-fought one my friend but you are
terminated out of Mall combat 11 here at
Evo 2023
that what a roller coaster it was a
perfect example of the dynamic
Terminator brings to the game and to be
frank
the way foxy looks at the character when
you look at Terminator in this game it's
a lot of stuff happening that
it's quite good but it's
the way everyone uses the character lots
of the Running Man lots of the sort of
doing the mix-up and then doing running
man into stuff the command grabs
this variation is so much more simple on
paper but with the ion grenade giving
you the damage output the launch
potential of everything the conversion
potential you look at this variation and
you think how can this be an EVO worthy
variation it's so simple it's so basic
but in the hands of someone like Foxy
Grandpa you know World finalists and
multiple titles uh crazy in multiple
games we talked about that before this
top success well foxy just so naturally
talented at gaming really just at life
but
that's neither here nor there foxy
incredible see what he can if he can
continue the Run uh making top four
again here at Evo okay our next match up
I can see the two players sitting down
to play Mighty unjust versus ninja
killer now we've talked about Ninja
killer uh we certainly do not need to
reintroduce this player you've seen you
know what what we bring to the table
here and the results speak for
themselves over time Mighty unjust I
really really want to talk about for a
second because Mighty unjust
another one of the uh the twin brother
players shouts to elkakoi in the crowd
no doubt Mighty unjust has been absolute
top level at mk11 for years but has
always been just outside of that major
major result like one of this caliber
and to be honest reaching the later
stages of this tournament even going up
against rewind to reach this point my
heart sank watching them play because if
Mighty unjust could not secure this
final spot here I feel like he would
have just been devastating yeah you know
you mentioned it before this was kind of
his last opportunity to get that that
performance to solidify himself here in
Mortal Kombat 11 on an offline stage
he's done it here against someone that
placed second last year ketchup second
and he's up here in that chair had the
most emotional response from anyone that
made top six today you could see that
weight of four years of grinding four
years
finally paying off the 722 time ESL
Champion the mighty unjust
making it work offline yeah it's no
exaggeration to say that Mighty unjust
had won
countless online North American
tournament and you're always looking to
see that that success be reflected
offline and who knows maybe that's where
things go now character Choice it has
got 13th last year but as you mentioned
just outside both him and his brother
9th and 13th last year that the twins
got an MK1 look out for all of them
maybe they've been nuts all right now
character Choice the thing about Mighty
Young Justice he plays a lot of
characters but the ones that you see the
most regular is Jackie Briggs I've seen
a bit of centurion in the past but a lot
of Kano actually yeah there are any Kano
fans out there there's definitely a
chance you're gonna see your boy in this
matchup don't quote me on it though that
Jackie sure was looking good it was
that's gonna be the pick here
ninja I'm assuming we're just gonna be
seeing the fujin
ninja killer known for using Liu Kang
back in the day but even early on in
this game yeah but you look at
fundamentals and natural talent and
execution
you can play Liu Kang or you can play
fujin who's gonna be better for you more
than likely it's going to go to the wind
God every time
looking at matchups across the board we
ask ourselves who beats who did
I can't think of a single character
it's quite a predicament to find
yourself in here
I mean I gotta say it's it's still great
to see fujin in this game because before
mk11 I believe it was somewhere around
the 14 years Mark since we saw fujin
fujin's last game before this was Mortal
Kombat Armageddon on the PlayStation 2.
did you say 40 years oh they said 40. I
think I had I think I had 14 in my head
and maybe four came out I'm not gonna
lie it's already left my brain it was a
long time it has been a long time it was
a long time he deserves to be this good
foreign
he's got
horrible Corner pressure
come on grab this character built on
offensive degeneracy is about the best
way I can describe it he puts you in a
forced situation and not many characters
can do that but they put you in a forced
situation Plus on block you'd be
guessing Don more a multitude of other
things now of course the custom
variation you've got the bio pull a stun
attack that reaches real far away the
chemical burn chip damage and pressure
and then a command grab because why not
just give yourself a command grab in
this game pretty even on the health
department so far might you unjust
there's a confirmed
the combo broken out but that's gonna be
three plus frames now tries to back out
and here comes even more of it 1-1
and ending it with the command grab once
more
if you're already on just that that's
exactly how you should play it don't be
trying to give this man a turn but hold
on he finds one and calling out the plus
range this time around
oh the Kano ball out of nowhere
nice spit attacker
let's go get a protein mid-match man so
it's all about those gains those uh
those Australian volcano gains ah it
doesn't matter it's been on the floor
who cares
but either way a really good first round
there from unjust no free to just fight
right to return the favor you get up
against the character who has a movement
like this I mean Kano does not have
movement anywhere near it
pick up from killer
look at the space that he builds in the
pressure
definitely could have walked out right
there and she tried to fish the forward
one but now he's in forward one Ranger
playing kano's game
so that throw Escape I'm just trying to
enforce the gravel to his range that's
why I walk and pull together break away
but yeah just now with no defensive bar
so you've got to be real careful how you
approach this character almost two miles
of offensive for Ninja killer even a
single Barbie expense good damage one of
which going off the wind push looking
for an anti-air that is a tight one
and if you saw him almost pull it off
but look at this matchup I saw it
earlier on the stage look for the mighty
young just to try the secret extended
suck that he's got if you get hit by
don't laugh at that if he gets hit by
the dagger it extends the range of that
battle pole that he's got and could come
in to play full screen as ninja killer
takes a few chapter
where that was we're gonna jump back to
I think it was it's the wind kick back
up just to make sure that we finish the
combo with Mighty unjust in the corner
and just like that one round each in
this first game and again elimination
elimination territory is a different
level of stress
the regular throw out of the corner that
harder to Tech in the situation guys in
doing so ninja killer has opened up a
chance to be put in the corner himself
what lost out on a whole setup there and
unjust and now he's neutral is reset
back to it out of the sky from half
screen I have genuinely never seen
chemical burn Miss in that situation
that is so unfortunate for my ear just
because that corner sequence that's like
entering set play territory yeah
we've seen health bars disappear in that
situation that's for sure turbine
covering all the space in front of a
form
just needs one more the push hitting
underneath kale it looked like it
another one to say sit down your full
screen Ninja on the board early
straight into a restart match here
wasting no time Kano still looking like
the character to pick but
so much of that momentum was taken away
by that back one chemical burn just for
some reason not working in the corner I
don't know if it was a rainy situation
or something but either way it gave
ninja killer an opportunity to escape
the corner we're going to turn that into
a full combo you're gonna try and
challenge it here comes to the pool for
another time it's not doing a bunch of
damage but it adds up eventually
cases down the wake-up roll the back
wants to connect to a ninja killer
turning things around now unjust back to
the wall that is
man's dancing here in uh in top six
freestyling with the movement and now
the offense is ninja simple jump and
pressure it gets I'd love to use the
sweep to reset neutral he goes back into
the corner he did that a lot
that up two is gonna be more than enough
to win that round a ninja killer now
we're talking about someone who's
currently feeling it look no further
when you reach a point where you start
to get up twos like that you're just so
in tune with when your opponent's gonna
press the button to use block that is a
scary message to send your opponent
because look I've reached a layer that
you now have to match and if you can't
you're in trouble a full combo again
Skywalker can't quite get the uh side
switch but this point who cares oh
punish you said the magic Works ninja
kill is getting comfortable this
starting to look kind of scary finally
one mistake from him gets unjust a hit
okay can you get a sequence going
there's two how about another one
no
back to immediately checks I'm not
letting him breathe sometimes no matter
where you are is a checkbook bag too
it's a check with pitch it's a check
with something
there's the KB from the wind push as
well for damage that unjust real he did
not want to have to deal with the
situation back to anti-year Amplified
that with kick just to be sure and at
this point that looked reactionary man
from from three-quarter screen to see
the jump instantly and to know the arc
that you or sorry the angle that you
can't have to hit that to wait a little
bit because if you do the back too too
early they're too high in their jump Arc
I think it's gonna miss that's
disgusting
the white unjust has a decision to make
whatever character you pick here you are
putting the rest of this match in the
balance
so if kano's not gonna be the choice we
could maybe see I mean no I don't know
wait wait no absolutely no chance
absolutely we might see the Raiden
Jackie oh no it's it's the Jackie and
Jackie got him here had to take out I
believe rewinds Kano
it was
match up in this instance again you're
putting a lot of faith into it Jackie
she is an overwhelming character and
she's definitely seen by many to be top
three but
with a character like fujin you have to
worry about the fact that she's got that
950 Health she has less Health than most
and against fujin that's less work he
has to do to win
and back to work we go in this one 2-0
for Ninja killer put now the goop full
screen I don't know why there maybe
maybe inviting fujin or telling fujin to
stay away from her
there's elements of either but so far I
think ninja killer has been content just
sitting full screen and letting it rock
that back one doesn't turn into anything
but damage damage he is known as the
lamest fujit to ever exist and that he
will Zone you to death with projectiles
I don't even do damage you're talking
about you talking about a troll on
another level he beats you without
damage sometimes
it's gonna frustrate it's gonna
interrupt the startup of loads of your
advancing attacks
with punish encounter him we'll just
take that free damage oh and was that
intentional to dude
I don't know what else he could have
done
maybe maybe it was so good we simply
can't comprehended ketchup they were
just not at that level maybe that's why
we're here and they're on the stage
that's right at this point though you
kind of you said it yourself it's just
that that lame playstyle not afraid to
sit back not afraid to be patient I
think it's Jackie think about Jackie is
she is a character that she's rushed
down heavy but she's gotta get in and
look at how ninja killer is just keeping
that distance Flawless block on the leap
and now keeping it even more so mighty
unjust is having a miserable time hold
this up a down one in the corner that
Skywalker all the way over here she's
trying to close the cap and another full
screen back to an entire this is just
this is just Madness my unjust is uh
laughing
he's just laughing on the stage he just
watched ninja fly away just fly away
oh another whiff punish on that back too
and sad to save really looks like this
Jackie was not the correct pick because
elimination territory tries to go for a
conversion there a stroke of luck though
means that my young just to get a combo
and the 114 was already spent the K be
on Win push and it's just going from bad
to worse I don't know I already used it
I got another one no big deal that's my
form looking for the reader with the
instant air spit oh my goodness if not
it worked I may have left my seat ninja
still needs one can a mighty unjust pull
off the mightiest comeback in Evo
how can you chase him come back come
back and on amplification it's gonna be
the kill
Ninja
played on another level there to the
point there there were points in the
match where we sat there and gone what
could unjust have done differently
I don't know I can only assume maybe not
pick Jackie but it's weird to say
because the Jackie is such a character
that he's known for and he's got such
good results with but in that matchup
there's not really much to practice
couldn't find him couldn't catch him
he's just running away the whole game
I've never seen a character able to get
away with anything Mobility
Shenanigans wise against a character
like Jackie who can match it right if
you're quick enough on reaction but
there there was something about what
Ninja did that he was like I don't know
how to get over there and punish where
is he going to land I don't know maybe
there are so many unknowns that ninja
kind of throw him there at the end well
sadly it doesn't mean that Mighty unjust
is out of the tournament but I want to
give one final shout out to unjust for
making it this far and really securing a
a legendary performance right when it
mattered most yes you know I think that
that's the important thing about Martin
just so congratulations well done he's
got a couple chips on that shoulder
going in MK1 that's for sure
but it's been really good so far we've
got plenty more matches here thanks to
everyone that's been tuning in and
joining us obviously I can see the
wonderful crowd on the other camera here
so shout outs to everyone tuning in in
person there's a sea of people out there
man it's awesome I love it that's what
it's all about and and if any of them
were here last year now a lot of them
probably were
it's a familiar Story coming up ahead it
really is it really is because last
year's Evo for Mortal Kombat 11 there
were still people's Champs remaining but
so many people were looking to just see
who can defeat The Twins and look we're
going to talk about it some more I can
see them sitting down and they're going
to set up their matches but before we do
it we're going to throw to a quick break
so thank you for joining us so far Evo
2023 continues after this
your Chipotle order just got extra the
fighter coins from Street Fighter 6.
order any entree in the Chipotle app
using promo code
hdkn236 and received 250 fighter coins
with yours visit chipotle.com sf6 for
details
you got this
only a handful of people in the world
can do it
be
best
but it's dangerous these are incredible
steaks you're going to be forced to make
Split Second decisions that could cost
you your life get out whether you like
it or not you are in this race
Red Bull gives you wings
thank you
[Music]
PlayStation
my soul keeps Rising as I sing my song
[Music]
nothing
here we go
[Music]
and welcome back everyone to the top six
of Mortal Kombat 11 here at Evolution we
have now ascended into the top four with
winners finals up next and two almost no
one's surprise it is going to be the
twins going at it from Chile it's going
to be scorpion procs going up against
nicolasi or ketchup and I think if we
look at the overall top four it's not
really one that surprises anybody we
have the twins ninja killer and Foxy
Grandpa this it was I think this was top
prediction this I think was top four
just with one or two differences with I
think just the difference between where
I think rewind was where ninja killer
was last year somewhere around there in
similarities uh but simple top four and
that is going to be one U.S
representative against foxy and the
twins that's a that's a tall order
it's the different generations of Mortal
Combat that's what excites me the most
every new fighting game brings forward a
new generation of players and sometimes
those players instantly Ascend into
stardom and that's where we are with the
twins obviously you can see it in front
of your shouts to you wonderful people
in the crowd enjoying the show and by
all means this is where the games merely
begin this weekend there's plenty more
fighting games where that came from but
look now we know these two yeah are we
about to talk about the same thing I
think so I think so take it away go on
by all means if you if you'd like to
well you can talk about characters in it
yeah we are yeah now is it is it gonna
be a mirror that we know them for have
known them for in these Grand finals
because we don't know if it's
if it's something if it's just you know
how the comfortable character they're
most comfortable against with against
each other but we usually see night wolf
V Night Moves will it be something
different here yeah in this case it will
be a mirror match but um unless this is
a unless yeah unless they're messing
with some fun check you see two Johnny's
on the screen if they mirror in any
capacity it's gonna be West because it
is essentially a mirror
these are two people that exist or sorry
one person that exists in two parts of
the bracket I don't understand it
if they go in with the Jody cage mirror
it's just a mirror in and out of the
game it's just the nature of twins I
suppose but normally twin fighting game
players tend to
actually pick different characters but
it's rare that they play exactly the
same but no they're restarting that it's
a Johnny Cage mirror winners finals
scorpion proxy Nicholas only one of them
can make it into Grand finals on the
Winner's side let's find out who it's
gonna be I'm the star you're the
stand-in
keep dreaming mini me we're going full
Hollywood here in winners finals today
proxy Nicholas throwing down it's a
battle of the cages into the mirror
between the two It's usually the night
wolf could be a lot more I mean similar
kind of functionality a lot of grounded
uh footsie oriented pressure we're gonna
see between the two getting ready to sit
back and take it all in ladies and
gentlemen First Blood going to Nicolas
here on the knock down getting things
crazy with the whip stand too it's just
the punish of the Shadow kick now I'm
gonna start this series by setting up
some expectations expect any possible
character after a game is over they play
basically everyone in the game and
against each other they seem to just go
through the entire roster for various
reasons but all right don't be a problem
that Health Smart disappeared awful
quick equalizer what implementing a no
block game is so aggressive
comes off cancel himself his scorpion
prox brings that back from a proverbial
grave to get a starter you said expect
anything it's already started I mean
that was almost a great comeback that
was fumbled at the last minute but
thankfully for Scorpion Crocs
somehow these buttons are just working
on their own Nicholas getting opened up
by just basic strings at this point
I think he's trying to get a little too
cheeky on wake up with some of this
disrespect against the brother I was
gonna say younger brother but they're
twins I can't really make any kind of
assumption here well you know
technically one of them
all right Nicholas with the comeback
arcing projectile versus the straight as
well there's a slightly different
variation let's keep that in mind not a
complete mirror match we can't stand to
the one two one the defense there from
Nicholas got both of the rising star to
keep himself safe
that was very risky that was very risky
very risky indeed oh
we trade off with the projectiles what a
way to start
oh this unconventional pressure let's
use the secret sweeps from Young Nikolas
will someone quit if that hits tonight
if that KB lands on someone it is a
community
known thing that you have to Simply give
up because your opponent is beating you
at that point
but we haven't seen it yet but in that
case it just got completely with
punished Nicholas looking pretty
comfortable in this final round of this
first game about letting that comeback
really face him whatsoever
determined as these two have you know it
hasn't been one-sided in their own
rivalry amongst these two as Nicolas
takes skin number one because Nikolas
has beaten scorpion procs at a major
Grand Final and taken one himself
I think we're just going for a restart
match was that right yep cage mirror
continues with these two straight to
business and not to curse things but I
have I think never seen these two not go
too through
to a game five
extremely rare if it doesn't that's for
sure appear to the end
between the two
boss blocks are seconded some follow-up
he's resources right now
we're punished
get out of here with that I'm gonna hit
you with my two-piece launcher punch you
in the nuts we're Flawless blocking low
folks right now ketchup on command it
seems
the level we are at knocked on the door
step one just super checks it oh far
away it Bliss go the up three is so bad
oh Johnny Cage
much of the night will fear you hear
that Flawless block sound unlock guys
when you watch this match just listen
what how how
and got the armor break optimal the
motion bizarre thing in the world with
these two is that they'll do the hardest
stuff ever and then they'll drop the
easy bit that was string into fatal flow
how do you mess that up
your Flawless blocking within
milliseconds of things and it's the
simple stuff you're right either way
though hit confirm
scorpion props drops the combo now
Nicholas
behind for the combo of his own he's so
quick on seeing those drops too
Thackery finally opens up
what are these drops right now it's a
little too early for both twins
I'm so confused
God look away I'm watching this is this
is what it takes to get into the mind of
your brother
okay someone who's known your own mind
since birth
you have to do the Unholy
there's the knowledge dunks under the
second and now we land the face
no trouble
to be shaky round spaghetti all over the
floor
but either way we tied up and Nicholas I
think you're gonna be feeling a bit good
after that you know because a couple of
mistakes that really you're not used to
seeing him make
swiftly undone by the same situation but
done better you're just feeling good
after that
sweep sweep
Brock's not afraid of the unconventional
buttons of the characters either and
when he's tuned to the night wolf mirror
you see every single tool in normal that
the character possesses and what it's
kind of known for it has a goose similar
to a Johnny Cage here these twins they
play every character at this level
that's what's scary about him ketchup I
don't know if people know this at home
they're like this with the whole roster
it's a pretty uncharacteristic combo
drops actually coming from both of these
players
I wonder what it is about them playing
against each other because you're used
to seeing them play against everyone
else and whenever they play against
other players everything just is almost
perfect what is going
not punched
the punches
I just don't get it they're just going
after the nuts and that's it it's the
only objective
Johnny Cage the confirm again one game a
piece drops the combo a wake up up three
Miss why are they trying to end the
family line here ketchup why are they
trying to stop it now
it's a very Johnny Cage thing to do
you're going for the Legacy
procs with the Unholy amount of that
Flawless plots on pokes on anything
the sound of the Flawless block has just
been printed into my brain at this point
thanks to these two and there we go
again
I'm so I I don't get it why are they
doing that
why are they just going for the nut
button on its own and he knew almost
knew that his brother was gonna drop
that combo and one toot him out of it
because he missed timed that the instant
jump too
fight you shouldn't make that read on
paper but he just did
that lets me know that I can twins can
feel each other in a way do you think in
bracket when someone gets mixed like the
other one feels it
maybe I'd add that to the list of loads
of silly questions us twins get asked on
a daily basis
can you feel each other's pain can you
feel each other's pain that's what I
want to know yeah have you ever felt
Mustard's paint ketchup no it's a stupid
one
the joke was that it's a silly silly
question Mr that's right now we're
pushing forward point taken a full combo
now Scorpio prop sadly misses the end of
it though Nicholas well at the rate of
it looks like we're going into one round
of Peace again
we can have another miracle comeback in
him this is a comeback character
specialist and that's the funnest block
of another Punk
down one taken out of the game
when you're taking away seven frame
normals that's a little bit of a
different monster that you're
approaching here from scorpion procs
guys
stuff that we haven't seen uh you know
as consistent in all the other rounds
and matches leading up to this point
you're seeing it at the Apex
even the meaty string was Flawless block
there
the difference in time he's had to do to
pull that off scorpion Brooks biting his
way out of the corner though back to
that mid screen we go the whip on the
throw actually keeps it I'd say keeps it
unbreakable but I think it was just like
a meter what yeah
I think we're gonna learn so many new
things about Johnny Cage tonight
pressure
I'm expecting rotten up punches here at
any point off the stand twos anything
there's a good thumb give me that
crushing blow please full combo side
switch
unconventional Ender though
the jump OS as well just off that just
in case the down two whiffs and that is
gonna be better hit by the down forward
Flawless blocks the projectile not that
it matches because Nicholas all right
it's one game away from getting Grand
finals
but with how things are going to be
honest I expected game five it's how
things go and have gone for two years
with these two quick rematched as
they've always done right back into it
and there's no difference in like the
octane-ness that they come out with
they're right back in the match they're
already making the crazy decisions and
reads
playing at that level
here comes the knocking scorpion project
the slight Health leading he does have
the yellow jacket on the left and that
was just footsies 101 with the movement
take it in turn to down one neither
player wants to completely give up a
turn just yeah
speaking of not wanting to oh my Lord
you do it to me I'll do it right back
and I'm gonna do it again
as if he's he's fishing his brother two
Flawless block by Flawless blocking
right now that's where we're at
just absolute Fearless fearlessness it's
such a sibling rivalry thing to do what
that was not like the punch I've ever
seen don't avoid a projectile
I don't really understand what's going
on with the uh
all tries to squeeze out more damage I
respect the attempt
if you're trying to do the Scorpion
process into him fast blocking after
Flawless block there's one
I'm listening for the second one after
every part goes plug here we go
so we're going to Mid screen jump in
Flawless block to take away some of
those frames and get a turn and now
scorpion prox has the Fatal blow cancels
coming no holds on to it attack again
Nicolas has been over it every time he's
done the Amplified projectile alarm
block says that's not gonna work on me
match point for Nicholas though one
round and that will be one of the twins
in Grand finals I'd say that was
guaranteed at the beginning of winners
finals but with Nicholas meeting in this
position we'll see which one's gonna be
right
gorgeous anti I guess I'll break
stays outside of the normal ranges of
Nicolas right now that's himself
how many buffers did he put in how many
how many do and still got the time to
let to be underneath the throw and get
that down to the loss on another level I
mean we didn't even see the combo get
finished but it didn't even really seem
to matter that much with punish and no
breaker for Scorpion procs at the rate
of things going Nicholas absolutely will
be taking this could be the first time
that there will not be a game by between
the two twins as Nicolas gonna start so
maybe take a look remember that though
he got a road too confident here I can
only assume some type of those nut
punches are being used to bait out down
fours and try and crush it oh no
no cancel was
just saying up shop in Grand finals with
the Winner's side the safety net of not
being sent to the lower bracket just yet
that's a pretty big deal in the
tournament like this so could rest easy
for a brief moment while we get through
the rest of these matches to find out
who's gonna join him you definitely have
to catch your breath a little bit after
watching those two play the level that
they play at the speed by the time you
even contemplate what they did seven
other things have already happened
especially in match-ups like that
because they they genuinely play so many
characters between themselves that when
they've gone Head to Head they've they
have gone through what feels like the
entire roster over two years we've seen
Johnny Cage mirrors like that we've seen
Nightwolf mirrors we've seen Kung Lao
Liu Kang their regular roster but it's
more likely that they go with the Lesser
used characters and I feel like there's
an element there of you play against
someone All the Time as their main
training partner they're gonna know the
ins and outs of your gameplay so the
regular character picks might not be the
best option sometimes you can go in with
a lesser used character that you
probably wouldn't use against someone
else but against your brother who knows
everything you're about to do that gives
you an edge and that's a really hard
thing to explain to people that aren't
experienced competing with people that
you play against every single day yeah
it's just it's its own meta and anyone
that has siblings that they compete
against will probably tell you the same
thing and one thing on top of that it
could be a challenge between the two as
to determine who's better between the
two using the same character right and
that being the determining factor that
could be it all this time too is that
they just want to mirror and see who's
the best with the same character Aquaman
look who's sitting down to play that's
me listening this is a huge match so we
are in that top four territory we're now
going to go back into the elimination
area and this is two legends going Head
to Head it's gonna be ninja killer and
it's gonna be a foxy Grandpa we're gonna
get the show on the road to find out who
is the last Defender
to go up against the twins because let's
rewind a little bit let's let's go back
and that wasn't even a punch oh yeah
I'll take I'll take full credit for it
that last year rewind was that player
and had the full support of the entire
crowd to try and conquer the
unconquerable in both brothers
that is gonna happen again this year but
it's one of these two and it's gonna be
so
insanely hard to win this tournament
for either because because now you have
to beat the twins three times
no matter how you slice it from here on
out now here we're both of these players
have they ever played each other in an
offline setting
if I recall they played in year one I
think it might have been CEO and it was
a very very long time ago yes it was
this game and it's
later stages coming full circle between
these two a boxy Grandpa ah the foxy
going in with the Sub-Zero I want to mix
you up but I want to have a good slide
good combo potential that's not enough
we shall see if this Sub-Zero is gonna
get the job done but ninja killer going
in with that absolutely Rock Solid
I think he just wants to contend with
the full screen zoning of fujin a little
bit better with the Sub-Zero gonna have
to thread of the slide which is still
not gonna be upon us there it's kind of
sniped out early by Ninja already puts
in a potential prison
you're gonna record a gorgeous air there
so I ain't tired
could led to a lot near the Sub-Zero has
the ice barrage hold on a second foxy
known for bringing those subtle
differences with the characters
see if he's gonna try to match a little
bit of the zoning of fujin here
now foxy has historically always got in
with different variations look no
further than the Terminator one the
Sub-Zero is kind of similar
however in this case that push is just
saying look mate stay away I have no
interest in letting you get close
because if there's one character you
want to avoid getting close range it's
Sub-Zero
and Foxy knowing the matchup knowing all
those pushes not Amplified aren't gonna
face him whatsoever as long as he gets
one trade with an ice ball it's gonna be
a good time
so relentless with the winch push at the
moment
cannot allow any of it to start up
oh and he really tried to change things
up there
the full screen wave Dash to 4-3 he said
he eats a nice ball and eight seconds on
the clock fox in the throw to take the
time off instead of ninja who still has
time to get a hit if he wants to
switch it all loud and it's going to not
be in no less time expires almost on the
second end of the Fatal blow for the
chip the Fatal blow so nearly did enough
to chip it out ninja killer is so smart
for going for it by the hair on the chin
of the Grand Master of the linquay foxy
gets through that one
overhead
let's not forget Sub-Zero's got that
overhead low mix up as well
the forward throw double digit plus
frames on that so here comes another one
in this case ninja killer tries to
challenge the low now foxy full combo
the rising ice even more damage reset
crushing blow and it's nearly enough not
quite
marketing sub pick at the ice axon
hadn't used it the entire time I was
wondering what was gonna be
complimenting that uh barrage and he
does have the ax equipped this is
subsidious this is the foxy variation
it's the barrage it's the air ax and
it's the rising ice it's utility and a
little bit of ranged options and you
still have your damage and only looking
for ice ball off the low which you don't
need the resources to Cabo into now off
to a decent start but the question is
for how long one big jump in from Ninja
killer he's gonna more than even the
score with that health and now forward
throw gonna make that divide even
stronger should I take the wind out of
this man tries to beat him with a little
bit of wave dashing maybe try to try to
force him into a slide some kind of
hesitation
he keeps the full screen game shutting
down the slones of the ice barrage
and this is slowly
slowly chipping away at the foxy Grandpa
health bar
only on Amplified let's do that one
percent at a time
not a war that Foxy's winning right now
the attrition on fujin's side and he
moved into it this time around
and I feel like this might be one of the
reasons we saw the Sub-Zero in the first
place it's just a matter of looking at
the range and trying to go for trades
Escape failed foxy quite rightly goes
for the Lesser expected throw Direction
oh tries to wake up with the armor
side switching throw of his own ninja
killer throwing popsy out of the corner
that will absolutely be enough damage
but we we've set up a few things in that
first round one of which being the
crushing blow throw is still locked and
loaded love what foxy attempted though
one of the biggest rubs of the
tournament with a wake up or two attempt
right there
unafraid to put it on the line and I
mean that has been his story in Evo 2023
he wrote the full screen we're ninja
killer
has found home
and this one not the healthy business
favor you see foxy moving forward
now ninja killer does have unbelievable
reactions so I do believe that low and
overhead is something that's going to be
a little bit trickier to enforce in
theory foxy really hesitant on the usage
of the 4-2 as well because you have to
commit to the rising ice he's using it
on stagger so far which is safe on block
gets some hit advantage
and a wake up jump wow we'll get him
going big jumping over so much of that
damage is unbreakable that it's almost
surprising that ninja Killers went for
the break most of the time there I think
it's used to try and shut down oh my
Lord most of the time is used to shut
down building up the KB
that's only a second M5 slide for this
one I think so far too
Foxy's dwindling unhealth that forward
walk of sub-zeroes are looking kind of
nasty
as he needs to close the gap ninja
killer every single person he's fought
everyone has seen him just fly away full
screen at some point in the match that
won't be the KP what button did he press
5.98 the update oh there we go
Sub-Zero rubber in its purest form
forward two now that's not gonna kill
he's still alive
he was very literally was shaking his
head he was like I can't believe I just
did that nowhere before we even went
away ninja killer with the largest smile
on his face after being able to get away
with that one but look I mean it was a
scary situation and hard dedicated to an
option I absolutely respect it on both
sides that's going to give us one game
each right now
may as well be in the best of three from
this point because only a few games left
and again to remind everyone this is
about the last Defender we're looking
for the last Defender from the twins
who have just been terrorizing these
events for two years and this is gonna
be the last big Champion for Mortal
Kombat 11 guys with MK1 releasing later
this year and has been playable here at
Evo shout out to Evo for having so many
booths of so many games this is one
massive fighting game event it feels so
it feels so complete this year oh it
really does
couldn't agree more reversal punish
throw Escape there from Ninja killer
says do not throw me good sir
no answer foxy just kind of froze in
there which ended up being a blessing
because ninja will sometimes do all
those Mobility things to try to get a
button out of you wow bam in and out a
throw before you know it we're back to
full screen
fujin giving you such freedom
to really do whatever you want whenever
you want and in the hands of ninja
killer you see what it's capable of
no further
defensive Fusion style of play because
yeah the wind push on its own doesn't do
any damage but it is the speed and the
fact that it's just so instant on
Startup you can't do anything at range
and all it does is waste the clock we've
got 15 seconds left to go and ninja
colors in the lead in the two other big
fugits that we see in this bracket have
a completely different play style really
all fusions across the world oh my God
and only time for foxy did forward four
and ninja killer was ready for the
instant with punish before the move even
came out before it even became active he
was punished I said a performer say it
again I think ninja killer might be a
framework man oh frame Walker I think he
just lives in slow motion it does only
explanations he sees the frames as they
happen guys it's the only explanation we
have
other than that he's a robot
could be could be now now this is
looking real good for Ninja killer so
far the KB's been landed about 40 damage
not too shabby and just importantly
range just hanging out in a safe Zone
which is full screen just goes to full
screen on the other side no big deal
just another day at the office just a
playground for a fujin really
is this game
to see a character that doesn't have to
simply try and Chase fujin now what is
kind of hurting up here is that ninja
not having to worry about Amplified ice
ball everything kind of becomes
reactionary here at full screen for him
and this is not someone that you want to
test any type of reactions with
whoa
almost almost
is another word but didn't
and that's great for Ninja killer
because again look damage isn't being
dealt but I'll tell you what is going
the clock 25 seconds to go
never ever seen people leaning out
people with this fuge in 20 seconds
for foxy to get something on the board
and he's gonna use that to build the
screen and kill more time
ninja is ruthless in this one I gotta
say as well doing this against Sub-Zero
is bold because he is so known for being
unpredictable oh and that's it the
timeout has been the worst enemy in this
matchup that was the first time he got
hit
you told me he went 96 seconds without
getting touched
foxy has to make a choice here Aquaman I
now can only pick one character and it
has to be one that can keep up with
fujin does foxy have anyone that can do
that
katana
we haven't seen this in an age
real calm and collected from Ninja
killer who think about the half floods
following the assignment you know
sticking true to that game plan
I think uses half Bloodstone slow fan
yep
the classic here going to the princess
Foxy's Last Chance otherwise he'll be
out of Evo 2023. fight
had a good start at the beginning you're
getting that first game for Sub-Zero but
the moment ninja killer has been able to
just get that defensive play on lockdown
it's been a very very different story
and now ninja killer going in rushing it
down and now the ninja knows that he has
that low fan that's going to be
contesting on full screen immediately
maybe more of an aggressive game plan
coming in
the katana is something I haven't seen
recorded with long but was one of the
characters that assisted that top
performance last year at Evo for the
same game so
katana's looking pretty good so far the
Half Blood stance combination of
projectiles tracking projectiles dive
kicks the low fan of course for the
zoning application you'll be reactionary
with a full screen teleport
play some Mind Games right there
solids up
no entire attempts Ginger just staggers
and this could be the round
all right very well could be this is the
spot that we see it be pretty close it's
a simple one two
oh you know it for sure that's gonna be
enough and ninja killer is on Match
Point for stage one of what could be one
of the most legendary ones that runs
we've seen you would get his run back
from the start of this top six
knock down
just throwing fans right now one pack to
find smart
no big damage keeping it simple as
nintending it early as boxing get the
Breakaway
which is close to build the space
tries to punish that whip throw but just
a little bit too far away to get
anything from it
to respect that back one ninja killer
bit by bit moving foxy into the corner
and now
things got a little bit scary Square
wave did he get the punish
irritates of his own medicine right
there and the the side was through the
silver Hero fujin on that one the hair
on his Jin Egyptian
now these trades are gonna pay for
Katana even the startup of the fan is
good enough
you see the detector from them together
short off the low fan
a lot of us content we're just blocking
it even the Flawless block taking away
the chip
he's optimal in how he deals with zoning
blocking versus not blocking with the
crouching block he's got knocked down
again
rather scary situation here
just about 13 Health remaining 10
seconds on the clock the timeout rears
its head for another time here ninja
killer punishes the square wave and Foxy
just did not have an answer for that
defensive runaway Fusion starter Place
well done foxy another top four
performance at Evo guys Round of
Applause that man The Legend going back
to the beginnings of our competitive
Community here the modern competitive
Community though as it were for Mortal
Kombat 11 Foxy's attendance record for
Evo top finishes is one of the more
consistent in the entire scene might
actually be the most consistent next to
a couple of players uh but overall that
was just a strict game plan from the
fujin was in and out take your damage
where you can get it but when we have
the neutral we Retreat we back dash we
make it a nightmare to chase down and
Foxy did not have an answer for that at
all this is something I'm seeing for one
of the first times too you know on a
consistent basis is the more lame fujin
and it's super effective it's it's the
the slowest most defensive fujin play I
have ever seen which is not something
you would think from someone that we
know as being one of the most aggressive
crazy rushed down players uh of olden
days I guess but complete all-around
players ninja killer coming to this for
sure well
stage one of the process is complete
ninja killer has been able to become the
last North American standing here and
I'm sure the crowd's going to be able to
give that energy to him as we go into
the next set of matches right through
the crowd given the spirit energy he's
gonna need it you're gonna have to do it
now and you're gonna basically have to
do it for the rest of it because ninja
killer is going to have to do what no
player has done yet which has beat both
of them back to back you said it
yourself three times one in losers
finals and then you have to reset the
bracket and then win again if ninja
killer can do that the greatest yeah
like Undisputed the greatest MK 11
player of all time
but it's going to be the hardest thing
this is the this is this is the Mount
Everest to climb now
love it that's what it's all about
that's what Evo's all about at the end
of the day that's what we're here for
but I tell you what we're going to go to
a short break for another time I want to
thank you all so much for tuning in and
shortly Mortal Kombat we'll be back
at Chipotle real food always starts with
real ingredients in real kitchens when
you order Chipotle real food starts with
you whether it's in restaurant pickup or
delivery however you Chipotle is the
easiest way to Chipotle
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up everyone we attendo are
Beyond excited to announce the launch of
some brand new merchandise for Evo
beginning with our new officially
licensed Street Fighter designs which
include premium embroidered hoodies and
more also we have new officially
licensed designs for the King of
Fighters 15 Guilty Gear Tekken and other
fgc partners each tenno product is
carefully designed by fgc heads with
only the best material for maximum
comfort and style trust me you don't
want to wait to cop these
yeah
and welcome back everyone Mortal Kombat
11 losers finals is going down this is
going to be the biggest storyline right
now in Mortal Kombat ninja Killer versus
the twins for the world championship
here at Evo
the reality is if you want to support
ninja killer and give that local crowd
energy
you have to do it right now because we
might be running out of time we want to
hear it we can hear you in the back Make
some noise what are y'all liking this
one look we can hear you back here but I
still don't think you're loud enough
Make Some Noise this is Mortal Kombat
files we're sending Mortal Kombat 11 up
with a pain
and there's only a few more matches left
to go Aquaman
it makes me almost sad it's almost over
you couldn't ask for a more beautiful
and we have the global Mortal Kombat
Community here and guess what everyone
else gets to do hold that [__] baby
because we're here
Evo is an absolute once in a lot like a
lifetime opportunity for so many players
I know I've spoken to so many players
this weekend that have said that this is
their first event this is their first
offline not even their first Evo this is
just their first event period and it's
an eye-opener for so many players right
you get to see so many communities so
many different games
ultimately when everything finishes up
to this point here there's just so much
passion there with all the players
and it's moments that will stick with
people for the rest of their lives
it sounds to me like we're going in with
another fujin mirror and I'll tell you
what we were talking about this to each
other during the break we could see
nothing but fujin for the rest of this
tournament so uh just saying get
yourself ready for it maybe
maybe some turbine action that's what we
like to call it is gone
that's against scorpion prox took it in
a close one on the winner side 3-1 I'm
here to warn in this mirror
and create a paradox that endangers us
both
ninja looking for the Vengeance looking
to begin his Ascent of Mount Everest
taking on the twins
pressed it goes to props
scorpion props has been able to do more
than Score first blood at the moment but
half of that life was already dealt with
Ninja killer kind of struggling to deal
with that Advance oh but never mind the
down two starts things off and we
instantly jump one into a side switch
that's 40 done and dusted and we can
start to mount our offense into even
more that's one way to catch up on their
health says on hand me enough forward
three lingered out there to meet him on
wake up
he's gonna build that space again not
gonna be able to lame out fujin in this
one though that's a character that can
contest you with all your own
shenanigans
I was about to jump in I'm still gonna
take her to those frames
only needs it to build the space though
no punishes
more safety and there's one way to
change things up
there was a time earlier when they
played where no one got hit for about 40
seconds on the clock so
strap yourselves in guys
right we're only just getting started
round one scorpion procs
having the mirror match of the fusions I
mean we saw ninja Killer versus foxy
just moments before and how about
backwards movement was such a nightmare
to deal with the second you had a mirror
Match Into The Fray it's a different
story entirely we can chase each other
we can land all the hits we need to and
it becomes a uh pretty interesting match
if you ask me but scorpion prox still
looking good here on the verge of taking
this first game looking pretty
comfortable if I say so myself Aquaman
what a what a difference in the way that
he's using his wave Dash pressure he's
using a lot of throws that's really
catching the job guard early
well he's got plenty resource now he did
that tank is looking awful full up there
it's good fatal blow four bars in the
bottom left
plenty of time to work with dashes right
up into some buttons though that
scorpion box needs the one almost meets
him with the KB killer
that would have narrowly
narrowly brought him into a situation to
move on here but oh the walking to grab
Escape failed
are we gonna see an attempt at a throw
here the crushing blow throw could in
theory win this round
oh he lets it Go and the punish such a
smart choice such a smart choice if you
throw someone in this game as a punish
they cannot Tech it meant the crushing
blow was guaranteed to win there
the smarter situation save the resources
and that's why easier putting for the
world championship ninja killer stays
alive in this one
this has been a fight to the death they
got the claws out and everything nothing
being held back from these competitors
today trying to take the wind out of
each other's breaths
to the corner we go
creating a cyclone with himself is this
character taking you from coast to coast
winning that range War just slightly
here
spend a lot of meter to do so though so
ninja killer with that extra bar of
offensive spending it on the ex push
back into the favor of Scorpion procs
now the Flawless blocked on the down one
side switching through we've got to take
damage anywhere we can get it at this
point Breakaway forced away and another
throw to connect that is opportunity for
Ninja killer to take the lead
I need help he's the first time I saw
him get the knock down and do nothing he
sat back and waited
it's a push here gets box a little time
to build some space and he does four
threes here in the movement Since You
Can Dance all you want but I'm coming in
hot and that was before it even ended a
quick restart from scorpion proximity
hesitation and I hear the crowd getting
a little antsy out there oh you can feel
it until it takes any kind of bleed here
that crowd gets excited because look
we're in America baby that's what it's
all about it is the most serious move
that we've seen ninja's face to I
haven't seen him blink or move in the
last 10 minutes this got serious
job is not done even if ninja killer
defeats scorpion procs the job is still
not done
all right I knocked down here for
Scorpio procs
scars to push forward but you know it's
got to be a fine line between knowing
when to go in yourself and kind of wait
for your opponent to try and advance in
the fujin mirror you can be in and out
in the blink of an eye that's true and
so many hits are kind of just raw hits
off of putting a button out half screen
and hitting someone wave dashing in yeah
there's been a lot of conventional
punishes in that regard
ninja Killer's gonna turn that in oh
drops the down one
and that is why those combos are a bit
trickier not necessarily because of the
execution but if you drop them you're
pretty punishable
especially mirror no Rangers see if he
got away with a couple of those spin
kicks earlier full screen
wow what what what what what what
I have never seen an instant jump into
land in a car mode ever I've never seen
that punished before ladies and
gentlemen we just learned something
about this game just now
well ninja Killer's looking really good
in this second round to say the least
we're gaming throw text very rarely a
throws hitting their Mark here that's
the reaction and the understanding of
which direction it's going to be it's
just way too on point at this level of
competition
did you let go of that block for a
slight second
was met by the suck of the back too
reach the wake up okay he's gonna be a
big damage and this might be it for the
round scorpion prox
I feel like it's not gonna be enough to
kill because there were a few hits to
scale in But Here Comes The Sword of a
thousand truth
not enough
ninja killer has a fatal blow of his own
you just can't get hit by a single push
here
spoke too soon because that's exactly
what happened one game each
and we simply continue the Fusion mirror
once again
killer knocks down to start things off
Quicken oh my goodness the response
respect that [__] but the immediate it's
almost like a ninja killer wow
the momentum stealer of a Flawless block
has led to all of this 60 of your health
God
and a health lead
with punished
press it but what the hell was that that
was some big old guaranteed damage
to be fair scorpion Brooks didn't have
Breakaway so we're gonna absolutely look
for the highest amount of damage there
and was that damage if that was
something
to a simple
have a nice day Flawless plug on a jump
in so many things that you can do after
all the smallest blocks and he's been
throwing them a lot he's been doing down
four a lot
oh expecting some kind of grab or
something else either way that back one
completely opened up Scorpio Brooks
ninja killer forced back to the mid
screen another dancing another dance out
and a whiff punishing in front of him
a whip punish 2.0 3.0 I'm losing count
of the stage
no he decided to Simply pressure jump
kick anyway
still giving some respect with how late
it was that there could have been some
frames there against them really smart
with robots now go unpleased
that whip throw could have been a lot
more disastrous than it was it's gonna
mean that ninja killer is still alive in
this round and with fatal blow logged in
not to mention two full bars of
offensive meter there is a chance to do
something now sadly the Breakaway has
just been taken away there goes the
defensive bar
gets the punish up close on the win push
available in play
ninja killer I'm gonna try to close the
gap here get a Rob with fatal blow
punish unbelievable fatal blow just
became a lot scarier that's a punish
what just happened the crowd has erupted
a ninja killer The Smiler comes out he
might not be a robot after all this time
you can be a stone-faced as you want but
the moment this crowd starts to back
here it hits different but the job is
not done this set is still going 2-1 for
Ninja killer right now
and Scorpion prox is not easily shaken
but you will be
a sandwich I might be after that one
Dusty oh
the black one you think
you thin
micro duck breaks the armor we're going
to the corner
he's a nice and safe
but ninja once he got his turn build the
space back you gotta love that
eating a couple and two not the most
damage though trying to steal him on
wake up and oh no ninja falling apart
with the back to the corner Fox is back
on the board try to go for a brave
wake-up option right you're getting
overwhelmed like that you just straight
up do buttons on wake up would have been
a god-like read how it works but
all right down two down one point kick
give me that 28 thank you very much can
I have the corner please
the scoring proxies can use to get out
no
she's safe coming in he's going out
where are you going where are you going
unbelievable call out
and and in this mirror in particular the
only option you have to chase that man
down is do it yourself
that is certainly one way to tackle it
but now ninja killer
that he taken all the momentum here
comes another one that back one mid oh
so delicious now the Scorpion prox's
turn to keep Wayne dashing into some
stuff that ninja killer making the right
reads
down two down one lands it's Mark and
that will take the round ninja killer
Match Point here versus scorpion props
to start the three-piece Journey gets
the first hit here two and wait on a
second no defensive bar to worry about
he's gonna have specific damage yes he
failed and hold on the crowd starting to
feel it here get there jumping get
killer going crazy right now on the
verge of a Flawless Victory and looking
for it at the air and the grab the throw
Escape scorpion Brooks keeping himself
in this game but a with punish and there
we go with a down two end it is so close
to putting ninja killer into Grand
finals Aquaman yes can he do it
it and he will upset Scorpio Fox you're
defending evil Champion as Stalin
use the crowd is on their feet they know
what is happening here and this
tournament isn't even finished the USA
chance come out go on you've earned it
you have earned it
but I can't believe it's gonna say it we
haven't even started Grand finals yet
can we imagine this crowd and the chance
to follow if USA does in fact take the
title back
where it has been for so many where it
has been forces every year except for
one we've been able to defend our game
the one made here in America ketchup
we've been able to I understand I
understand we've tried we tried our best
for many many years we tried our best
and many medals were earned in the
process
it's all about that number one you know
people remember above all else people
remember the Evo Champions and with two
players left in the running that being
cool
ninja killer making it into Grand finals
here is
Monumental because of what it could mean
if he wins however
however Nicholas is lying in weight
Nicholas
has the extra comfort zone
[Music]
of the Winner's bracket and is the only
one of the two
to defeat ninja killer already today we
had some Hollywood people left we got Ed
Boone shout outs to netherrealm Studios
of course watching about one watching
this week epic unfold before our eyes
it's no mystery
what
player this crowd is supporting the most
but I tell you what I tell you what
for the sake of it being Evo and for
there being so many of you wonderful
people in the crowd
it's about to be grand finals ninja
Killer versus Nicholas
if you want to see Ninja killer take it
all the way
make some goddamn noise
[Applause]
they're making some noise right now and
if you want Nicolas to take it make some
noise
I hear some noise for Nicolas out there
hold on they want to see the Young Gun
there is South America In This Crowd no
matter what we have a new Evo Champion
for Mortal Kombat love it love it
and I'm gonna love this Grand finals
even more
the final tournament for Mortal Kombat
11. as we usher in a new chapter of
Mortal Kombat history
we're just getting past this button
check and the insanity begins
mirror once more that again Nicolas has
shown that he is capable of taking it
against Ninja or will ninja just answer
the challenge like he is known to do
and go right back to work the warm-up's
already there against his brother he
needs to beat him twice
coming from the lower bracket if you
guys don't understand watching at home
if you're on the Winner's side everyone
technically has two lives
and since he has not lost at all he's
still in the winter side in order to be
limited from this tournament you have to
lose twice so we still got that second
life to his name he has to beat him
twice to eliminate him from this
tournament now I must say
Nicholas and Scorpion props they've
historically been able to show that they
can deal with the pressure that the
crowd puts onto them the pressure that
the people at home put on them the
demand for them to constantly perform
this is pressure unlike anything else if
Nicholas can win this tournament it is
going to be pure Insanity however we're
gonna get this Grand finals on the road
here Nicholas versus ninja killer
another fujin mirror but at this point
it's all about the players yes it is
here we go
wind push is already in effect Flawless
blocks already in effect here we go the
programs
are fighting right now this is the dawn
of the AI before our eyes now catch up
we are up to a wonderful start if you're
a ninja killer fan the Flawless flop on
the jump in shut down that chip damage
shut down some of those frames
and now he's got the health lead looking
to play more of that full screen zone
game and there we go challenge the
meaning by Nicolas With the Wind push
and he's using that to close the gap
bold it was that four throw out of the
corner
but bold is what he's gonna need here to
bring this back
oh
I was very nervous when I saw a whiffed
button within back one Ranger tell you
that much
ninja just chipping at Nicolas
now you'll notice in this Grand finals
you know to really reflect to really
reflect the similarities of the Chilean
twins having gameplay
you would be forgiven for thinking we
were still in losers finals with the
characters the matchups how everything's
unfolding unfortunately he goes into the
flying kick what are we doing are we
going everywhere this is the Ninja
killer special catch me if you can
and it'll take round number one here not
building meter he was doing that for
almost no reason other than that it hit
him trying to approach ninja killer
looking might be comfortable to get
started here in Grand finals if you're
playing patiently and earning a timeout
in the first round of grand finals you
are mentally ready for anything I would
say last thing I was mentally ready for
it in this top six we're a timeouts
catch-up and
and not in the traditional sense either
no no
damage
It's a Wonderful spot
that's a big mind game that they're
playing too is when they're doing that
jump kick if you try to meet him because
of the Flawless blocks because the
anti-airs
yep anti-air low folks don't forget
fujin's one's pretty damn good all
things considered the punish the flying
kick in the air and just a little bit
more to do it Nicholas on the verge of
tying things up no defensive bar could
do anything right now
dive kicks him for a round of peace
but make no mistake this Series has only
just begun we haven't even finished the
first match yet
and now the Flawless blocks so many of
them the release block text just in case
there was some kind of jumping Nicholas
going in with the grab listen to time
it's going to be successful rare footage
of the grounds actually working full
combo now and the Flying Kicks just in
case there was a break attempt
what safety here so far some hit
Advantage instead of jail goes for the
throw
good quick pick nice ninja expected a
wake up slight hesitation
is it back though and now Nicholas says
here it's time for you to deal with the
corner buckle
oh tries to chase it down in this case
the punish on the dive kick and the 114
crushing blow to follow as well it's
going to be a guaranteed displaying kick
a little bit of Health left at the tank
for Nicholas but it ain't much and it's
not enough to survive game one right
there on game one goes to USA
two more did it just to reset this the
crowd going crazy they can feel it the
energy
seen in this building right now that is
hosting I don't know near fifteen
thousand twenty thousand people at this
point
I'm gonna take a bold prediction and say
quite a few
as far as I'm gonna go on that one hope
you guys here are enjoying even open
everyone watching at home isn't doing
this evil as this is the first top six
two kickoff Evo
and it's been magic Nicholas looking to
obtain a full combo there with a
breakaway from Ninja killer to shut it
down
looking for a short hop it's hard to say
most of the time like some kind of
flawless blocks you never really know
either way Nicholas another full combo
good to go
ninja getting up in the back one range
getting out of the range love those
dances
there we go again in this case the back
two catches Nicholas pressing something
and now the aggressive back one the
reverse throw throws are so scary
because at this range it could really be
anywhere that back two surely must have
been some kind of follow-up
and one of the slower buttons to be
reacting in anti-airing with again more
impressive from Ninja killer of anyone
I've seen in this uh brilliantess
tournament and entering with so many
different things his reactions on
another level sometimes we'll see if the
twins can match it got taken from him to
full screen this is where ninja wants
you Nicholas has fatal blow but I'm
looking at the fact that there's 10
seconds eight seconds on the clock the
pickup doesn't Let It Rock
three two one
and another timeout for Ninja killer he
is grinding or down his opponents I've
never seen this type of gameplay
implemented in Mortal Kombat like this I
have never seen a player grinder match
to a halt this extremely but clearly
it's a strategy that is working in a
great amount because right now it's got
me to Grand finals it's looking real
good versus Nicholas so far Flawless
plug get out of here defense wins
championships and ninja killers and
looking mighty Championship caliber
today
Nico lost the execution
the down two as well for the bigger
damage every drop giving ninja killer
the momentum and he's riding it right
now
wake up buttons no counter hit though
tries to whisper the up three but no one
home only a little bit of work left to
go to make it a 2-0 however
fatal blow as well that's gonna hurt and
it is gonna set up a position where if
Nicholas can land a clean hit without
breaker
can win the round on it
what's gonna be hashtag has it goes
assistance right and oh no
needs a miracle that Breakaway gonna be
a hindrance if you could find the hit
needed at least two reads I think in
that situation and not ninja killer wait
a second what a different story that's
unfolding before our eyes it came away
from a reset and more importantly some
mighty huge momentum
let's look at how this is going so far
ninja killer one game away from
resetting this bracket I'm bringing us
into a final three out of five and if I
do say so the way that first round
started is pretty good
ninja killer once more
being the less aggressor
in this matchup full screen Nicolas
doesn't know what to do and even when
he's turbining unable to answer the
turbines himself he doesn't know how to
chase those down get the punishes get
away with so much Mobility as ninja
killing this matchup in comparison to
the one prior
more of that patience looking for a trip
guard in that back one somebody jumps
too far away you win punish it back one
easy money but
wow
they both have the same idea there
pushing them to stay away from me I stay
away from until I get meter that's what
he's thinking of his mind
now he's got the bar
can't find any time in four or three at
any time
both can rob here on kill
4-3 turbine down two hits hang on a
minute soaked up a norm a poke it look
like there speaking of that down four
oh
however never mind actually ninja killer
on the verge of yet another timeout but
isn't gonna need it
everybody in the crowd everybody at home
a reset point is obtained here for Ninja
killer one more round and we're starting
again it's starting to scare me because
negle also started to play Ninja
Killer's game this entire time playing
this the flyaways none have gone
punished
to drastically different style to what
Nicholas has been bringing to the table
Nicholas has been a bit more fundamental
a bit more aggressive ninja Killer's
plan has been frustrates you annoy you
to the point of making a mistake
California nice empty job by Nicolas
punishing the defense capabilities of
next kill as well
hit that is another clean hit Miss
tracker man one more of those there is
no breaker for Nicholas at the moment
was one loses some pressure there's a
little bit gonna put out there probably
wanted the whole string
all right Nicholas has fatal blow let us
not forget that rather important Detail
no meter for Ninjago right now
it ain't got the implication but it
drops still alive by one HPS ninja
killer he is going to reset this three
two zero everyone behind him is standing
right now if you want to look at the
cleanest example of momentum look no
further than ninja killer right now the
entire crowd on his back no doubt people
at home the many fans around the world
for Ninja killer wanting to see him
succeed a 3-0 to reset
I am very worried for Nicholas at this
point you've got to block all of this
out but how can you this is this is a
hard reset here because how much mental
damage has already been done can it be
undone at this point
one final set is gonna decide who is the
final champion of Mortal Kombat 11
Evolution 2023 one more series and two
players left to go I guess we'll get
this final show on the road as ninja
killer starts off strong and a grab for
good measure Aquaman as I get started
post reset now all of a sudden this is
completely even zero zero and you got
the help lead early on and a beautiful
beautifully uh almost full screen with
one is there with the back too full
screen puts he's gonna talk about enough
in this matchup but they exist oh
absolutely
another catch and another full combo
this is looking all ninja killer right
now
as well the stylist stuff this is uh
that's why guys so they're sweeping
ninja killer takes another round that
crowd getting louder and louder as this
progresses
towards its epic conclusion no matter
how it's sliced and a nice answer from
Nicolas to get a little bit of something
a little bit of a breather a flower spot
to get your foot in the door post reset
wow a whole lot of nothing
a whole lot of respect going on between
the two there
interrupts the fourth through the one to
the mid can't out enough in time to stop
it
now Nicholas starting to fight back and
for his sake really does need these kind
of rounds dominant rounds taking very
little damage in return you need to just
continue to cement to yourself that it
could be close if ninja killer won that
first game dominantly I would have been
terrified for Nicholas but for
Nicholas's sake taking the ground like
that all right we're back in business
yeah I like how you're seeing the
quicker rounds here post reset from both
of them a lot of aggression from Ninja
early on that was a very aggressive
round from Nicholas if you can keep it
going
that's gonna be the name of the game for
Nicolas to make this comeback he has to
close the gap on ninja kill he has to
keep that pressure on with punishment
he's got to start punishing some
turbines
back to the mid screen we go does not
really seem like a particularly
corner-oriented matchup to be honest
with you
look at a jump out of the corner here
ninja killer trying to challenge it back
to back there goes the launch into a
full combo Nicholas the Fatal blow has
been activated but with Ninja killer
having even a bar of meter opts not to
spend it
will find a hit
all right Nicholas fighting back and a
face away
coming off early really had two options
right there score the knockdown do some
kind of uh movement Shenanigans go for a
reset and try to steal with the Fatal
blow or put it down to here to one but
you gave him his fatal blow
Ninja
a fatal blow Nicolas a combo from
getting this post reset started right
away look it away with another one
unpunished not ready for the full grip
we mustn't forget the ninja killer does
have a fatal blow off his own so
anything on the ground into that is
guaranteed and it will lead to the end
of the game however the wind push him
return Nicholas this is for all the
momentum post reset
would a tectonic shift this would be if
he's able to do it but he only got the
string
at 22.2 help
ing early are you kidding me he just
beated him hook line and sinter full
screen with a turbine put it early and
send him a watch to whip and thank you
for the win how was he ready for that
how was he ready for the Aquaman that's
another level right there that's the
level I can't comprehend anymore
I cannot believe it he's put one game to
zero in this post reset Grand finals
Nicholas still alive though and still
fighting back but a neutral jump from
Ninja killer to more than equalize that
damage
little buttons are finding their Mark
now he's feeling it uh-oh Nico lost the
defense phone apart
the delayed back to what good blocks
there from Nicholas though most players
would have been so convinced the throw
was coming
watch out on those forward threes no
ninja killer has been punishing those
all series long tries to trip guard with
the back one Nicholas quite rightly with
the empty jump to stay safe
4-3
it's a drop of pressure still on
the one who does get the punch time
around it's a little bit of damage
interrupts the wave Dash attempts
as well so it will be a straight punish
and the back one is more than good for
Ninja killer who takes another round
here in game two
it felt like Nicolas activated ninja
Killer's trap card right there chased
him down and it's exactly what he wanted
even out space them afterwards
tried to go for the unbreakable there
sadly got punished for his troubles but
wasn't as much damage as what could have
been in various other situations so
honestly I think he'll take that another
throw to add to the mix-up and make it
even scarier the more grabs that land
the scarier that back one becomes
this time using that blood pressure to
push him away could have ended the back
one one early keep the distance another
one down two down one into the pickup
big damage Aquaman this is the throw
Nicolas gonna punch for a little bit
more maybe
51 240. beautiful KP now Nicolas
knocking on the door no Breakaway for
Ninja killing us can be it and the
rounds secured nicolasi is alive he is
refusing to give up and refusing let
ninja kill get too much momentum in this
no no two rounds victories here keeping
your head in the game continuing to play
as good as you have been all tournament
long I mean it's an important strength
to have in a grand final and it's good
that Nicholas is able to keep that in
the tank however ninja killer did not
commit
checking each other
similarities the back one one pushes
tried to call out turbine with turbine
right there put an early cast by Nicolas
saves him that's what that's what got
his brother earlier
more back one pressure
so scary Ninja dashed up in your face
and then he went defensive
oh whips the forward three eats the
crushing blow for it
forces a breakaway looking for a clean
hit another throw ninja killer has been
dedicated to these throws and has been
pretty on the money speaking of which
here comes another one ninja killer had
narrowly taken the lead but Nicholas
with a swift turnaround
Seven health or Sorry Seven damage away
available over Zone
they're trying to snipe each other the
full screen footsies the back twos if
he's gonna wave Dash into that range
however like the original killer has
been given a fatal blow thanks to that
oh
11 seconds
a throw from downtown so far away Escape
failed as well the wake up down one that
is so risky
guys reading the throw and he stays
alive in his great final one to one
we're still completely even having eight
seconds on the clock with a fujin that
has escaped failed locked in and you on
the floor to wake up with buttons is
such a risk but it worked
keeps the young Chilean alive here
trying to win his first Evo as well
and now we're turning around
tries to scout out the wake up role but
maybe just a little bit too late
either way ninja killer a large amount
of that momentum has been equalized as
Nicholas is continuing to look good dive
kick meets Skywalker I guess nothing
wins wonderful trade for Nicolas as well
in damage
getting away not getting punished
and you did the turbine away right there
keep himself safe
didn't want to over Dash
I think just trying to poke take a turn
right there
when these guys slightly wait and then
press That's where so many Mind Games
start to occur
because when you're when you fight
people that are good at Flawless
blocking too good to get around that you
know some Unholy things you're gonna do
some crazy timings on your butts that's
what we see a lot in this matchup it
totally messes with the timing of almost
everything that's why I see jumping
delayed something empty jump just walk
up nothing and then something trying to
bait each other on those situations
that's the highest possible level Mortal
Kombat that we're seeing ninja killer
was looking for something and they are
back one for his troubles up forward
three eight seconds on the clock and now
on the verge of being timed out himself
tries to win punishment but trades with
it that was a disaster of a encounter
Nicholas takes the lead in the set
momentum completely halted indeed as his
lead of Evo at the moment if he can hold
on to it debug grass tries to over press
in offense double down one not getting
away with against Ninja killer
that was the spiciest walk under the
jumping that you're gonna see and
something that you unconventionally see
as a great way to deal with Jumpers in
this game
back one ones turbines away
that's been that's been his safe Zone
this whole time
another 4-3 I'm gonna squeeze out as
much percentage as possible because at
this point everything counts we're split
right down the middle once again
as ninja killer pushes forward with more
of that back one pressure make that two
but he's got the position but that man
just shook himself into the corner if I
turned Nicolas
maybe sometimes matter when you can
simply turbine your way to wherever and
whenever you want to be in this matchup
there it is that slight weight and then
back 1-1 opening up Nikolas that's
hesitating oh that's unfortunate though
a lot of damage was left on the table
and then you're swiftly interrupted by
it down two out of nowhere
40 of some mean damage from the wing god
to kill they're not empty jumping this
time around trying to open up Nikolas
which is a straight jump kick that's a
mistake away if I've ever seen one that
is huge for Ninja killer if he can
capitalize forcing Nicholas to
accidentally break away in that position
and now there's no breaker we can
squeeze out every ounce no the combo
drop that was your opportunity
the first gift given by Ninja killer in
this Grand finals perhaps and can he can
he pounce can Nicolas take this
opportunity to close
and Nicholas knows that a fatal blow is
in his future if he gets opened up so
he's gonna have to be so careful here
ninja using the fear of the Fatal blow
to get the throne needs another one
and this takes the lead
it came down to one Cliff Fighters one
with opportunity
slide from Ninja killer now one away for
Nicolas crowd still feeling the
background none out of it quite yet an
unfortunate we're pulling that forward
three it must be said
Catalyst to Nicholas taking the lead in
this series
I gotta say it to the crowd you want
Ninja killer to get the job done you're
gonna have to show some more support
than that
he's gonna need the energy now oh we
hear him they're getting loud out there
[Applause]
it's a chance to turn it around his
ninja killer opens up Nicholas continues
to push on oh nearly with punishes but
not quite and you heard the sound of
beautiful music here in mk11 the
Flawless block Flawless blocked back to
back
two notes I hope to hear before I die
which is which is
definitely expected some kind of maybe
an amplify on the dive kick right there
looks for the 4-3 again tries to
anti-year a full combo and this should
be the round ninja killer end things and
takes it one round up here
[Applause]
he heard the crowd on that one he
thought your energy
you can use it take another round that
forward throw off wave Dash catch you at
such a range unexpected
empty Jump Ninja killer has done an
awful lot of flaws attack attempts on
jumping
ugly lovely pick up there from Ninja
killer and it's looking like
a different player in this matchup so
clean the crushing blow on the win push
as well looks to win punishment but no
walks right into the backward Daddy was
going to know something that simply
wasn't limbo in the back one one but
he's been playing this game this entire
round
and that is gonna be a turnaround and
just like that
one more match
either side to cement our champion for
emo 2023. so the crowd it's becoming
very real now isn't it it's down to one
digital the 2-2 final game and Evo this
is how we get started in 2023 would not
have it any other way my friend and that
was the most insane in and out I've seen
of the entire tournament that was in out
in that enough six times and still got
the throw to open up ninja killer we're
on layer 92 of MK 11.
get off me
the reverse throw not gonna give up
we're gonna go for even more
lovely anti-air that up to Nicholas
really just reacting to what Ninja
killer has been bringing forward in this
match so far but a back-to-back mid a
chance to equalize the health and bring
ourselves some much needed momentum
the throw again
the guaranteed damage
sit back let ninja killer come to him
now a little bit of the zone game
and now any clean hit the wake up
buttons Nicholas with the riskiest
decision dedicates to it and brings
himself onto Championship point
for everything guys guess the funnest
get started ninja Strike King first
execution there this time around
3 30 he's gonna pick up for a whole lot
more here he's pushing the glass to the
corner trying to dance him into a shimmy
there not falling for it no fall from
the back
crossover down three you'll ever see
into the spins full screen